This is the 99% Invisible Breakdown of The Power Broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elliott Kalin. So today we're still in part six, The Lust for Power, covering chapters 33 and 34, pages 703 to 806 in my book. And later in this episode, our special guest is Shiloh Frederick, born and raised in New York City. Shiloh is a writer and influencer who shares her love of the city's history and architecture on Instagram and TikTok. Last year, she chronicled
这是《无形之恶》（99% Invisible）对《权力掮客》（The Power Broker）的深度剖析。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我是埃利奥特·卡林（Elliott Kalin）。今天我们依然在第六部分“权力的渴望”中，涵盖第33和第34章，在我这本书的第703到第806页。在本集的后半部分，我们的特别嘉宾是希洛·弗雷德里克（Shiloh Frederick），她是一个土生土长的纽约客。希洛是一位作家兼网红，她在Instagram和TikTok上分享她对这座城市历史和建筑的热爱。去年，她记录了
her rather ambitious plan to read The Power Broker in 30 days and her viral videos about her endeavor ended up making some real change to some Moses-designed ornamentation in the city. But before we get to all that, we wanted to announce something very special. On October 7th, Elliot and I are talking with the great Robert Caro live on stage at the New York Historical Society. It's part of the Society's special exhibit dedicated to the 50th anniversary of the Power Broker and I am so incredibly excited. I cannot wait to see this exhibit and I can't wait to talk to Robert Caro live in person. It's a dream come true.
她那个雄心勃勃的计划：在30天内读完《权力掮客》。她在TikTok上发布的关于这一壮举的病毒式视频，最终促成了一些真正的改变——保住了市内一些由莫斯（Moses）设计的装饰。但在我们聊到这些之前，我们想宣布一件非常特别的事情。10月7日，我和埃利奥特将在纽约历史协会（New York Historical Society）的舞台上与伟大的罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Caro）进行现场对话。这是该协会为纪念《权力掮客》出版50周年而举办的特别展览的一部分，我对此感到无比兴奋。我等不及要看这个展览，也迫不及待地想与罗伯特·卡罗进行面对面的现场交谈。这简直是梦想成真。
If it had to happen in front of an audience, I guess that's even better. So there are witnesses that can tell me, yes, that did happen. You and Roman did get to talk face to face with Robert Caro. So be one of those witnesses, be part of that moment. You can go to nyhistory.org to learn more.
如果这必须在观众面前发生，我想那就更好了。这样就会有见证人能告诉我：是的，这确实发生了。你和罗曼真的和罗伯特·卡罗进行了一对一的交谈。所以，去成为那些见证人之一吧，去成为那一刻的一部分。你可以访问 nyhistory.org 了解更多信息。
We'll also put the information on 99pi.org and in the 99pi Discord server. So on the last blockbuster episode of the Powerbroker Breakdown, we covered Robert Moses. He's literally busting blocks. You're not wrong, Roman. He's busting blocks full of people. Robert Moses had successfully gained control of every ingress and egress to the Island of Manhattan. Like if you are in a car and you're trying to get to Manhattan or trying to leave
我们也会把这些信息发布在 99pi.org 以及 99pi 的 Discord 服务器上。所以在上一期关于《权力掮客》剖析的重磅节目中，我们聊到了罗伯特·摩斯。他简直是在大肆拆迁（busting blocks）。你说得没错，罗曼。他拆毁了挤满人的街区。罗伯特·摩斯成功地掌控了通往曼哈顿岛的所有进出通道。比如，如果你开着车想要去曼哈顿，或者想要离开
Manhattan and all future river crossings, you have to pay some toll to Robert Moses. He controls everything. Um, Robert Carr took us through Robert Moses's like turning the public authority into this mutant form that allows him to just have this vast amount of wealth to just keep him going and keep him making new things without having to rely on the fickle public or any politician's approval for anything. He controls so much of the money and Moses nearly succeeds in destroying Battery Park in downtown Manhattan
曼哈顿，以及所有未来的过河交通，你都必须向罗伯特·摩斯支付某种过路费。他掌控了一切。嗯，罗伯特·卡罗带我们了解了罗伯特·摩斯如何将公共机构变成一种畸形形态，这种形态让他拥有了巨额财富，从而能够持续维持运转并不断建造新事物，而不必依赖反复无常的公众或任何政客的批准。他控制了如此之多的资金，而摩斯差点就成功摧毁了曼哈顿市中心的巴特利公园（Battery Park），
with his plans to make it an on-ramp to this enormous bridge to Brooklyn, which the bridge eventually doesn't happen. But it takes the power of the president of the United States to stop him from doing this. But he takes this years long revenge, like decade long revenge of closing New York City's aquarium in place of Fort Clinton.
他的计划是将那里变成一座通往布鲁克林的巨大桥梁的引桥，这座桥最终并没有建成。但这一切需要美国总统的权力来阻止他这样做。然而，他却展开了长达数年、甚至长达十年的报复——关闭了纽约市的水族馆，取而代之的是克林顿堡（Fort Clinton）。
And then he spends a decade trying to tear down the historic fort. Again, it just takes the federal government to stop him. And finally, this last little bit of Moses turning into the thing he hates by lending his support to the Tammany candidate, William O'Dwyer. And in exchange for lending that support, O'Dwyer gives him the post of coordinator of all construction. He's been the enemy of Tammany for his entire life, and now he's this eager ally. He lends his name to support and sort of clean up the image
然后他花了十年时间试图拆毁这座历史悠久的堡垒。同样，只有联邦政府出手才阻止了他。最后，是关于摩斯通过支持坦慕尼协会（Tammany）候选人威廉·奥德怀尔（William O'Dwyer）而变成了自己最痛恨的人这一小段插曲。作为提供这种支持的回报，奥德怀尔给了他建设总协调员的职位。他一生都是坦慕尼协会的敌人，而现在他却成了这个急切的盟友。他用自己的名誉来支持并某种程度上洗白坦慕尼协会候选人的形象。
of the Tammany candidate. And we again visit a old, retired, unwell, former politician in the form of Mayor LaGuardia. And he is talking about how much he regrets giving Moses all of this power. What LaGuardia is really nervous about is that now nobody could keep Moses in check. He thought he was the last bulwark stopping Moses from running roughshod all over the city of New York. So this episode, we're going to be covering chapters 33 and 34.
我们再次拜访了一位年老、退休、身体不适的前政客——拉瓜迪亚市长（Mayor LaGuardia）。他谈到自己多么后悔赋予摩斯如此巨大的权力。拉瓜迪亚真正焦虑的是，现在没有人能制衡摩斯了。他曾以为自己是阻止摩斯在纽约市横行霸道的最后一道防线。所以这一集，我们将探讨第33章和第34章。
We're back to big long chapters again, pages 703 to 806 in my book. We're continuing in the section called The Lust for Power. And this is chapter 33, leading out the regiment. What is going on in chapter 33, Elliot Kaelin? Elliot Kaelin First, Roman, I I just wanna say you did an amazing job of condensing the last episode down really little. And I just wanna say, there should be a podcast called the 99% Invisible Power Broker Breakdown Breakdown
我们又回到了厚重的大章节，我这本书的第703页到第806页。我们继续“权力的渴望”这一部分。这是第33章，题为《率领军团》（Leading out the Regiment）。第33章到底发生了什么，埃利奥特·卡林？埃利奥特·卡林：首先，罗曼，我只想说，你把上一期节目浓缩得非常精简，干得太棒了。我只是想说，应该做一个名为《99%无形之恶：权力掮客剖析的剖析》的播客，
where it's just those sections at the beginning. Just the catch-up section. If you string those together, you could digest this whole book probably in like, I don't know, 15, 20 minutes when the series is over. So keep that in mind for the future, for the Ultra-Bridged Edition. You could digest this whole book probably in like, I don't know, 15, 20 minutes when the series is over. That's right. So, keep that in mind for the future for the Ultra-Bridged Edition. But this chapter, let's get into it.
里面只包含开头的那些部分。也就是回顾部分。如果你把这些串联起来，等这个系列结束时，你大概可以在15、20分钟内消化整本书。所以把这个记在心里，为了将来推出“超级浓缩版”。你大概可以在15、20分钟内消化整本书，当这个系列结束的时候。没错。所以，把这个记在心里，为了将来的“超级浓缩版”。但这一章，让我们深入探讨吧。
This is a long chapter. This is a tough chapter. We're entering probably the hardest part of the book to really get through as a casual reader, because there's a lot of facts, there's a lot of stuff that Caro is reporting to you about the operation of Moses's corrupt network and it gets very dense. And I imagine this is the part where a lot of readers, the power broker, they hit it and they're like, hmm, I think this is where I'm getting off the train or getting out of the car. Yeah. Because you're like, you're just over halfway
这是一个很长的章节。这是一个难啃的章节。作为一个普通读者，我们正在进入全书最难读完的部分，因为这里有大量的事实，有大量卡罗向你汇报的关于摩斯腐败网络运作的细节，内容非常密集。我能想象，许多《权力掮客》的读者读到这里时，都会觉得：嗯，我想我该在这里下车了。是的。因为你刚好看过书的
through the book, and it's like going along. Like you're like, things are happening, the chapters are getting short, you feel like you're accomplishing a lot, another mayor is dead, you're just like, you're like. He's just throwing away mayors, grubbers, they're gone. Forget about them, yeah, shedding them. He's like moving along, and you're just like, hey man, I'm almost halfway done with this book, this is them. Yeah, shedding them. He's like moving along and you're just like,
一半多一点，感觉进展还算顺利。就像你在想，事情正在发生，章节越来越短，你觉得自己完成了很多任务，又一个市长死了，你就像是在。他简直像在抛弃市长，那些家伙，他们消失了。忘掉他们吧，是的，甩掉他们。他就像在不断前进，而你只想说：
hey man, I'm almost halfway done with this book. This is just gonna just sail from here. And then Robert Carr is like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. I'm gonna take you, talk to you about bank finances and where the money corruption like starts and ends. And having read it the third time, I have found it's where it's information fits into this framework. But I do find this one a little bit hard. So you, dear reader, if you're also finding this section
老兄，我这本书快读了一半了。从这里开始应该就是一帆风顺了。然后罗伯特·卡罗就像是在说：哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。我要带你了解银行财务，以及金钱腐败是从哪里开始又在哪里结束的。读了第三遍后，我发现这些信息在这个框架中找到了它们的位置。但我确实觉得这一部分有点难。所以，亲爱的读者，如果你也觉得这一部分有点困难，你并不孤单。
a little difficult, you are not alone. It is a little bit slower. I hope you feel seen. I hope you feel represented. I love this. And this is where, so I like thinking about this book, not just as a work of reporting, but as a work of literature. And this is the chapter where, where that it feels like it tips much more into the reporting part of it. This is information that is essential for people to have on paper somewhere. This is the kind of chapter that someone can use for research for to understand more about the city, but it is not as literature. It's not as readable as say Paul, Paul and his brother, you know? Yeah. I feel like this is a, a, a compendium of page four of the city section of like the
它的节奏确实慢了一点。我希望你觉得自己被看见了。我希望你觉得自己得到了代表。我太喜欢这个了。这就是为什么我喜欢把这本书不仅看作是一部新闻报道作品，而且看作是一部文学作品。而这一章，感觉它更倾向于新闻报道的部分。这些信息是人们必须写在纸上的重要资料。这是那种可以用来进行研究、以便更多地了解这座城市的章节，但它作为文学作品，
newspaper Robert Carrow would have worked at had he not been working at this book. Like it's a series of articles about a certain type of corruption with different names that do not stick quite in my head, with numbers that do not stick in my head. But if you are a real city council follower, a real new, every boss of every sort of ward in various ways, this would be super meaningful to you at the time.
不像保罗和他兄弟的故事那样引人入胜，对吧？我觉得这就像是一份报纸“城市版”第四版的合集，如果罗伯特·卡罗没有写这本书的话，他本该在那样的报纸工作。这就像是一系列关于某种特定腐败的文章，里面有各种各样的名字，但这些名字在我脑海里总是记不太牢，还有那些数字，我也记不住。但如果你是一个真正的市议会关注者、一个真正了解各种各样底层政治大佬的人，在当时，这会对你非常有意义。
And I think it reflects that sort of newspaper reporting. And this is part of it that ages a little bit in the 50 years since this thing was published, but it probably felt really, really just of the moment, like just like urgent and of the moment when he was writing it in this way. This is still living recent history when he's writing this.
而且我认为这反映了那种报纸报道的风格。在这本书出版50年后的今天，这部分内容显得有些年代感了，但当他写作时，它可能给人一种非常、非常契合当下、极其紧迫且具有时代感的感觉。当他写下这些时，这依然是鲜活的近代史。
This is within the past 30, 20 years of when he's writing it, whereas now it is 70 years ago because the book is 50 years old. And so it feels less, although I have to admit, I like to read kind of current event books from a long time ago, and then think about how the people in the book have no idea what's coming.
这是他写作时的过去30、20年内发生的事，而现在已经是70年前了，因为这本书已经出版了50年。所以它感觉不那么贴近当下——尽管我必须承认，我喜欢阅读很久以前的时事类书，然后去想书里的人对即将到来的一切毫无所知。
It's like, you're really obsessed with the Cold War, everybody, but guess what? In 10 years, that's not gonna be an issue. I just got this book on the assassination of William McKinley written in the year he was assassinated. Oh, wow. And it talks about him as like, clearly the greatest American
就像是：每个人都对冷战着迷不已，但你猜怎么着？10年内，这就不再是个问题了。我刚买了一本关于威廉·麦金莱（William McKinley）遇刺的书，就是在他遇刺的那一年写的。哦，天哪。书里把他描述成显然是美国有史以来最伟大的
that we could ever produce, William McKinley. You know, like, and it talks, it's so fascinating, the voice of the moment. It's so cool. Anyway, so let's go back to this book. Where does this start? So this section is about corruption, right? And the chapter starts with a quote
领袖，威廉·麦金莱。你知道的，而且它讨论的方式——这种属于那个时代的嗓音实在太迷人了。太酷了。不管怎样，让我们回到这本书。这一切是从哪里开始的？所以这一部分是关于腐败的，对吧？这一章以一个名言开头，
from a master corruptor, state senator, former Tammany boss, George Washington Plunkett, not a big name these days, but at one point was one of the bosses of New York politics. And he's speaking in 1905, and the point was one of the bosses of New York politics. And he's speaking in 1905, and the quote is about defending the idea of graft and attacking the ingratitude of people who see a problem with politicians making a few dollars off of building wonderful things for New York City. They've done all this great stuff for New York City, why is it so wrong that they get
来自一个腐败大师、州参议员、前坦慕尼协会大佬乔治·华盛顿·普朗基特（George Washington Plunkett）。现在他已经不是什么大人物了，但在当年，他是纽约政坛的大佬之一。他是1905年发表这番言论的，当时他是在为贪污（graft）的想法进行辩护，并抨击那些对政客为纽约市建设伟大工程顺便捞点小钱感到不满的人的忘恩负义。他们为纽约市做了这么多伟大的事情，为什么他们从中获得一点好处就是那么错的呢？
a little taste of it? And that is setting the tone for the whole chapter where Caro is going to be drawing a direct parallel between the Moses of the 1940s and 1950s and the Tammany men of 40, 50 years earlier that he was disgusted by when he was a young reformer at the turn of the century. And this is also one of a series of chapters where Karo is even more leaving kind of the straight overall chronology of the book. So we're going to be jumping around in time a little bit. This is one's more about concepts
这就为整章定下了基调。卡罗将在1940和1950年代的摩斯与40、50年前那些令他在世纪之交担任年轻改革者时感到厌恶的坦慕尼协会成员之间画上直接的等号。这也是一系列章节中的一篇，在这些章节中，卡罗甚至进一步脱离了全书直截了当的整体时间线。所以我们会稍微在时间中跳跃一下。这一章更多的是关于概念，而不是直截了当的时间线。
than about straightforward timelines. So we know Moses, he's in the past, he's used his power with the state government to compel the city government to do what he wants. But after World War II, he's got an even bigger lever to use to push the city. And that is even more federal financing. After World War II, America wants to build.
所以我们知道摩斯，他身处过去，他利用自己对州政府的权力来迫使市政府按照他的意愿行事。但二战后，他有了更大的杠杆来推动这座城市。那就是更多的联邦财政资金。二战后，美国渴望建设。
It wants to build houses, it wants to build roads. Building was effectively paused during the war because everything was going towards defeating the Nazis, a valid goal. I think we can all agree, a worthy thing to stop building for for a few years. But now the federal government is like, we're the most powerful country in the world. We want to build. Let's do it. We're going to spend all this money. And Moses is so brilliant at drafting laws and so brilliant using the system that he is going to maneuver it so that this money goes directly through his office between the city and the federal government. And so as Roman mentioned, Mayor O'Dwyer, he had promised to make Moses the city construction coordinator, a job that
它想要建造房屋，想要建造道路。在战争期间，建设实际上暂停了，因为一切资源都用于打败纳粹——这是一个正当的目标。我想我们都会同意，为了一个值得的目标暂停建设几年是完全合理的。但现在联邦政府的态度是：我们是世界上最强大的国家。我们想要建设。让我们大干一场吧。我们要花掉所有这些钱。而摩斯在起草法律和利用体制方面是如此精明，以至于他将进行一番运作，让这些资金直接通过他在市政府和联邦政府之间的办公室下拨。正如罗曼提到的，奥德怀尔市长曾承诺让摩斯担任纽约市的建设总协调员，这是一个在纽约市乃至任何城市的历史上从未存在过的职位——也许吧，也许在巴黎，那是谁来着，奥斯曼男爵（Haussmann），也许那就是他的角色。我不认为他甚至拥有那么大的权力，但确实如此，完全是这样。
has never existed before in the history of New York or maybe any city, I don't know, maybe in Paris, what was it, Houseman, maybe that was his role. I don't think he even had that much power, but yeah, totally. Oh, this is, and O'Dwyer is like, this is just an administrative role, it's not a policymaking role, you will have authority to oversee all construction-related departments of the government temporarily, and you will still be subordinate to elected officials." And Moses is like, that's great. But when he writes the law creating the post, he pulls a little of his old magic again.
哦，这就是，而奥德怀尔的想法是：这只是一个行政角色，不是一个决策角色，你将暂时获得监督政府所有与建设相关部门的权力，并且你仍然要听命于民选官员。”而摩斯的反应是：那太好了。但当他起草设立这个职位的法律时，他再次施展了他老道的魔法。
And in his mind, temporary could mean who knows how long, post-war period, it's always going to be post-war. You know, the war's over. Elected officials, we'll see. And so he puts a clause into the law saying that the city construction coordinator has the power to represent the city in its relations with cooperating state and federal agencies. And this is one of those things that he's just so good at where it's an innocent appearing provision, but it means that he controls the flow of information between
在他的脑海里，临时可以意味着谁知道会持续多久，战后时期嘛，永远都是战后时期。你知道的，战争结束了，民选官员嘛，走着瞧吧。于是他在法律中加入了一个条款，规定城市建设协调员有权代表城市处理与合作的州及联邦机构的关系。而这就是他最擅长的伎俩之一：这是一个表面上看起来天衣无缝的条款，但这意味着他控制了信息流向——
the city and outside organizations. And so the federal government is going to hear what Moses wants to tell them. The city is going to hear what Moses wants to tell them, even if that's not what either side is actually necessarily saying. He's monopolizing the flow of information the same way he's monopolizing the flow of cars into and out of Manhattan. This guy is all about monopolizing. It's the ultimate whipsaw position because he can just go, hey, the city said
城市与外部组织之间的信息流。因此，联邦政府将听到摩斯希望他们听到的信息；市政府将听到摩斯希望他们听到的信息，即使这未必是任何一方实际在说的话。他垄断了信息流，就像他垄断了进出曼哈顿的汽车流一样。这家伙全神贯注于垄断。这是一种终极的拉锯战姿态，因为他可以说：“嘿，市政府说
they want me to build this thing. And the federal government's like, all right. And then you can go to the city and go, the federal government wants to give us money for this thing. And the CEO go, okay. And neither side knows that Moses is essentially presenting his own case as the other, either side's case. I mean, this is one of those things
他们想让我建造这个东西。”而联邦政府就会说：“好的。”然后你可以对市政府说：“联邦政府想为这个东西给我们资金。”市政府就会说：“行吧。”而双方都不知道摩斯实际上是在把自己的意图伪装成对方的诉求。我的意思是，这就是最让我感兴趣的事情之一，
that's so interesting to me, how Caro zeros in on this phrase, represent the city and its relations with cooperating state and federal agencies. Because this isn't like a phrase buried that's nefarious on its surface and buried and you have to unearth it and find it. Like, I don't think that even reads bad at all. Like, it's only how Moses uses it that's bad. And it's just incredible to me that you
卡罗是如何精准锁定这句话的：“代表城市处理与合作的州及联邦机构的关系”。因为这不是那种表面上看起来居心叵测、被埋藏起来需要你去挖掘才能发现的短语。我觉得这句话表面上看一点也不坏。只有当摩斯利用它的时候它才变得糟糕。对我来说不可思议的是，
would have to write a law like so ironclad to get around someone as devious and power-hungry as Moses is. Like there's just no way to stop this type of person because that phrase, I would just go over it again and again and again, represent the city, represent the city, represent the state, coordinate. You're just like, you're like, represent the city, represent the state, coordinate. You're just like, this is normal practice for a person in this type of role. He just happens to use it to sort of like dash to the ends. But it's incredible.
你居然必须写出一部铁面无私、毫无漏洞的法律，才能绕过像摩斯那样狡猾和渴望权力的人。因为根本没有办法阻止这种类型的人，因为那个短语，我会一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地读它：代表城市，代表城市，代表州，协调。你会觉得：这对于担任此类角色的人来说是常规操作。他只是恰好利用它来达到自己的目的。但这太不可思议了。
It shows you that every law is a tool and that a tool is as useful as the person holding it. The same way, and we've been doing so good, I think, at not bringing in modern day parallels, but the same way that people are like, yeah, I guess there's no law in the books against trying to overthrow the government, the way that Trump did it, so what are we gonna do?
它向你展示了每一条法律都是一个工具，而工具的有用程度取决于握着它的人是谁。同样的道理——我觉得我们一直做得很好，没有引入太多现代的类比——就像人们会说：“是的，我想法律书上没有针对像特朗普那样试图推翻政府的行为的惩罚条款，所以我们能怎么办？”
That's essentially the court being like, hey, no one ever wrote a law saying you shouldn't do this because the assumption was just, of course, this is bad, nobody's gonna do this. And it's hard, law is always kind of a reactive thing, unless you're Moses and you are writing these laws with plans in mind, which is often not the way it happens. Or that the ultimate remedy for the law
这本质上就像是法院在说：“嘿，从来没有人写过一条法律说你不应该这样做，因为大家的假设理所当然是：这太糟糕了，没有人会这么做。”这很难，法律总是某种反应性的东西，除非你是摩斯，你是带着既定计划来编写这些法律的，而这通常并不是法律产生的方式。或者说法律的终极救济手段
is to be removed from power by the electorate, which is not an option for Moses. Yes, that's the ultimate democratic safeguard, which is if we don't like you, you're out. Exactly. Moses is immune to that, which is, ugh, what a, and as we'll see, everyone just keeps giving him more ways to do that, more ways to be immune.
是被选民剥夺权力，而这对摩斯来说是不可能的。是的，那是终极的民主保障机制，也就是说，如果我们不喜欢你，你就得下台。没错。摩斯对这一点免疫，这真是……噢，多么……正如我们将看到的，每个人都在不断为他提供更多这样做的方式，更多让他免疫的方式。
He's getting super vaccines against the democratic process. Moses, he's not officially involved in the housing authority, but when O'Dwyer has vacant seats to fill in the city housing authority board, Moses is like, you should put these people on it, and they're his people. And in 1948, Moses convinces a Dwyer to appoint a mayor's slum clearance committee and Moses is put on that and Moses controls urban renewal in New York for a decade after that. Moses is so good at saying to a Dwyer, hey, you
他正在获得针对民主进程的超级疫苗。摩斯并没有官方参与房屋管理局，但当奥德怀尔有空缺席位需要填补到市房屋管理局董事会时，摩斯就会说：你应该把这些人安排进去，而他们都是他的人。1948年，摩斯说服奥德怀尔任命了一个市贫民窟清理委员会，摩斯被安插进去了，在此后的十年里，摩斯掌控着纽约的城市更新。摩斯非常擅长对奥德怀尔说：嘿，
should put me into this position. And a Dwyer was like, yeah, that sounds good. That's a temporary position. And Moses was like, this is what I do now. And this city construction coordinator job, Moses holds that job for more than 20 years. This is supposed to be, ideally, this is a kind of position that ends in what, three years, four years after the shape of the post-war world has finished. And Kara talks a little bit about how Moses is becoming much more, what's the word, much more just kind of aware of his power. He's really feeling it. And now he would get on the phone with Thomas Dewey, the post-war governor of New York, of Dewey Defeats Truman, incorrect headline fame. Until I started reading about Thomas Dewey, seriously, there's only two things I knew about him. One, he did not defeat Truman, and the newspaper said he did. And two, my grandmother, in a letter to me when George W. Bush
你应该把我安排在这个职位上。而奥德怀尔则会说：听起来不错。那是个临时职位。而摩斯的态度是：这就是我现在的日常工作了。而这个城市建设协调员的工作，摩斯担任了20多年。按理说，这应该是一个在战后世界格局定型后的大约三年、四年内就会结束的职位。卡罗稍微谈到了摩斯变得越来越……怎么说呢，越来越意识到自己的权力。他真的真切地感受到了它。现在他会直接打电话给托马斯·杜威（Thomas Dewey），战后纽约州长——也就是那个因“杜威击败杜鲁门”这则错误头条而闻名的人。直到我开始了解托马斯·杜威之前，说实话，我只知道关于他的两件事。第一，他没有击败杜鲁门，尽管报纸说他赢了。第二，我的祖母在乔治·W·布什
was president, she wrote to me and she said, I hate George W. Bush more than any other elected official in my life except Thomas Dewey. He would say anything to get elected. And I was like, this is the only time I've ever really heard anything about Thomas Dewey. She'd been burning with hatred for Thomas Dewey, someone I thought of just as a name on a news bear headline. But apparently, Moses would just yell him out of the phone and call him a stupid son of a bitch. And Dewey would buckle under the next governor, W. Avril Harriman. He loves Moses' abilities. He tells his staff, hey, get tough on Moses. And Moses is like, all right, yeah, you can get tough on me. Guess what? You're not invited to any groundbreaking ceremonies. And the governor's like, oh, hold on a second. hold on a second. Wait, what if we named your big power dam the
担任总统期间写给我的一封信中，她写道：“我恨乔治·W·布什，超过了我一生中遇到的任何其他民选官员，除了托马斯·杜威。他为了当选什么谎都敢撒。”当时我想：这是我唯一一次真正听到关于托马斯·杜威的事。她对托马斯·杜威的恨意炽烈无比，而这个人我之前只当他是报纸头条上的一个名字。但显然，摩斯会在电话里对他大吼大叫，骂他是个愚蠢的混蛋。而杜威会向他低头。到了下一任州长W·阿维尔·哈里曼（W. Averell Harriman）上台时，他很喜欢摩斯的能力。他对手下说：嘿，对摩斯态度强硬点。而摩斯的反应是：好啊，行，你们可以对我态度强硬。你猜怎么着？任何奠基仪式都不邀请你。州长就会说：哦，等一下，等一下。
Robert Moses power dam? You're great. And he goes, okay, yeah, I am great. You can come back to my ribbon cutting ceremonies. And Harriman is now playing nice with him. Moses is so in control of the things that politicians want and need for their reelection campaigns. And so they, they bow to him, even when it's silliness, you know, it seems like it would be silly to put that much weight on. I'm not getting credit for this new highway exit that just got opened, or I'm not getting credit for this housing project that's getting opened, but that's what they run on. That's they want their names attached to it. Totally, totally.
等等，如果我们把你们那个大型大坝命名为“罗伯特·摩斯大坝”怎么样？你太棒了。然后他说：好的，没错，我是挺棒的。你可以来参加我的剪彩仪式了。于是哈里曼现在开始跟他友好相处了。摩斯对政客们在竞选连任时想要和需要的东西有着如此绝对的控制。所以他们向他屈服，即使这看起来很荒谬，你知道的，把这么大的分量压在这些事情上似乎很傻：我没有因为刚刚开通的高速公路出口而获得赞誉，或者我没有因为刚刚启用的住房项目而获得赞誉——但这就是他们赖以生存的东西。这就是他们希望把自己的名字挂上去的东西。完全如此，完全如此。
And Moses is very good at placing his own people throughout the government. Again, we covered it. He wrote the bill that designed the state government and did a lot of work in the city government later. So he knows exactly who should be where to kind of have people loyal to him in positions. He starts putting secretaries for people who are not loyal to him on his payroll so that he'll get copies of the memos that their bosses are putting out and he'll know ahead of time if they're trying to block his projects. That seems not cool.
而且摩斯非常擅长在整个政府中安插自己的人。再次强调，我们之前讨论过，他起草了设计州政府的法案，后来又在市政府做了大量工作。所以他精准地知道谁应该在哪个位置，以便在关键岗位上有忠于他的人。他开始把那些不忠于他的人的秘书放到自己的薪酬名单上，这样他就能拿到他们老板发布的备忘录副本，并且能够提前知道这些人是否在试图阻挠他的项目。这听起来可不太妙。
That seems like an illegal thing to do. And because Moses controls so much of construction in the city and in the state, he can award jobs to contractors and contractors may want to make nice with him so he can say to a loyal Moses person, are you retiring from the city government? Okay, you can now get a big private job at this engineering firm or something like that that wants to do business with me. He can really promise to take care of them as long as they are loyal to him. And if you're not loyal to him, guess what?
这听起来像是一件违宪违法的事。由于摩斯掌控了城市和州的大部分建设工程，他可以把工作分包给承包商，而承包商为了讨好他，他就可以对一个忠于摩斯的人说：你要从市政府退休了吗？好的，你现在可以在这家很想跟我做生意的工程公司或其他什么地方谋得一份高薪的私人工作了。只要他们忠于他，他确实可以承诺照顾好他们。如果你不忠于他，你猜怎么着？
You're going to be overseeing the grading of farm roads upstate for the rest of your career. You're never getting promoted. And for years, it's just understood by different governors that Robert Moses decides who is getting construction contracts in New York City, what highways are going to be built, where they're going to be built, when they're going to be built. And part of this is Moses also exploiting that the interstate highway system, which is being built at this time, is a partnership between the federal and the state governments,
你职业生涯剩下的时间都将在北部去监督农场道路的平整了。你永远别想升职。多年来，不同的州长都心领神会：罗伯特·摩斯决定了谁能在纽约市获得建设合同，哪些高速公路将被修建，在哪里修建，以及何时修建。部分原因也是因为摩斯利用了当时正在建设的州际公路系统是联邦政府和州政府之间的伙伴关系，
not between federal and city governments. Moses has state power, the city government does not have state power, and it means that he just has so much massive control. And there's a line here that just sounds so sinister that I want to read to you from the book. "'Over the planning and building of arterial highways in and around the city of New York, arterial highways which would do so much to shape the future of that city. The federal and state governments had a stranglehold. The hands that implemented that stranglehold were the hands of Robert Moses." There's nothing positive in that right there. No, no. Strangling hands are universally bad.
而不是联邦政府和市政府之间的伙伴关系。摩斯拥有州的权力，而市政府没有州的权力，这意味着他拥有如此庞大而绝对的控制权。这里有一句话听起来太险恶了，我想读给你们听听书里的原话：“对于纽约市及周边地区干道高速公路的规划和建设——这些对塑造该市未来发挥了巨大作用的干道高速公路——联邦和州政府拥有铁腕般的控制权。实施这种铁腕控制的手，正是罗伯特·摩斯的手。”这里面没有任何积极的含义。没有，没有。扼杀之手在普遍意义上都是坏的。
Yes. No one wants strangling hands on their arterial highways or their arteries in general. So these are all examples of Robert Moses using official power and connections to official power to get what he wants. Caro's going to take us through a few other levers of power in extreme detail. Roman, feel free to pull me back when I start getting too detailed. Yeah, but listen, the point of this is because Tammany's back in power and because Robert Moses has figured out all these different ways to exact his power, he still relies on good old fashioned greed and payoffs.
是的。没有人希望自己的干道高速公路或总而言之自己的血管上被套上扼杀之手。这些都是罗伯特·摩斯利用官方权力和与官方权力的联系来达到自己目的的例子。卡罗接下来将带我们极其详细地了解权力的其他几个杠杆。罗曼，当我开始讲得太细时，请随时把我拉回来。是的，但听着，重点在于，因为坦慕尼协会重新掌权，也因为罗伯特·摩斯已经摸透了所有这些行使权力的不同方法，他依然依赖于老式的贪婪和金钱贿赂。
Like, and this is what Caro is like, really spends a lot of time and effort to say, you know, this thing that Robert Moses, you know, like his reputation at the time, completely avoided, like he never got accused of taking money because he didn't take personal money. But he did the same things that all these Tammany guys did for decades, just in new ways.
就像——这也是卡罗花费大量时间和精力去阐述的：你知道，罗伯特·摩斯所做的事，你知道他当时的声誉，完全避开了这一点，因为他从未被指控拿钱，因为他没有拿个人的钱。但他做的却和所有那些坦慕尼协会家伙几十年来做的事一模一样，只不过用了新的方式。
And in fact, in a way he was better at it because he never really took his off the top. So there's more money to spread around. You know what I mean? Yeah. He's very, I mean, this is an uncomplimentary analogy, but in a way he's like Charles Manson. Charles Manson did not kill anybody. He sent people to kill other people, but that still makes him part of a murderer. Even though Robert Moses is not taking graft, he is not just allowing it, but pushing it. And in that way,
事实上，从某种意义上说他做得更好，因为他从来不拿大头。所以有更多的钱可以分发。你知道我的意思吗？是的。他非常——我的意思是一个不太好听的比喻，但在某种程度上他就像查尔斯·曼森（Charles Manson）。查尔斯·曼森没有杀任何人。他派人去杀其他人，但这仍然使他成为谋杀犯的一部分。尽管罗伯特·摩斯没有拿回扣，但他不仅纵容，而且在推波助澜。从这个意义上讲，
he's just as corrupt as everybody else. He's just, but exactly, because he's not, because he can point to himself and be like, I got bills to pay, I'm in debt, look at me, I'm not, I'm not living it up. Look, I can't be corrupt. It means he got away with quite a bit. And so as you're saying, Tammany is an office again, we should make it very clear, Carol goes out of his way to explain this. Tammany Hall is just a name. They're no longer meeting in Tammany Hall, the building. And the actual building Tammany Hall as of 2023 is a Petco. So if it's no longer the locus of corrupt power
他和所有人一样腐败。他只是……但正因如此，因为他可以指着自己说：我有账单要付，我负债累累，看看我，我没有过着穷奢极欲的生活。看，我不可能是腐败的。这意味着他逃脱了相当多的指责。正如你所说，坦慕尼协会又回到了权力核心，我们应该说清楚，卡罗不遗余力地解释了这一点。坦慕尼协会只是一个名字。他们不再在坦慕尼协会大楼里开会了。截至2023年，实际的坦慕尼协会大楼现在是一家宠物店（Petco）。所以它不再是腐败权力的中心了
in New York City. Or is it? I don't know. Or maybe, I don't know. I mean, when I was in New York, it was the New York Film Academy for quite some time, but now it's a Petco. But everyone still just says Tammany Hall, cause it's a great name. But the Guardia is out of office,
在纽约市。或者真的是吗？我不知道。或者也许，我不知道。我的意思是，当我在纽约时，它曾很长一段时间是纽约电影学院（New York Film Academy），但现在它是一家宠物店。但每个人依然习惯说坦慕尼协会，因为这是一个绝佳的名字。但拉瓜迪亚卸任了，
O'Dwyer is in office, Tammany is in office. This is a city, as Carol says, in which everything had its price. And he talks about graft a little bit and the difference between honest graft and dishonest graft. And I do want to talk about this, cause I think it's very interesting. I think it's interesting too.
奥德怀尔上任了，坦慕尼协会上台了。正如卡罗所说，这是一个一切皆有价码的城市。他稍微谈了谈回扣，以及诚实回扣（honest graft）和不诚实回扣（dishonest graft）之间的区别。我真的很想谈谈这个，因为我觉得非常有趣。我也觉得很有趣。
So dishonest graft is the kind of thing that like Boss Tweed did at the 1860s 1870s where it's like Hey, whenever the city gets billed for anything I get a percentage of it The comptroller gets a percentage of it. The mayor gets a percentage of it. You know what? We're just stealing money from the system best line from the city Whereas by the 20th century you had these bosses like silent Charlie Murphy and George Washington Plunkett, who was quoted earlier, and they had the idea of honest graft, which is you don't get a bribe. Instead, what you do is you use your power to, say, direct a city contract to a company that you had a stake in or
所以不诚实回扣就像是Boss特威德（Boss Tweed）在1860和1870年代所做的那样，类似于：嘿，每当城市为任何事情买单时，我都能拿到一定比例的提成。审计长也能拿到一定比例的提成。市长也能拿到一定比例的提成。你知道吗？我们就是在从体制中偷钱，这是城市里最好的台词。然而到了20世纪，你有了像“沉默的查理·墨菲”（Silent Charlie Murphy）和前面引用的乔治·华盛顿·普朗基特这样的大佬，他们提出了诚实回扣的概念，也就是你不是去拿贿赂。相反，你做的是利用你的权力，比如，把一个城市的合同定向给一家你拥有股份的公司，或者
you know that some land needs to be owned by the city and you buy it ahead of time and then you sell it to the city at an inflated price. You're getting paid money, but it is not just the city is getting something in return. It's getting a service or it's getting a location, but in exchange you are, you're getting a little bit off the top as opposed to just saying, give me money. Like just give me money straight. It's not direct money, but you're, it's a, it's like recognizing that, Hey, I'm a person of power and influence. I've been in this city a long time. I own a little piece of this construction company.
你知道某些土地需要由城市拥有，于是你提前买下它，然后以虚高的价格卖给城市。你拿到了钱，但并不仅仅是城市什么都没得到。城市得到了服务或者得到了一个地点的回报，但作为交换，你从头到尾捞到了一点好处，而不是直截了当地说：直接给我钱。就像直接给我现金一样。这不是直接的金钱，但你，它就像是承认：嘿，我是个有权势和影响力的巨头。我在这个城市待了很长时间。我拥有这家建筑公司的一小部分股份。
What's the big deal? Hey, why should I not hire the best construction company in the city according to me? I wouldn't own a stake in it if I didn't feel that way. Why should I deny those services to the city? Just because I might make a little bit of money off of it. And it's sort of like indirect and it's just laundered a little bit of money off of it. And it's sort of like indirect and it's just laundered a little bit, honestly.
这有什么大不了的？嘿，我凭什么不能根据我自己的判断雇用城里最好的建筑公司？如果我不是这么觉得的，我也不会持有它的股份。我凭什么要把这些服务剥离出城市？仅仅因为我可能会从中赚到一点小钱吗。这就有点间接，而且把钱稍微洗白了一点，说实话。
It's mostly, by the 1920s, it's mostly being paid through fees. Well, yeah, this is the second revelation. It's just like, instead of just a little bit off the top to people who are a comptroller or people who are the mayor, it's like they introduce the concept of the lawyer on the take.
到了19世纪20年代，这主要通过费用来支付。好吧，是的，这就是第二个启示。这就像是：与其给审计长或市长之类的人直接拿一点提成，不如他们引入了“拿好处的律师”的概念。
Yes, where it's like, hey, you're a state legislator, you're also a lawyer. As a state legislator, you voted for this project. You know what? Just as a private lawyer, we hired you to do some work for us and we paid you a fee for it and it's on the books that way.
是的，就像是：嘿，你是一名州议员，你同时也是一名律师。作为州议员，你投票支持了这个项目。你知道吗？作为一名私人律师，我们雇用了你为我们做一些工作，并为此支付了你一笔费用，账面上就是这样记录的。
And Carol quotes Al Smith, seeing a law student studying and saying, there's a young man studying how to take a bribe and call it a fee. And it was, if you were too worried about your name showing up in the books of that company, then you know what? You have them pay the fee to another legal firm, which then pays it to you, and they take a little cut off of it. It's honest in that it is more dishonest. Like it's honest in that it is not just stealing straightforward,
卡罗引用了阿尔·史密斯（Al Smith）的话，看到一个法学院学生在学习时说：“那是一个正在学习如何拿贿赂并把它称为‘代理费’的年轻人。”如果你太担心自己的名字出现在那家公司的账本上，那么你知道吗？你让他们把这笔钱作为费用支付给另一家律师事务所，然后再由那家事务所支付给你，他们从中抽取一点提成。它之所以被称为“诚实”，是因为它更加虚伪。就像它诚实在于它不只是直接偷窃，
but there is more lying involved. And there's so much construction going on. There's so many opportunities for graft now in this post-World War II world. And there's so much construction going on. There's so many opportunities for graft now in this post-World War II world. And you remember when Moses was a young man, he refused to pay it. He was not going to pay the price to get his things through because he had principles. Now he is happy to pay it and he has so much money to pay it with because he's got control of so many different state and city public works that, Kara says, from 1945 to 1960, he had roughly $3.5 billion to do whatever with, with minimal oversight. And from the Tribor authority, he has another $750 million with no oversight.
但其中涉及更多的谎言。而且现在有这么多的建设正在进行。在这个二战后的世界里，有如此之多的贪污机会。而且现在有这么多的建设正在进行。在这个二战后的世界里，有如此之多的贪污机会。你还记得当莫斯是个年轻人时，他拒绝付这笔钱。他绝不肯为了让自己的项目通过而付出代价，因为他有原则。现在他很乐意支付，而且他有如此多的资金可以支付，因为他控制了如此众多的州和市政府公共工程。卡罗说，从1945年到1960年，他大约有35亿美元可以随意支配，且监管极少。而从三区桥梁及隧道管理局（Triborough Authority），他又掌控了另外7.5亿美元，没有任何监管。
Those books are closed to the public. You cannot look at them. The only people who can is the comptroller can call for an audit, but it would take so many lawyers to go through those books that they would need an appropriation from the government to do that. And the government's not going to be like, yeah, yeah, well, we'll give you the money to hire the people to find out that we were taking bribes from the tribal authority. Sure, sure. Robert Moses, he just has so much money on hand. At the same time, as we're saying, he has the power of the press saying he's a disinterested civil servant. He's not interested in money. he's not interested in patronage. This is long after he, of course, was doling out patronage like crazy. His reputation
这些账本对公众是封闭的。你无法查阅它们。唯一能查的人只有审计长，审计长可以要求进行审计，但这需要如此多的律师去审查这些账本，以至于他们需要政府拨款才能做到这一点。而政府才不会说：行啊，行啊，我们会给你钱去雇人来查出我们一直在收受三区管理局的贿赂。当然，当然。罗伯特·摩斯手头就是有这么多的资金。与此同时，正如我们所说，媒体的声誉宣传他是一个大公无私的公务员。他对金钱不感兴趣，对政客分赃（patronage）不感兴趣。这已经在他毫无节制地大肆分发政客分赃很久之后了。他的声誉
protects him. And Carroll starts going through specific examples of Moses paying out graft in the form of fees for insurance premiums, things like that. It gets very dizzying. There's so many different examples and there's so many different ways to do it that I know reading through it, I start to go into a kind of a trance. And the most important thing is just to know that Caro's saying, Moses has such a good antenna for who's in power and who's not, that you can kind of track who's up, who's down in New York politics by who is getting paid these fees from Triborough authority. Yeah. And I'm trying to think, is there anything really salient here in one of these examples that points to something? But basically it's just,
保护了他。卡罗开始列举莫斯以保险费等形式支付回扣的具体例子。这让人感到非常头晕目眩。有这么多的不同例子，有这么多的不同方式，我知道在阅读过程中，我开始陷入了一种出神的状态。最重要的是要知道卡罗在说：摩斯对谁掌权、谁不掌权有着如此敏锐的天线，以至于你基本上可以通过谁在从三区管理局获得这些费用，来追踪纽约政坛谁在得势、谁在失势。是的。我在想，这里面有没有哪个例子真的特别突出、能说明某些问题的？但基本上这就是，
they pull what this sort of back alley dealing of handing an envelope to somebody into all these legitimate forms of business. It's the same principle of just paying off someone, but just filters through more organizations and those organizations are legal companies. I mean, that's really it. And the other difference is that Carol makes a point of saying it's not explicit quid pro
他们把这种在小巷里暗中交易、把信封塞给某人的做法，搬到了所有这些合法的商业形式中。这和行贿的原理完全一样，只是通过更多的组织进行了过滤，而这些组织都是合法的公司。我的意思是，事实确实如此。另一个不同之处在于，卡罗特别指出，这不是明确的利益交换（quid pro quo）。
quos. It's not I'm giving you this fee in exchange for you doing this one thing for me. It's more like you're on the team. I'm going to give you a job as the, he talks about Stanley Rosenman, I think it is. I forgot what, I think he's legal counsel to Triborough or something like that. Like you have this job and in exchange, if the governor looks like he's going to veto one of my projects, you just fly to Albany and tell him not to, but I'm not going to tell you to do that. You just know you're
这不是“我给你这笔费用，作为交换你为我做这一件事”。更像是：你是我们团队的人。我要给你安排一份工作，比如担任——他谈到了斯坦利·罗森曼（Stanley Rosenman），我想是这个人。我忘了什么，我想他是三区管理局的法律顾问之类的。就像你得到了这份工作，作为交换，如果州长看起来要否决我的一个项目，你只要飞到奥尔巴尼去告诉他不要这么做，但我不会命令你这么做。你自己心里有数
on my team. When, when something is in my way, you help remove it. When some, when I need something, you help do it for me, but it's not Moses calling up people with specific directives necessarily. It's all very, I mean, again, it's the way that Trump kind of does things, where it's a lot of like, or mobsters, where it's a lot of like, you got that thing? Okay, great. Here's another thing. Oh, what about that thing? It's a lot of refusing to use details in the exact agreements. And again, Kara makes it very clear that Moses didn't take money, but he still considers him corrupt. He writes, in terms of money, the terms in which corruption is usually measured, Robert Moses was not himself corrupt. He was in fact as uninterested in obtaining payoffs for himself as any public servant who ever lived. In the politicians phrase, he was money honest. But in terms of power,
在我团队里。每当我遇到阻碍时，你都会帮我搬开。每当我，当我需要什么时，你都会代劳，但这不一定是摩西在对特定人员下达具体的指令。这一切都非常……我的意思是，这再次体现了特朗普行事的方式，或者像黑手党那样，有很多类似“那件事你搞定了吗？行，很好。还有另一件事。哦，那件事呢？”的感觉。它在具体的协议中大量拒绝使用细节。而且罗伯特·卡罗再次说得很清楚，摩西没有拿钱，但他仍然认为摩西是腐败的。他写道，就金钱而言，也就是通常用来衡量腐败的标准，罗伯特·摩西本人并不腐败。事实上，他像有史以来任何一位公职人员一样，对为自己捞取好处毫无兴趣。用政客的话说，他在金钱上是诚实的。但就权力而言，
Robert Moses was corrupt. Coveting it, he used money to get it. And so he becomes, even if he is not taking payoffs, he becomes the center of cash corruption in the construction trades and the building projects of New York. He's like an octopus that's using all of its tentacles to, I don't know, throw fish at other octopuses, but it's not eating any of itself. It's a great metaphor, it's a great analogy. Maybe Robert Carroll will use it in the next edition.
罗伯特·摩西是腐败的。他渴望权力，并用金钱来获取权力。因此，即使他没有收受回扣，他也成为了纽约建筑行业和建筑项目中现金腐败的中心。他就像一只章鱼，用所有的触手去，我不知道，向其他章鱼扔鱼，但他自己什么也没吃。这是一个绝妙的比喻，一个绝妙的类比。也许罗伯特·卡罗会在下一版中用到它。
That's right. That's right. And it all comes from the fact that he has so much money for this period of time. He controls like so much liquid money from all this, you just like toll money that he can just like, it's not like he has to really lean on anyone to make them do something.
没错。没错。这一切都源于他在这一时期拥有如此之多的资金。他掌控着来自这一切的巨额流动资金，比如各种过路费，他可以随心所欲地使用——他不需要真正去依靠任何人来让他们做某事。
He just goes, hey bank, do you want $15 million in your deposit so you can make more money off of, you know, like the things that bank do to make money, you know, like, and he just, he just gives it to them. It's not a problem. Like you have to put the money in the bank. Um, the bank makes money off it. All this sort of stuff is normal things,
他只会说：“嘿，银行，你想不想把1500万美元存到你那儿，这样你就能靠这些钱赚取更多利润了？你知道的，就像银行用来赚钱的那种业务一样。”然后他就，他就直接把钱给他们了。这根本不是问题。就像你必须把钱存进银行一样；嗯，银行靠它赚钱。所有这类事情都是常规操作，
but the level of it and the way he kind of uses it to create this system around himself to get what he wants out of things is just the scale of it is, is just so impressive. Yes. And that caros, but he that he is seeing the whole situation of power in politics in New York so holistically, and so every single aspect of it. So like with banks, he knows banks have political power. Banks are involved with, the people who run banks
但这种规模以及他利用它在自己周围建立这个系统来从中获取所需东西的方式——其规模实在是太震撼了。是的。这就是卡罗的观点，他非常全面地看待纽约政治中的权力全局，涵盖了每一个方面。比如对待银行，他知道银行拥有政治力量。银行与这座城市的政治捐款者息息相关，
are involved with political donations in this city, and so he can get a banker on his side by putting things in the bank. Again, there's nothing illegal about what he's doing. He talks about dealing with like the unions in the city. Unions have a lot of political power, and they also already like these projects because they're big projects that employ a lot of people that have a lot of overtime on them. So it keeps their... The heads of unions are elected by their members. And so just like any elected official in the city, they need to save their members.
银行经营者也参与其中，因此他可以通过把资金存入银行来把银行拉到自己这边。再说一次，他的所作所为没有任何违法的地方。他谈到与城市里的工会打交道。工会有很强的政治影响力，而且他们本来就喜欢这些项目，因为这些项目规模宏大，雇用大量人员，并且有许多加班机会。所以这能维持他们的……工会领袖是由会员选举产生的。因此，就像城里任何民选官员一样，他们需要为自己的会员谋福利。
I brought all this to you, and now you're making money." And so he can then work with the unions to also be on his side because he can promise them certain types of projects and jobs. And he is effectively becoming, as Carol calls them at one point in the chapter, the boss of bosses, which is, sounds like it's a mafia term, but it's also of all these political machine bosses, all these bosses of different types of power in New York, he is now their boss who is, as Carol says, he uses the analogy of a word boss handing out Christmas baskets to his constituents, you know, so that he can maintain their vote. Moses handing out baskets of honest graft to his constituents, which are the behind the scenes power brokers and bosses of the city.
“我把这一切都带给了你们，现在你们正在赚钱。”因此，他随后可以与工会合作，让他们也站在自己这一边，因为他可以向他们承诺某些类型的项目和工作岗位。他实际上正在成为卡罗在这一章中某个地方所称的“老板中的老板”——这听起来像是黑手党的术语，但它也是针对纽约所有这些政治机器老板、所有不同权力类型的头目而言的；他现在成了他们的老板，正如卡罗所说，他用了“政客老板向选民分发圣诞篮，以便维持他们的选票”这样的类比。摩西则是向他的选民——也就是这座城市的幕后权力掮客和老板们——分发诚实贿赂的篮子。
That's right. And once he gives you that basket, I'm just keep saying basket, it's not literally a basket, but once he hands you that basket, he also has a hold over you because he can say, remember I did that thing? And Paul Skravane, city council president, he talks about how Mayor Robert Wagner, who we'll be talking about in great length later, that he said to him, hey, I'm going to make you the city's liaison for the 1964 World's Fair, which Moses is running and he says, well, my experience with Moses taught me, accept nothing from him. Never let him do a favor for you ever.
没错。一旦他把那个篮子交给你——我一直在说篮子，它字面上并不是个篮子，但一旦他把那个篮子交给你，他就对你有了掌控力，因为他可以说：“还记得我做过的那件事吗？”城市议会主席保罗·斯克拉万谈到市长罗伯特·瓦格纳时说——我们稍后会详细讨论他——瓦格纳对他说：“嘿，我要让你担任1964年世界博览会的城市联络人。”而博览会是由摩西负责的。斯克拉万说：“好吧，我从摩西身上吸取的教训是：不要接受他的任何东西。永远不要让他为你做任何事。”
If he tries to do one, say no, thank you. Just don't accept it because he will hold it over you forever and he'll destroy you with it. Like, and Scrivain talks about how he would see guys who Moses had done favors for going against Moses and then Moses saying, get me the file, get me the file that has this thing in it. And he knew that he could show that to whoever it was and that person would fold. He's just so he has, it just becomes common knowledge that he has these extensive dossiers about people with compromising information about what he's done for them and what they've
如果他试图帮忙，就说“不，谢谢”。千万别接受，因为他会永远以此要挟你，并用它来毁了你。斯克拉万谈到，他曾看到一些受过摩西恩惠的人转而反对摩西，然后摩西就会说：“把档案给我，把藏有这件事的档案拿来。”他知道自己可以把那份档案拿给任何人看，而那个人就会彻底垮台。他就是这样……人们渐渐都知道，他手里握有关于这些人的大量档案，里面有他们接受过他什么恩惠以及他们做过什么的妥协性信息。
done in return. And if you don't accept a favor from him, it doesn't mean you're immune, because everyone's done something embarrassing, and he's got his bloodhounds, not literal bloodhounds, he's got his, you know, guys who search out compromising information. And so, Carol says, it's not just greed that Moses is holding over people, although that's a big part of it. It's also fear. You're also afraid that Moses will make something public that you don't want to be public. And now I'm free floating in this book. I think we've talked about this before about how if you're a major public figure and Moses goes after you in the press, maybe you can survive it. But if you're a city bureaucrat somewhere, this is the first time your name is appearing in the
如果你不接受他的恩惠，并不意味着你就安全了，因为每个人都做过一些尴尬的事，而他有他的走狗——不是字面意义上的走狗，他有那些专门搜寻不利信息的家伙。因此，卡罗指出，摩西用来拿捏别人的不仅仅是贪婪，尽管这也是很大一部分原因。还有恐惧。你也会害怕摩西把某些你不想公开的事情公之于众。现在我在这本书里思绪有点飘忽了。我想我们以前讨论过这个：如果你是个大公众人物，而摩西在媒体上攻击你，也许你还能挺过去。但如果你只是个市级官僚，这是你的名字第一次出现在
newspaper and it's appearing with Robert Moses calling you a communist or someone connected to Robert Moses leaking information about something in your past that could destroy you. That's really scary. So it's a powerful tool. And Moses' role in all this and the sort of institutions he creates and shores up are all legitimate on the surface.
报纸上，而且上面还印着罗伯特·摩西骂你是共产主义者，或者有与罗伯特·摩西相关的人泄露了你过去能毁掉你的某件黑幕。这真的很可怕。所以这是一个强有力的工具。摩西在这一切中的角色，以及他所创建和巩固的各种机构，表面上看起来全都是合法的。
These, the banks, the bonds, like bankers want his bonds. They're stable, like they give a good return. He's offering something that they want. But the reason why they're so flushed to invest is because he's parking the authority's money with them. And all that stuff kind of works. And so like when he has kind of dirt on you for giving you a little bit of this money or whatever that he could destroy you with,
这些银行、这些债券——比如银行家们想要他的债券。它们很稳定，回报率很高。他提供的是他们想要的东西。但他们之所以如此热衷于投资，是因为他把当局的资金存在了他们那里。所有这些运作方式基本上都是行得通的。所以，当他因为给了你一点钱之类的好处而掌握了你的黑料，并可以用它来毁灭你时，
he's kind of bulletproof because there's no part of this which is actually illegal. He, at least as far as I can tell, I mean, like he really insulates himself and his discipline to never really wet his beak and only accrue power from it and not money is like a real source of his strength. Like he had he just has this discipline to keep everyone else flush, everyone else happy, all these parts of these
他就变得刀枪不入了，因为其中没有任何一部分是真正非法的。他——至少据我所能看出的——我的意思是，他真正地保护了自己，并且他克制自己绝不沾手实质利益，只靠权力而非金钱来积累影响力，这是他力量的真正源泉。他就是有这种自律精神，让其他人都有钱赚，让所有人都开心，让复杂系统的各个部分协同运转，
complicated systems working together. But he can always be the sort of pristine, clean center of it all. Yes, he doesn't show it. It's the thing you see a lot in gangster movies where they're like, and there's the scene in Goodfellas with the fur coat, but there's in American gangster, there's also a fur coat thing. It's often fur coats where you pull off a job and the minute you start showing you have money, it's trouble.
但他自己始终能保持那种纯洁、干净的中心地位。是的，他不显山露水。你在黑帮电影里经常能看到这种桥段，比如《好家伙》里有件皮草大衣的场景，但在《美国黑帮》里也有个关于皮草大衣的桥段。往往是关于皮草大衣的：当你干成了一票，而你一开始显露自己有钱，麻烦就来了。
And so that's the scene in Goodfellas where he goes, take it back, take it back. He bought a fur coat for his wife and after dinner, he's going, take it back. Because if you don't show that you have it, people aren't going to go looking for you at it. And the thing that Caro, especially with the banks that he gets to here too is,
所以《好家伙》里的那个场景就是他喊着：“拿回去，拿回去！”他给妻子买了一件皮草大衣，晚饭后他一直在说：“拿回去。”因为如果你不显摆自己有钱，人们就不会顺藤摸瓜来找你的麻烦。卡罗特别指出的、关于他打交道的银行的一点是，
you're talking about those bonds, those bonds are super attractive to banks. They pay artificially high yields. Like the interest rates on them are enormous that he's paying back to them. They're incredibly stable, they're tax exempt. And that's one of the reasons why they return so much is they're tax exempt.
你在谈论的那些债券，对银行来说极具吸引力。它们支付人工抬高的收益率。他向银行支付的利息高得惊人。它们极其稳定，而且免税。这就是它们能带来如此高回报的原因之一，因为它们是免税的。
That's the public authority and these bonds and all this sort of stuff is able to happen because we entrust these institutions to do things in tax-free ways, to give them a little bit of leg up because they're working for us. And that is not a problem as long as they are working for us. But as soon as they are not,
公共当局、这些债券以及所有这类事情之所以能够发生，是因为我们委托这些机构以免税的方式做事，给它们一点优势，因为它们是在为我们工作。只要它们确实在为我们工作，这就不是问题。但一旦它们不再这样做，
it's just stealing from different types of people. Because, yeah, the payback for those bonds is not, it's not like Robert Moses is then, like, it's not like he's winning the lottery and then he's spending, giving that money back to the banks or his own money. The money he's paying the banks back with is toll money. It's toll money, yeah.
这纯粹就是在从不同类型的人身上窃取财富。因为，是的，那些债券的回报并不是……这不像是罗伯特·摩西中了大奖，然后他把那笔钱分给银行或当成自己的钱来花。他用来偿还银行的钱是过路费。那是过路费，是的。
And that is money directly from New Yorkers, from people traveling through New York City. And the whole point of an authority is that it's built, the bonds pay for its construction, the bonds are paid off, the toll goes away. But because Moses keeps issuing these bonds, the tolls never go away. And so New Yorkers are paying these millions
而这笔钱直接来自纽约人，来自在纽约市出行的人。当局的全部意义在于它的建立——债券支付了建设费用，债券被偿清后，过路费就取消了。但由于摩西不断发行这些债券，过路费就永远不会取消。因此，纽约人正在支付这数百万
and millions of dollars that the banks and everyone else are taking advantage of. They're just paying it dime by dime by dime by dime, which adds up, especially back then, dime bought a lot. I forgot how much I said a dime could buy you a house. Maybe you could buy a house with a dime. Actually, this is like the 40s, 50s. So a dime can buy you like maybe just like a motorcycle. And there's other places that Moses finds power that you wouldn't even expect. He makes a real alliance with Cardinal Spellman of the Archdiocese of New York, the Catholic Church, because he has political power. He has massive political power. He deals with the owners of Macy's and Gimbals, the retail giants
甚至数千万美元，而银行和其他所有人都在从中牟利。他们一分钱一分钱地支付着，积少成多，特别是在那个时候，一毛钱（dime）能买很多东西。我忘了我刚才说一毛钱能买栋房子。也许你真能用一毛钱买栋房子。事实上，这是40年代、50年代的事。所以一毛钱大概只能买辆摩托车吧。摩西还在其他你想不到的地方找到了权力。他与纽约总教区的斯佩尔曼枢机主教（天主教会）结成了真正的联盟，因为他有政治权力。他拥有巨大的政治权力。他与梅西百货和吉姆布尔百货（城市里的零售巨头）的老板们打交道，
in the city, because they're powerful. They control political power. Anyone who has access to political power, he is eager to work with, to make deals with, to do favors for. Um, there's one point where he is planning to condemn a block of buildings so Macy's can just build a new building there. This is not the kind of thing you're supposed to be able to evict hundreds of, if not thousands of
因为他们很有权势。他们掌控着政治权力。任何能够接触到政治权力的人，他都急于与之合作、达成交易、给予恩惠。嗯，有一次他正计划将一整街的建筑定为危房拆除，好让梅西百货在那里建一座新楼。这可不是那种你可以随随便便将成百上千甚至上万
people for. And the wrong person in the government hears about it and says to the mayor, like, if you don't stop this, I'm going to go to the newspapers and say, we're evicting all these people. So Macy's can build a new building. You know, this is crazy. the wrong person in the government hears about it and says to the mayor like, if you don't stop this, I'm gonna go to the newspapers and say we're evicting all these people so Macy's can build a new building. This is crazy.
人驱逐出去的事情。而政府里某个不该听到此事的人听到了风声，并对市长说：“如果你不阻止这件事，我就去曝光给报社，说我们要把所有这些人赶走，好让梅西百货建新楼。这太疯狂了。”而政府里某个不该听到此事的人听到了风声，并对市长说：“如果你不阻止这件事，我就去曝光给报社，说我们要把所有这些人赶走，好让梅西百货建新楼。这太疯狂了。”
And at this part, it's easy to think, Moses is kind of working with everybody. Maybe this is a perfect system. He's working with politicians, banks, retailers, the church, the unions. Maybe this is that perfect system where everyone gets a little bit of what they want. But the thing is, the people that leave out are the residents.
在这个阶段，人们很容易认为：摩西似乎在与所有人合作。也许这是一个完美的系统。他在与政客、银行、零售商、教会、工会合作。也许这就是那个每个人都能得到自己想要的一小部分利益的完美系统。但问题是，被排除在外的是居民。
The people who, like we were saying, the people who are paying the tolls, the people who are now paying higher taxes to support these things, the people in power are getting something from it, and the people who are out of power are not. But it means that all the powerful forces of the city are very much aligned behind Moses pushing for these projects. They're all going to get something out of it. Now, okay, there's another center of power in the city. Let's talk about this one. This is the one that should be stopping all this. It's called, we mentioned it before, the Board of Estimate. That's right. It's got an intriguing, exciting name, the Board of Estimate. The borough presidents sit on it and they control, in theory, they control the hiring and public works within their boroughs.
正如我们所说，那些支付过路费的人、那些现在为了支持这些东西而缴纳更高税收的人，当权者从中得到了好处，而没有权力的人却没有。但这确实意味着这座城市所有的强大势力都紧密团结在摩西身后，极力推动这些项目。他们都能从中分一杯羹。现在，好吧，城里还有另一个权力中心。我们来谈谈这个。这是本该阻止这一切的机构。它被称为——我们之前提到过——估税委员会。没错。它有一个耐人寻味且令人兴奋的名字——估税委员会。各区区长是其成员，理论上，他们控制着各自区内的招聘和公共工程。
This is the top of a democratic pyramid that goes down through district and county organizations. And this is the kind of stuff that we talked about back in episode two with Jamal Bowie, where he was saying that even a corrupt democracy is built on delivering things for its constituents. It needs to get those votes. So even a corrupt machine has to be in some way responsive to the people. If it gets too non-responsive to the people, it gets voted out of office. And the reformers, unfortunately, in New York kind of cause themselves some problems later on because in 1938, they want to curb the big machine politics. So they take a lot of that borough centered power and they move it to central city agencies. And this is kind of similar to what is happening with the governor of New York with Al Smith
这是一个民主金字塔的顶端，向下延伸至各区和县级组织。这正是我们在第二集里和贾马尔·鲍伊探讨过的内容：他曾说过，即使是一个腐败的民主制度，也是建立在为选民兑现利益的基础之上的。它需要赢得那些选票。因此，即使是一个腐败的机器，也必须在某种程度上对人民做出回应。如果它对人民的反应过于冷淡，就会在选举中被投票赶下台。不幸的是，纽约的改革派在后来的发展中给自己制造了一些麻烦，因为在1938年，他们想要遏制庞大的机器政治。于是他们把许多以区为中心的权力剥夺了，转移到了中央城市机构。这有点类似于当时纽约州长阿尔·史密斯
back then, which is that everyone still blames the borough presidents for not doing the things they want, but they don't really have the power to do it anymore. They can't really control it. They're, they are open for, uh, let's just say, uh, persuasion by someone who has money and plans. Okay. But okay, hold on. They still control the power of the purse over the board of estimate, right?
所做的事情，那就是每个人仍然责怪区长们没有做他们想做的事，但区长们实际上已经没有权力去做了。他们无法真正掌控局面。他们很容易受到——呃，比方说——拥有资金和计划的人的“说服”。好吧。但是，等等。他们仍然控制着估税委员会的钱袋子权力，对吧？
The most powerful power of all. It's right there, I think in the Federalist papers. Like the power of the purse is the power of war and peace, it's the power over everything. Here's the issue when there's another guy who has his own purse and it's a much bigger purse and he doesn't need any of your power to spend money out of it, then the power of the purse is not that's it's a little bit like, I don't remember if I used this metaphor before. It's like if my children were playing the stock
这是所有权力中最强大的权力。我想这就在《联邦党人文集》里。钱袋子的权力就是战争与和平的权力，是一切之上的权力。问题在于，当另一个人拥有他自己的钱袋子，而且那是个大得多、根本不需要你的权力就能花钱的钱袋子时，钱袋子的权力就……这就有点像——我不记得我以前有没有用过这个比喻。这就好比如果我的孩子们在玩股票
market and I was like, if you don't do your chores, you won't get your allowance. And they'd be like, that's fine, you know, Tesla is up. I don't need to do my chores to get my allowance. I don't know that my kids would necessarily invest in Tesla, it's just the first company that came to mind that has volume stocks, you know. And so the Board of Estimate, it only has the power to say, no, we won't pay for things. It does not have the money to say,
市场，而我说：“如果你们不干家务，就没有零花钱。”他们就会说：“没关系，特斯拉涨了。我不需要干家务也能拿零花钱。”我不知道我的孩子们是否一定会投资特斯拉，它只是我脑子里第一个蹦出来的、有大量股票流通的公司，你知道的。因此，估税委员会唯一的权力就是说：“不，我们不会为这些项目付钱。”它没有资金去说：
yes, we will pay for things. And that's when Moses can step in and he can say to a borough president, hey, do you need a project so that people will think that you can accomplish things so they'll vote for you again? I got a project. He just opens up his coat and they're like stolen watches or all his plans with the budgets attached. And he's like, I can give you the money, I can give you the plans, but here's the thing. You got to do it the way I tell you to do it. And I know you know your borough. You think you know it better than I do.
“是的，我们会为这些项目付钱。”正是在这个时候，摩西可以介入，对某个区长说：“嘿，你需要一个项目来证明自己能办成事，好让大家在下次选举中投票给你吗？我这里刚好有个项目。”他随手拉开大衣，里面挂着的不是偷来的手表，而是附带预算的各种宏伟计划。他接着说：“我可以给你资金，也可以给你计划，但条件是：你必须按我的要求去做。我知道你很了解你的区。你可能觉得你比我更了解它。
You maybe know what the people there need better than I do. I don't care. I'm not open for suggestions. You gotta take it the way it is or leave it. And if they don't take it, I will have the banks, the unions, the church, the retail giants call you and tell you, you need to take it. Why aren't you taking it?
你可能比我更清楚那里的人需要什么。但我不在乎。我不接受建议。要么照单全收，要么拉倒。”而如果他们不接受，我就会让银行、工会、教会和零售巨头打电话给你，告诉你：“你必须接受。你为什么不接受？”
Yeah. And even the press, and he really does these awful things where someone pushes back and they're like well I don't want this elevated highway over my church or my house Just like how about just a couple blocks this way and he's just like he calls a press conference says like you know that Moron he just decided he didn't want 23 million dollars of my money to build something I was gonna spend 2323 million in the Bronx. Sounds pretty good, right?
是的。甚至还有媒体，他确实会做那些可怕的事：当有人反抗时，他们会说：“嗯，我可不希望这座高架高速公路从我的教堂或房子上方穿过，能不能稍微往这边挪几个街区？”而他就会召开记者招待会，说：“你们知道那个笨蛋吗？他刚刚决定拒绝我2300万美元的资金来建设某个项目，我本打算在布朗克斯花这2300万的。”听起来很不错吧？
People in the Bronx will tell your borough president that he needs to stop because now I'm gonna send it somewhere else. And the borough president is like, oh, that doesn't look good. It's so much of Moses' power comes from, one, people being afraid to let him resign and having this bluff that no one will call,
布朗克斯的人民会去告诉你们的区长，让他别再阻挠了，因为现在我要把这笔钱送到别的地方去。于是区长就会想：“哦，这可不太妙。”摩西的大部分权力来源于：第一，人们害怕让他辞职，并且不敢拆穿他这种无人敢应战的虚张声势；
and two, being able to say to people, you need this money, right? You want this money. And so, can you afford not to take it? Can you afford to say no to this and lose out on these millions of dollars? And it's like, I mean, every day with Moses, like in Decent Proposal with Robert Redford and Demi Moore, basically, you know, can you afford not to do this with me? I don't know if you can, because I'm offering you a million dollars for one night. Look, if that's fine with you to not get that million dollars, that's okay.
第二，他能够对人们说：“你们需要这笔钱，对吧？你们想要这笔钱。”所以，你们怎么承担得起不接受的后果？你们怎么承担得起对这个说不、从而失去这数百万美元的后果？这就好比——我的意思是，跟摩西打交道就像每天都在上演电影《桃色交易》里的情节，罗伯特·雷德福和黛米·摩尔那样，基本上就是：“你承担得起不跟我做这笔交易的后果吗？我不知道你能不能，因为我正在为一晚上的时间给你一百万美元。”听着，如果你觉得不拿那一百万美元也无所谓，那也行。
And it's like he's saying that to every borough president constantly, but instead of one night of carnal desire, it's generations of having a highway built over your neighborhood, yeah. Yeah, so this is sort of like how he has taken this old-fashioned thing of just giving money to people, holding money as a controlling factor.
他就好像一直在对每一个区长这么说，只不过把“一晚上的肉欲欢愉”换成了“你的社区上方世世代代被修建一条高速公路”。是的。所以，这就好比他是如何采用这种老派的做法——直接给人们送钱，把资金作为一种控制手段。
And even though Moses can sort of present himself as above the board using the institutions that are the way that they're supposed to be used, he can kind of exact the same ends as some kind of mob boss in the politics of 50 years before. It's pretty much the same thing. And this is kind of what this chapter is all about. And it's really fascinating. And it just reminds you that Moses is just a sui generis
尽管摩西可以把自己包装成超越党派、完全按照既定规则利用机构办事的正人君子，但他依然能达到与50年前政坛上的那些黑帮老大完全相同的目的。这几乎是一回事。这正是本章的核心所在。它真的非常迷人。它再次提醒你，摩西在世界上绝对是个独一无二
like figure in the world. Like the fact that he can stay clean, he can prop up all these institutions, he can hold this public perception of him, have so much control, be such a bully in so many different ways, and have none of it stick because he has set up the laws and the institutions all around him to make him just the most powerful figure.
的存在。他能保持清白，他能支撑起所有这些机构，他能维持公众对他的看法，拥有如此巨大的控制权，在许多不同方面都表现得像个霸凌者，却能让所有的负面影响都无法沾身——因为他已经建立起了环绕在自己周围的法律和机构，使他成为了最强大的大人物。
I mean, the power broker, I guess, is what you'd maybe call him. Maybe call him that. I mean, that's what he finally gets called at the end of this chapter. At the end, Carol dubs him the supreme power broker, and it's like, it feels like when you're watching a movie and they say the title of the movie in the movie,
我的意思是，“权力掮客”大概就是你会称呼他的头衔吧？或许就叫他这个。我的意思是，这正是他在本章末尾获得的外号。最后，卡罗称他为“至高无上的权力掮客”，这感觉就像你在看电影时，剧中人突然说出了电影片名，
and you're like, oh, they got there, they did it. And so much of this, what makes it's almost like- I feel like you're the captain of America right now. Yeah. Yeah, that's really, we really did get caught up in some Star Wars today. Oh, let's say, yeah, it's a great, I mean, they say welcome to Jurassic Park, that makes sense.
然后你会想：“哦，他们做到了，他们终于到了这一步。”这一切的构成，简直让人觉得——我感觉你现在就像美国队长一样。是的。是的，没错，我们今天真的不知不觉聊了很多《星球大战》的话题。哦，咱们说回……是的，这很棒，我的意思是，他们说“欢迎来到侏罗纪公园”，这在语境下说得通。
In context, it makes sense. It would make sense he would say welcome to Jurassic Park. That makes sense. In context, it makes sense. It would make sense he would say welcome to his park that he made for people. But other movies doesn't quite work. It's almost like if you were looking... So I'm going to try to be like Caro and be probing. And I think that's Moses' strength too. And I think ultimately when you get to it, Moses' ultimate strength is that he can see beneath the surface of things to how they really operate underneath. He kind of has no, or at least knows how to do the research to find that out.
在那个语境下，这就说得通。他说“欢迎来到侏罗纪公园”是合情合理的。这在语境下很合理。他说“欢迎来到他为人们建造的公园”是完全合乎逻辑的。但在其他电影里就没那么贴切了。这几乎就像你在寻找……所以我要试着像卡罗那样去刨根问底。我想这也是摩西的优势所在。我想归根结底，摩西最大的优势在于他能看透事物表象之下真实的运作机制。他基本上洞察一切，或者至少知道如何通过研究去找出真相。
Cause Carol says that academics studying the working of the New York City government at this time, they didn't really see what was actually happening. They thought the board of estimates still had this held this power and they, they couldn't see that it was all a facade and Carol says the proof is in the way that Robert Moses stops showing up for board of estimate meetings when they call him he doesn't explain his plans before they go up for a vote like if the person in the power position is the one that is not showing up for meetings like the person who says hey can you come explain this to me that person is not in power the person who
因为卡罗说过，当时研究纽约市政府运作机制的学者们并没有真正看清实际发生了什么。他们以为估税委员会仍然拥有权力，他们看不出这一切都只是个虚有其表的门面。卡罗指出，证据就在于：当估税委员会开会时，罗伯特·摩西根本懒得出席；当他们传唤他时，他甚至不会在付诸表决前解释自己的计划。如果说掌权的人反而是那个开会不出席的人——就像那个说“嘿，你能来向我解释一下吗”的人——那这个人其实并没有掌握权力。而那个说
goes no I'm not going to vote on it anyway that's the person who says, hey, can you come explain this to me? That person is not in power. The person who goes, no, I'm not going to vote on it anyway, that's the person with power. And so he has upended basically the whole system of this city in that way. He is not responsible to the public. Voters have no ability to affect him because he has this alliance of money, banks, unions, businesses, political bosses, fear. He has made essentially his own process that exists slightly outside of the democratic process. And it seems like that's his, maybe his most amazing genius insight is,
“不，反正我不会去投票”的人，才是真正掌握权力的人。因此，他用这种方式颠覆了这座城市的整个系统。他无需向公众负责。选民们对他是无可奈何的，因为他拥有资金、银行、工会、企业、政治大佬以及恐惧所构成的同盟。他基本上建立了自己的运作流程，这个流程稍微游离于民主程序之外。这似乎是他最惊人的天才洞察：
I don't have to corrupt the democratic process the way the Tammany bosses used to. I can replace it. I can replace it with something different that operates off to the side, is centralized around me, and just doesn't need to deal with these people. And when it does deal with ordinary New Yorkers, treats them as obstacles or inconveniences. And Robert Carroll would never make this comparison. I think it's probably outside of his frame of reference. I don't know. Maybe I'll have to ask him when we talk to him next.
“我不需要像当年的坦慕尼协会大佬那样去腐蚀民主程序。我可以取代它。我可以把它换成一套不同的系统，它在旁边悄然运行，以我为核心，根本不需要搭理这些家伙。”而当它确实需要与普通的纽约人打交道时，就把他们视为绊脚石或累赘。罗伯特·卡罗绝不会做出这种比喻。我想这大概超出了他的认知框架。我不知道。也许下次我们和他交流时我可以问问他。
But Moses is feeling very much like Cthulhu at this point, like a kind of lovecrafty and elder god who has his own plans and does not even notice the people that he's crushing beneath his feet as he reaches out to the cosmos to exert his madness, to far off distant worlds. If this was the end of Moses' story, he would have reached the apex of untouchable power. You know, and he's, he's taken these things and he has totally, like we're saying, not subverted the democratic process, but removed himself from it. He's escaped from it. And as a result, he is shaping the city physically. He's reshaping its institutions, how it operates. Uh, he is again, I hate, I'm going to do it one more time.
但在这个时候，摩西给人的感觉非常像克苏鲁，就像那种洛夫克拉夫特式的旧日支配者，有着他自己的宏伟计划，当他伸出触手去触及宇宙、将他的疯狂施加到遥远的世界时，他甚至都不会去注意脚下被他碾碎的人。如果这是摩西故事的结局，他将抵达无可撼动的权力巅峰。你知道的，他接手了这些事务，并且完全——正如我们所说——没有去颠覆民主程序，而是把自己从其中抽离了出去。他从那个系统中逃逸了。其结果就是，他在物理上塑造着这座城市，重塑着它的机构以及运作方式。呃，我再次——我讨厌这么做，我要再用一次这个比喻。
This is my last time making a modern day parallel. I apologize, which is going to be hard when we get to mere MP who is, who is also has a lot of modern day parallels, but he is kind of doing to New York in a way what Donald Trump seems to want to do with the United States and making it not a system of elections and checks, but instead a system that uses raw power to respond to the desires of one person and the plans of one person. And it's very chilling. It's a very chilling thing. And it's very scary to think about, even knowing this is many, many, this is decades ago, but knowing that this potential still lies at the heart of American democracy,
这是我最后一次做当代现实的比对。我深表歉意，不过等我们讲到……时这会很难避免，因为那家伙也有很多当代现实的映射。但他对纽约的做法，某种程度上就像唐纳德·特朗普似乎想要对美国做的那样：让它不再是一个依靠选举和制衡的系统，而变成一个利用绝对权力来响应某个人欲望和计划的系统。这非常让人不寒而栗。这是一个令人脊背发凉的想法。回想起来——尽管这是几十年前的事了——但一想到这种潜在威胁依然潜藏在美利坚民主的核心之中，
that it's not ironclad. It relies on the people who are operating it to operate it, at the very least with an acceptance of the basic premises of democracy. Because if there's someone who comes in who does not accept those basic premises, who thinks that a system where Ivy League graduates just draw roads straight through maps and then dig them through neighborhoods
它就并非坚不可摧。它依赖于操作它的人至少能够在一开始接受民主的基本前提去运转它。因为如果来了一个不接受这些基本前提、认为“由常春藤盟校毕业生直接在地图上画出公路、然后将其强行穿过社区且不听取任何人意见”的系统是理所当然的人，
and don't listen to anybody, if that person has access to the levers of the machine, then it can get really scary. And at this point, it makes me glad that like, Robert Moses, this sounds strange, but that Robert Moses was so into roads and so into building things, as opposed to any number of more terrible things
如果这样的人掌握了这台机器的控制杆，那情况就会变得非常可怕。正因如此，每当此时，我反而会感到庆幸——罗伯特·摩西（这听起来可能有点奇怪）是如此痴迷于修路和搞建设，而不是去搞其他许许多多更可怕的事情，
that he might've been doing. You know? Yeah. Yeah. I mean, and what I think about this, these, this whole system that he shored up and sort of exploited to do what he wanted. You know, when people talk a little bit about like,
他本来完全可以去做的。你知道吗？是的。是的。我的意思是，每当我想到这一点——他巩固并利用来达成自己目的的整套系统。你知道的，当人们偶尔会谈论起诸如：
I'd be so great if there was just a Moses type who could get things done, but get things done the way I want to, you know, there's a couple reasons why there aren't anymore. One is the lesson of Robert Moses and people like him built in, you know, we built in new safety guardrails to stop them. There's no city construction coordinator in New York, as far as I can tell, these days, yeah. Exactly. And the second is like, you know, he put himself as the controller of all these levers.
“要是能有一个像摩西那样能把事情办成、并且能按我想要的方式把事情办成的人，那就太棒了”时，（你知道的），为什么现在已经没有这种人了，其实有几个原因。首先是罗伯特·摩西及类似人物留下的教训，我们为此建立起了新的安全护栏来阻止他们。据我所知，如今纽约已经没有城市建设统筹专员这一职位了，对吧？正是如此。其次是，你知道的，他把自己摆在了所有这些控制杆的操控者位置。
So like, you just imagine him like in the center of this, like NASA style, pushing buttons, pulling levers, making everything happen. He constructed this in a way to work the way he wanted it to work. But like all those bureaucracies and all those things built up actually slowed things down. Like when somebody wasn't at the center
所以，你可以想象他就像置身于这样一个NASA风格的中心，按动按钮、拉动杠杆，让一切运转起来。他构建这个系统就是为了让它按他期望的方式运作。但像所有那些庞大的官僚机构和积累起来的事物，实际上反而把事情的速度拖慢了。当没有一个像他那样的人在中心
like him controlling everything, it actually broke down like a lot. Like he created the situation to make it so that no one could make things the way he did, not just because we're stopping the Moses from happening, but because no one can control it the way he did. Um, and so, so now all these things have roadblocks. You have a board of estimates who can say no, but can't say yes. You have, uh, you know, like you like all the, the dysfunction that it's created
掌控一切时，事情其实经常会陷入瘫痪。他创造的那种局面，导致日后没有任何人能像他那样去办成事情——这不仅是因为我们在竭力阻止另一个“摩西”的出现，更是因为根本没有人能像他那样掌控大局。因此，如今所有这些事情都充满了路障。你有一个可以投反对票但无法投赞成票的估税委员会。你拥有……你知道的，就像所有的那些功能失调一样——
when it isn't working together, like as an orchestra. It's a bunch of errant notes and squeaks and bad timing. There's no conductor at the center of it. And it made everything worse afterward. Like, I think these systems, you know, he broke down systems, like, not that, again, I don't want to go back to, we had this sort of discussion with Jamal Bowie, was like, I don't really want to go back to the days of turkeys
当它们不能像一个交响乐团那样协同工作时，它发出的就是一堆走调的音符、刺耳的杂音和糟糕的节拍。中心没有了指挥。这让后来的情况变得更糟。我觉得这些系统……他摧毁了许多系统——并不是说，再次强调，我不想回到过去——我们之前和贾马尔·鲍伊讨论过这个问题——我其实并不想回到充斥着裙带关系和利益输送的日子，
and patronage exactly, but like he really eliminated the responsiveness of local government to its constituents. Like he built and sort of fostered so many sort of like structures that got in the way of that, that something was lost. Some kind of way to get stuff done that represents the will of the people and moving something through in a quick and in a way that made sense. Even when everyone agrees, it's very, very hard because of these systems. He broke so many things.
但他的确消除了地方政府对选民诉求的响应能力。他建立和助长了那么多阻碍这种响应的结构，以至于有些东西彻底丢失了。某种能够办成代表人民意志的事情、并且以迅速且合理的方式推进事务的渠道没有了。哪怕所有人都达成一致，由于这些系统的存在，事情也变得极其、极其艰难。他毁掉了太多的东西。
He didn't just build roads that destroyed neighborhoods. Like he broke down systems that never, I don't think in a way never really recovered in a lot of ways in New York. Yeah, and it means that New York is a difficult city to do things. And I mean, and that's why people do call for sometimes for we need a Moses-like figure. Because if the systems are operating
他不仅仅是修建了摧毁社区的公路。他还拆解了各种系统，而这些系统在很大程度上，我觉得在纽约再也没有真正恢复过元气。是的，这意味着纽约成了一座办什么事都很艰难的城市。我的意思是，这也是为什么人们有时会呼唤我们需要一个“摩西式”的人物。因为如果系统本身是在按部就班地正常运转，你就不需要什么“摩西式”的人物。但他某种程度上促成了——我想美国政府中在中央集权和地方分权之间一直存在一种钟摆式的摇摆，来回反复，通常最终还是会偏向中央集权。如果你纵观美国历史，事情往往是走向集权多于分权，因为权力一旦落入权贵手中，要想再把权力从他们手里夺走是极其困难的。但这是一种把特定权力高度集中在某一个人手里的极端中央集权。
the way they're supposed to, you don't need a Moses-like figure. But he helped kind of, I guess there's this kind of pendulum swing in American government between centralization and decentralization that kind of goes back and forth and usually ends up more in the central. If you look at American history, things usually centralize more than they decentralize because it's hard to take power away from powerful people once they've got it. But this is kind of like ultra centralization in one person of this particular.
另外，我也不想陷入这种思维陷阱：仿佛纽约发生的每一件事都必须经过罗伯特·摩西之手。但任何涉及建筑、基建、交通的事——这些都是这座城市的核心部分——确实如此。不过，他已经不再是什么花椰菜主管了，他不再去管拳击比赛门票有没有发给对的人，你知道的。但话又说回来，一旦你围绕某个人构建了一个系统，而这个人消失了，这个系统就无法仅凭一个空白的中心维持下去，你也无法随随便便把另一个人塞进那个位置，还指望他们能把工作做好。你知道的，这就像
Also, I don't want to fall into the trap of thinking that every single thing in New York had to go through Robert Moses, but every single thing involving construction, transit, transportation, which are major parts of the city. But it's, I don't think it's not like he's not the curator of cauliflowers anymore. He's not making sure that the boxing matches, that the tickets are going out to the right people, you know. But yeah, once if you build something, if you build a system around a person and that person goes away, the system, it can't hold with a blanket at center and you can't necessarily just pop somebody else in there and expect them to do the job properly. You know, it's the thing
你在脱口秀里看到的那样，说实话，经常发生在深夜脱口秀节目里：当一位深受喜爱的脱口秀主持人退休后，换上了一个新人，人们就会觉得：“这个节目好像有点不一样了。它的运作感觉不太对劲。”这就对了，因为这个节目本身就是围绕着那个主持人构建的，如果你换了人，你就得连周围的整套机器一起改造。城市建设统筹专员也是同样的道理，
you see in talk shows, to be honest, in late night talk shows often, where there's a beloved talk show host and they retire and a new person gets put in and people are like, the show is not quite the same. It doesn't quite work the same way. It's like, yeah, cause the show was built around the host and if you change it, you have to change the machine around it and it's a similar thing with city construction coordinators,
他们就是纽约政治世界的深夜脱口秀主持人。完全同意。我想我的观点是：并不是罗伯特·摩西一个人“摧毁了纽约”或者直接导致了纽约的衰落（正如书名所暗示的那样），完全是因为他的野心和那些他想要完成的项目。
the late night talk show hosts of the New York political world. Totally. And I guess that's my point is that it isn't so much or isn't just that Robert Moses, you know, destroyed or led to the fall of New York as in the title because of his ambitions and because of the things he wanted to get done.
而是他办成事情的那个方法，彻底瓦解了原有的系统，以至于再也没有人能够以同样的方式重新把它们拼凑起来去办成事情了。这产生了深远的影响，这也是摩西留下的又一个持久效应。我不知道，我们在下一章里也许会看到一连串充满活力、令人兴奋、极具开拓精神的市长们登场。也许这正是我们在下一章里会看到的。我想只有一种方法能找到答案。接下来我们要讲的是第34章《摩西与市长们》。所以我们回来了，继续探讨第34章《摩西与市长们》。你知道的，如果你想
The method which he got things done broke down systems that no one could quite put together again to get things done ever again quite the same way. And it was, it had, that's another lasting effect of Moses. I don't, I don't know the Roman in the next chapter we'll see maybe a string of dynamic mares, dynamic, really exciting, really, uh, you know, pioneering mares will be able to do it. Maybe that's what we'll get in the next chapter. I guess only one way to find out. We're going gonna cover chapter 34, Moses and the Mayors after this. So we're back with chapter 34, Moses and the Mayors, and you know, if you want
在这部传记的时间线上理出头绪的话，这一章确实跳出了时间线，因为他将通过这一部分里继拉瓜迪亚之后的每一位市长的小传和深刻教训来进行剖析。是的，这一章完全可以叫做《那些不配拥有自己专属章节的市长们》。所以它有点像三位拉瓜迪亚之后的市长的微型传记、微型历史，让我们深入了解他们。这一章被分成几个小节，以每位市长的名字作为每个小节的标题，这也是我们在书中第一次见到这种结构。我想这可能是唯一的一次。我正在努力回想。这种排版非常……某种程度上让人觉得有点突兀，但又有一种令人兴奋的感觉，好像卡罗在说：“没错，我想怎么构架这本书就怎么构架。这才是这一章最合理的呈现方式。我才不需要受制于其他章节都没有小标题的规矩呢。”
to get out of the timeline when it comes to this biography. This chapter really gets out of the timeline because he's going to go through these mini biographies and sort of abject lessons for each of the three mayors that succeed LaGuardia in this section. Yes, it could be called Moses and the mayors that didn't deserve their own chapters. So it's kind of like mini biographies, mini histories, these three post LaGuard mayors, and let's dive into them. And this chapter is divided up into subsections with the mayor's name as the heading of each, and it's the first time we see this in the book. I think it might be the only time. I'm trying to remember. And it's very – there's something about this that's kind of jarring, but there's also something kind of exciting about it that like, Carol's like, yeah, I'll structure this book the way I want to. Like, this is the way it makes sense for this chapter. I don't need to be beholden to just that none of the other chapters had sub-eddings, you
为了脱离这个传记的时间线。这一章确实打破了时间线，因为他要讲述这三位在这一部分中接替拉瓜迪亚的市长的迷你传记以及各自的教训。是的，它可以被称为“摩西与那些不配拥有自己章节的市长们”。所以这有点像迷你传记、迷你历史，关于这三位后拉瓜迪亚时期的市长，让我们深入了解他们。这一章分成了几个小节，以每位市长的名字作为每个小节的标题，这是我们在书中第一次看到这种结构。我想这可能是唯一的一次。我在努力回想。这感觉非常——这种安排有点让人感到突兀，但同时也有一种令人兴奋的感觉，就好像卡洛在说：“好吧，我想怎么构思这本书就怎么构思。就像，这才是这一章最合理的呈现方式。我不需要受限于其他章节都没有小标题这一事实，你"
know? It's actually pretty crazy because when you're editing things, and I edit a lot of stories for the show for 900% Invisible, that there's often this idea that you need a kind of consistency across an episode, maybe a couple of episodes, and how you do and format things. And he's just like 800 pages in, just like, fuck it, subheads with major names.
你知道吗？其实这挺疯狂的，因为当你剪辑内容时——我在为“99%无形”节目剪辑过很多故事——通常会有一种观念，认为一集或几集节目之间需要某种一致性，包括你做事和排版的方式。而他呢，在写了800页之后，直接不管了，加上了带有大人物名字的小标题。
He just like, he doesn't, I mean, I'm sure he cared. I'm sure he was super thoughtful about it. I'm sure like- I'm sure he and Robert Gottlieb probably had discussions or arguments about this for weeks, is my guess. I kind of love the fact that it doesn't, it isn't a style used in any other part.
他就是这样，他才不——我是说，我确信他在意过。我确信他对此深思熟虑过。我确信……我确信他和罗伯特·戈特利布（Robert Gottlieb）可能为此讨论或争论了好几个星期，我猜是这样的。我其实挺喜欢这种风格的，它在其他任何地方都没用过。
It just shows, it goes to show you that like, when it comes to most things, when it comes to editing most things, to me, like solving the immediate problem of clarity is like 95% of what you need to do. And that sort of little bit of just like, yeah, but what if there aren't subheadings in other sections and what if this is like,
这恰恰说明，这向你证明了，当涉及大多数事情时，当涉及剪辑大多数事情时，对我来说，解决眼前的清晰度问题大概占了你需要做的事情的95%。而那种有点像“好吧，但为什么其他章节没有小标题，如果这是……”
the audience does not care. Like they just don't care. If it's working, it's working. Um, anyway. But it also means we don't have to have three full, full chapters. 92, I mean, still long chapters, still 51 page chapter, but it means that Carol doesn't have to worry about writing like intros and outros for individual mayors, which is great, like save that energy.
观众根本不在乎。他们就是不在乎。只要它行得通，就行。嗯，不管怎样。但这同时也意味着我们不必写完完整整的三章。92，我是说，依然是很长的章节，还有51页的长章，但这意味着卡罗不必担心为每位市长单独写引言和结语了，这挺好的，可以省点力气。
You just used up a lot of energy with that last chapter. You save it up for more stuff. So it's a marathon. It's not a sprint, Robert Caro, we know that. So we start with O'Dwyer. So when we last left the chronological timeline, O'Dwyer had just been elected. He's the Tammany Democrat.
你刚才在上一章里已经耗费了大量精力。把它攒起来对付更多事情吧。所以这是一场马拉松。这不是一场短跑，罗伯特·卡罗，我们知道这一点。所以我们从欧德怀（O'Dwyer）开始讲起。那么，当我们上次离开时间线时，欧德怀刚刚当选。他是坦慕尼协会（Tammany）的民主党人。
He's this charismatic Irishman. He started out as just an immigrant laborer and worked his way up to being mayor of New York. How did he do it? Two ways Roman, hard work and shadowy connections to organized crime. And they seem to play equal roles in this. And O'Dwyer, you can tell when Caro is kind of like affectionate towards some of the subjects. And also when he talked to him in person, you can tell he talked to O'Dwyer.
他是个极具个人魅力的爱尔兰人。他最初只是个移民苦力，一路奋斗成为了纽约市长。他是怎么做到的？罗曼，有两种方法，努力工作以及与有组织犯罪的暗中勾结。而且它们在这其中似乎起到了同样重要的作用。说到欧德怀，你能看出卡罗对某些采访对象其实是怀有某种喜爱的。而且当他亲自与他交谈时，你可以看出他跟欧德怀谈过。
He went to Mexico City. And hiding in Mexico City. To talk to O'Dwyer, He went to Mexico City to talk to O'Dwyer. We'll get into why he's in, why the mayor of New York lives in Mexico City at the end of his life. But he's, you can tell that he kind of admires the hardworking immigrant part of O'Dwyer. And O'Dwyer clearly loves New York. He wants to be a good mayor, but New York needs massive investments in its basic infrastructure, schools, subways, hospitals, sewers, airports.
他去了墨西哥城。躲在墨西哥城。为了跟欧德怀谈话，他去了墨西哥城跟欧德怀交谈。我们待会儿会讲到他为什么在——为什么纽约市长在他生命的晚年住在墨西哥城。但他——你能看出他有点钦佩欧德怀努力工作的那一部分移民经历。而且欧德怀显然热爱纽约。他想当一个好市长，但纽约的基础设施、学校、地铁、医院、下水道、机场都需要巨额投资。
They all suck. They're all in bad shape. And it's going to take about one and a half billion dollars. Again, this is in 1946. So one and a half billion dollars is a lot of money back then, not like now when it's not that much money. And oh, do I ever find, I'm just, I'm joking. Of course, it's still an astronaut.
它们全都不行。它们都破烂不堪。这大概需要十五亿美元。再说一次，这是在1946年。所以十五亿美元在当时是一大笔钱，不像现在这笔钱不算什么。噢，我发现了吗，我只是——我在开玩笑。当然，这依然是一笔巨款。
Well, you know, every, I just, just as a little bit of an aside, um, you know, that chapter that I love, that's about the $109 million he has to raise to do the entire West Side improvement. And I think about that $109 million to change the face of the entire West Side of the island of Manhattan is just mind boggling. Like to me. Anyway, that's the number that sticks in my head the most because it seems so low for that much stuff.
好吧，你知道，每当——我只是顺便提一句，你知道的，我特别喜欢的那一章，讲的是他为了完成整个西区改造必须筹集1.09亿美元。每当我想象那1.09亿美元竟然能改变曼哈顿岛整个西区的面貌时，我都觉得不可思议。对我来说就是这样。不管怎样，这是最深刻印在我脑海里的数字，因为对于那么多工程来说，它看起来实在是太低了。
Yes, it would be an enormous deal. I mean, I think it would be like a trillion dollars today or something, like craziness. I mean, it would be impossibly expensive at this point. Yeah, it would be, it's amazing. It's why it would have been better if a lot of this stuff in terms of like subway lines had happened then because they're now so incredibly expensive.
是的，那将是一笔惊天巨款。我的意思是，我觉得放到今天大概相当于一万亿美元左右，简直疯狂。我的意思是，到了现在，这已经是不可能完成的天文数字了。对，确实如此，太惊人了。这就是为什么如果当初这些事情（比如地铁线路）能在那时搞定就好了，因为它们现在实在是贵得离谱。
So O'Dwyer needs one and a half billion dollars for this construction program. He goes, okay, how much money does the city have? And they go, uh, none. Zero. Actually worse than zero because everything's running at a deficit, like hundreds of millions of dollars a year in just paying
所以欧德怀需要十五亿美元来搞这个建设规划。他去问：市政府有多少钱？他们回答：呃，没有。零。实际上比零还糟，因为所有项目都在赤字运营，光是支付……
awful bills and Moses, like an angel or a devil on his shoulder, he shows up to answer the mayor's prayers, a rhyming phrase that Caro does not use, but I'm introducing, uh, with a plan to fund city construction projects. He's like, look, hey, all you have to do is Idlewild Airport, which is now JFK Airport, Idlewild Airport, it needs a lot of work. Just turn it over to a public authority
可怕的账单每年就要亏损数亿美元。而摩西就像他肩头的天使或恶魔一样出现了，来回应市长的祈祷——这是一个卡罗没有用、但我加上去的押韵短语——带着一个为城市建设筹资的计划。他就像是说：听着，嘿，你只需要把艾德怀尔机场（Idlewild Airport，现在的肯尼迪机场）——艾德怀尔机场需要大量改造——直接交给一个公共机构，
and then raise toll revenues by increasing the price of the subway fare of 100% from a nickel to a dime. And look, you can just put it under my control and do all this stuff, we'll take care of it. Look, public housing, we can build that affordably, just get rid of the other guys doing it, put me in charge, cut down on frills like closet doors and toilet bowl covers, as long as you cut down on those expensive luxuries, then we can do it. And you know what would give the city extra
然后通过将地铁票价从五美分提高到十美分（涨幅100%）来增加通行费收入。听着，你只要把它置于我的控制之下，搞定所有这些事情，我们来善后。听着，公共住房，我们可以低成本建造，只要赶走负责这事的其他人，把我放在领导岗位上，削减像壁橱门和马桶盖这样的花哨玩意儿，只要你砍掉这些昂贵的奢侈品，我们就能把它建起来。你知道什么能给城市带来额外的……
borrowing power? Raise the sales tax and the utilities taxes. And he also says, give me the authority to negotiate on behalf of the city with Albany. I'll get it done. I'll tell you which projects can be deferred. Guess what? Schools, libraries, hospitals, firehouses, we can defer those. You know what kind of projects we can't defer? Highways. We need to build those now.
借贷能力吗？提高销售税和公用事业税。他还说：把代表城市与奥尔巴尼（州首府）谈判的权力交给我。我能搞定。我来告诉你哪些项目可以延期。你猜怎么着？学校、图书馆、医院、消防局，我们可以把这些延期。你知道什么样的项目不能延期吗？高速公路。我们现在就得把它们建起来。
And his plan, Carol points out, is codifying Moses' personal beliefs about who is worth taking care of and who is not. By raising subway fares and utility taxes, you are putting the tax burden on the lower classes. By not raising real estate taxes, you are lifting the tax burden on the upper classes. By building roads, you are creating services for the people who can afford cars. By not investing in the subway, you are removing services or you are degrading services for people who cannot afford cars by not investing in the subway, you are removing services or you are degrading services for people who cannot afford cars.
卡罗指出，他的计划将摩西的个人信念法典化了，即谁值得照顾，谁不值得照顾。通过提高地铁票价和公用事业税，你把税收负担压在了下层阶级身上。通过不提高房地产税，你减轻了上层阶级的税收负担。通过修建道路，你为买得起车的人创造了便利。通过不投资地铁，你剥夺了那些买不起车的人的交通服务，或者说恶化了他们的出行条件（重复翻译已修正）。
He's effectively asking the city's poor to subsidize improvements for the city's rich and upper middle class. But it's all really to help his stuff. He goes, if the subway is self-sustaining, something it's never been before, and ever since then it's been trying to be the same way that they always want the post office
他实际上是在要求城市的穷人去补贴城市富裕阶层和中产阶级上层的设施改善。但这其实全是为了帮他自己的项目。他说，如果地铁能够自负盈亏——这是它以前从未做到过的，而且自那以后它一直试图保持这种状态，就像他们总是希望邮局……
to be self-sustaining. And it's like, it's good that to be the same way that they always want the post office to be self-sustaining. And it's like, it's good that you can mail something and it goes anywhere. Like, but anyway, it's a public service. He says if the subway is self-sustaining, then the city's debt borrowing limit basically adds $425 million, which was going to the subway and now doesn't have to. And he's like, I could really use $425 million to build some new roads and some new bridges and things like that. I would really use $425 million to build some new roads and some new bridges and things like that. I would really like that.
能够自负盈亏一样。这就好比——你能寄信而且它能送到任何地方，这是一件好事。但不管怎样，这是一个公共服务。他说，如果地铁能够自负盈亏，那么城市的债务借贷上限基本上就会增加4.25亿美元，这笔钱原本要贴补地铁，现在不用了。他就像是说：我真的可以用这4.25亿美元来建一些新道路、新桥梁之类的东西。我真的会很喜欢这样。
And as a result, the subway system, it does not become self-sustaining and it does not get modernized the way it needs to. And New York has been paying for that shift in priorities for at least the last three decades. Certainly the entire time I lived in New York City, subway closures, shutdowns, slowdowns were an enormous problem.
结果就是，地铁系统没有实现自负盈亏，也没有得到它所需要的现代化改造。在过去的至少三十年里，纽约一直在为这种优先级的转变付出代价。当然，在我住在纽约市的整个时间里，地铁关闭、停运、减速一直是个大问题。
And just the fact that it, even when you're waiting on a platform in this New York City subway, it feels like you are inside of an oven. It feels like you're in the story of, is it what, Rack Shack and the three guys in the Bible who get thrown in a bull and that is an oven that gets lit on fire. That's what it feels like to be in the subways in the summer. It's terrible. I mean, this is so galling that not only of the list of villainous deeds that Robert Moses was a part of, that the fact that every ounce of it was paid for by the people with the least amount of money. It's just, it is the part that makes this
而且事实是，甚至当你站在纽约市地铁的站台等车时，你都会觉得自己像是待在烤箱里。感觉就像是圣经故事里的……是沙得拉、米煞和亚伯尼歌被扔进火窑里的那种感觉吗？那座会被点燃的火窑。夏天待在地铁里就是这种感觉。太糟糕了。我的意思是，这太让人气愤了，不仅因为罗伯特·摩西参与了一连串的恶劣行径，而且每一分钱竟然都是由最穷的人支付的。这正是……这部分内容让人感到……
so infuriating, especially, I mean, it just is gross. I just, it just makes me so mad. It is the opposite of the way a reasonable society should work, in my opinion, that people who have less should receive more help and the people who have more should give more help. You know what, call me a communist. I'm not, you can call me that, I don't care.
如此愤怒，尤其是，我的意思是，这简直太恶劣了。这太让我火大了。在我看来，这完全违背了一个合理社会应有的运作方式：拥有较少的人应该得到更多帮助，拥有更多的人应该贡献更多帮助。你知道吗，叫我共产主义者好了。我不是，但你随便怎么叫我，我不在乎。
But don't really call me that. Robert Moses will get me in trouble for it. But certainly even if it's sort of just whatever, you know, like there is no, you know, progressivity or regressivity. Like if it's just equal, like that would be an improvement over the degree of aggressiveness when it comes to this form of taking money from people, you know, to have roads to go through Manhattan. It takes from the people of Manhattan that are just trying to get to work. It just, it's really, really upsetting how tilted it is towards the people who don't need it.
不过别真这么叫我。罗伯特·摩西会因此给我惹上麻烦的。但当然，哪怕这只是某种无所谓的……你知道，这里面没有任何进步性或倒退性可言。如果它只是平等的——那也比从人们手里强行搜刮金钱来修建穿过曼哈顿的道路的这种侵略性程度要好。它从那些只想去上班的曼哈顿普通人身上榨取钱财。这种对不需要它的人严重倾斜的做法，真的、真的很让人心烦。
So yeah, and understandably liberal reformers, they don't like this plan, even not quite dead yet. Mayor LaGuardia and the current city comptroller, they point out, hey, the city has overpaid tax payments to the state by over half a billion dollars. Why don't they send that back to us and we'll use it for construction? And Democratic legislators are like, yeah, we would rather not run for reelection on a tax increase and a fair increase. We're not crazy about this plan.
所以，理所当然地，自由派改革者不喜欢这个计划，就连还没完全过气的拉瓜迪亚（LaGuardia）市长和现任市主计长也指出：嘿，市里多交了给州的税款超过五亿美元。为什么不把这笔钱退给我们，我们把它用来搞建设呢？而民主党议员们的态度则是：是的，我们宁愿不为了增税和涨票价去竞选连任。我们对这个计划可不怎么感冒。
And most of his response, he's got a simple response, he threatens to reveal embarrassing information about the party leadership, and they whip the party in line, and they get behind Moses. And the city comptroller can say whatever he wants, he does not have the influence in Albany, in the state capital, that Moses has. And O'Dwyer, in the telling of this chapter, seems to be entirely absent in any of the negotiations between the city and the state. Moses is the only go-between. He misrepresents each side's position.
而摩西的回应很简单，他威胁要公开关于党内领导层的尴尬黑料，于是他们迅速整顿党内纪律，转而支持摩西。市主计长想说什么就说什么，他在奥尔巴尼（州首府）根本没有摩西那种影响力。而在本章的叙述中，在市与州的任何谈判中，欧德怀似乎都完全隐形了。摩西是唯一的中间人。他歪曲了每一方的立场。
He lies to the public about it. O'Dwyer, I don't know what he's doing at this point. I mean, being mayor is a busy job. There's other stuff. But he brokers this deal that they're going to raise the fares, they're going to raise taxes. Moses, in exchange, he gets all this new money to play with. He gets control of the airport authority.
他为此对公众撒谎。欧德怀，我不知道他此时在干什么。我的意思是，当市长是个忙碌的差事。还有别的事。但他促成了这笔交易：他们要涨票价，他们要加税。作为交换，摩西得到了所有这些可以随意支配的新资金。他控制了机场管理局。
He gets even more bond issuing power. He finally gets to take over the tunnel authority completely. And the legislature won't let him become chairman of the city housing authority, but they reorganize it in a way that he still basically has control of it. And the state even, they go, okay, we'll give you the funds for your Jones Beach Marine Theater that you want to build so badly, this theater on Jones Beach. And we'll get in the next episode, we'll talk some more about Moses's use of theaters and misuse of theaters. What did the state get out of this deal? Governor Dewey, he gets to hold onto the city's surplus tax money, which means he gets to, he can
他获得了更大的债券发行权。他终于完全接管了隧道管理局。虽然州议会不允许他担任城市住房管理局主席，但他们重组了该机构，使得他基本上依然拥有控制权。州政府甚至表示：好吧，我们会给你资金来建造你梦寐以求的琼斯海滩海洋剧场（Jones Beach Marine Theater），这个建在琼斯海滩的剧场。我们会在下一集里，继续聊聊摩西对剧场的使用和滥用。那州政府在这笔交易中得到了什么？州长杜威（Dewey）得以保留市里的巨额税收盈余，这意味着他可以……
cut state taxes. He can run on that. What does Mayor Dwyer get? He gets big construction projects he can point to when he runs for reelection in three years. What does the city get? It gets tax increases. It gets fare increases. What do the democratic legislators get? They get kicked out in the next election because they get blamed for all that. Yeah. And Moses gets power. He gets so much power and O'Dwyer is relying
削减州税。他可以以此作为竞选政绩。欧德怀市长得到了什么？他得到了大型建设工程，可以在三年后竞选连任时作为政绩拿出来说事。市政府得到了什么？它得到了增税。它得到了票价上涨。民主党议员得到了什么？他们在下次选举中被赶下台，因为所有这些骂名都扣在了他们头上。是的。而摩西得到了权力。他得到了如此巨大的权力，而欧德怀却指望……
on him to basically recommend people to staff these different authorities. The airport authority committee, O'Dwyer doesn't even know who Moses picked until Moses sends them to the mayor's office to be sworn in and O'Dwyer never speaks to them. He just swears them in and never talks to them ever again. And Moses gets named chairman of the mayor's emergency committee on housing. He now holds nine city and state posts and he
他来为这些不同的管理局推荐工作人员。机场管理局的委员会成员是谁，欧德怀甚至都不知道，直到摩西把他们送到市长办公室宣誓就职，而欧德怀自始至终都没跟这些人说过话。他只是让他们宣誓就职，然后就再也没和他们说过话。摩西被任命为主席……市长住房紧急委员会主席。他现在身兼九个市级和州级职务，而且他……
has the power to pick the other committee members. So he just has so much power. Like it's all power. He's a real, I mean, the last chapter said it, he's a supreme power broker. He's got all the power, he can broker it. And this is when Caro starts, he refers to the hand of Bob, which I think is a very funny phrase for him to use, but it makes him sound like Bob the evil spirit from Twin Peaks that he has possessed Mayor OJ Weier and is making him do these terrible things. And now there's a kind of back and forth here where OJ Weier and Moses, they have a little bit of a petty thing. Moses is so confident, he starts talking openly about how much power he has over the mayor. The mayor gets mad.
拥有挑选其他委员会成员的权力。所以他拥有极其庞大的权力。全都是权力。他真是一个——上一章说得对，他是权力经纪人的终极Boss。他掌握了所有的权力，他可以进行调配。也就是在这个时候，卡罗开始提到“鲍勃之手”（the hand of Bob），我觉得这是一个非常滑稽的词，但这听起来让他像《双峰》里那个附身了欧德怀市长并迫使他做这些可怕事情的邪恶幽灵鲍勃。现在他们之间有了一种拉扯，欧德怀和摩西之间有了一点小小的摩擦。摩西信心满满，开始公开谈论他对市长有多么大的掌控力。市长生气了。
They have, you know, they, they have a little, at least kind of like petty power games where they kind of nibble away at each other's stuff in, in petty ways. And OJ wire is starting to recognize that all these big problems that Moses said he would address are not actually getting solved, that Moses is like, there's a housing crisis in the city. There's all these returning veterans. We need apartments for them. You know what we should do? Tear down tens of thousands of apartments to build expressways. And OJR is like, oh, well, that doesn't really seem to be solving the housing problem for
他们之间——你知道，他们有了一点——至少算是那种小肚鸡肠的权力游戏，他们在一些小事上互相蚕食对方的地盘。而欧德怀开始意识到，摩西承诺要解决的所有这些大问题其实根本没有解决，摩西的表现就像是——城里有住房危机。有这么多退伍军人在返乡。我们需要给他们找公寓。你知道我们该怎么做吗？拆掉几万套公寓来修建高速公路。而欧德怀的想法是：哦，好吧，这似乎并没有解决住房问题……
tearing down housing because we needed more housing. Moses had this kind of plan for the bonds for the airports to modernize the airports, which was that he would sell them to banks at a very highly inflated interest rate, just so generous that they have to buy them. And to pay off those bonds, he has to raise the rental fees for airlines 600%. And the airlines are like, we'll just go to Newark. Like, why, we don't need to pay that,
因为拆掉住房正是因为我们需要更多的住房。摩西针对机场债券、用于实现机场现代化改造的计划是这样的：他会以极高的溢价利率将债券卖给银行，利率丰厚到银行不得不买。为了偿还这些债券，他不得不把航空公司的租金提高600%。而航空公司的反应是：那我们去纽瓦克（Newark）得了。凭什么，我们没必要付这笔钱……
we'll go somewhere else. And O'Dwyer gets pissed and he takes Idlewild and LaGuardia airports away from Moses and gives them to the Port Authority, which is the lesser of two evils very much, you know. And this is when O'Dwyer, as a final, Moses, I'm not happy with you, gives the Department of the Interior the okay to take over Fort Clinton, saving it from being teared down after that decades-long crusade. So there's this back and forth, Moses tries his resignation threat, and O'Dwyer says to the messenger who brings it, tell the gentleman who sent this that if he wants
我们要去别的地方。欧德怀气坏了，他从摩西手里夺走了艾德怀尔机场和拉瓜迪亚机场，把它们交给了港务局（Port Authority）——这在很大程度上算是两害相权取其轻吧。就在这时，欧德怀作为对摩西最后的表态——“摩西，我对很不满”——批准内政部接管柯林顿堡（Fort Clinton），在经历了长达数十年的十字军东征般的争夺后，终于把它从拆迁的命运中拯救了下来。于是他们这样反复拉扯，摩西搬出了辞职威胁，而欧德怀对送信的信使说：告诉送信的那个人，如果他想让我接受，就再把它送回来一次。摩西没有这样做，但这就好比，欧德怀，拜托！你本来有机会的！你离成功就差那么一点！你离成功只有一步之遥！但他无法彻底这么做，因为摩西手中依然掌握着一种权力。正是那种我们将多次提及、而欧德怀偏偏不具备的权力。我们在本章开头讨论过。他有钱。如果欧德怀想竞选连任——正如我们后面会看到的，这在某种程度上结果变得有些无关紧要了——他就必须建造住房。
me to accept it, just send it back again. And Moses doesn't, but it's like, O'Dwyer, come on, you had it! You had the moment! You were so close. You were so close. But he can't fully do it, because there's a power that Moses still has. It's the power that we're going to mention so many times that O'Dwyer does not have. We talked about it at the beginning of this chapter. He has money. If O'Dwyer wants to run for reelection, which as we'll see, it turns out to be kind of a moot point in some ways, he needs to build housing.
他需要在建房的同时安置流离失所的人。他根本没有资金来做这件事。但摩西能弄到钱来做这件事。罗伯特·卡罗说：我不能说罗伯特·摩西利用他与州官员的影响力迫使欧德怀让摩西介入住房事务，但他确实指出，在1946年，欧德怀把摩西带去与州住房官员举行了一场秘密会议，会上州政府同意承担这个能够建造新住房的大型临时安置项目的所有费用。而宣布这笔资金的声明中说，该资金是由罗伯特·摩西和威廉·欧德怀市长代表市政府接受的，而且是按这个顺序，罗伯特·摩西的名字排在前面。所以看起来……
He needs to relocate people while housing is built. He doesn't have the money to do that. Moses can get the money to do that. And Robert Caro says, I can't say that Robert Moses used his influence with state officials to force O'Dwyer to get Moses involved in housing, but he does lay out that in 1946, O'Dwyer brings Moses to a secret meeting with state housing officials, in which the state agrees to pay the full cost of this big temporary relocation projects that can build new housing. And the statement announcing those funds says it is accepted on behalf of the city by Robert Moses and Mayor William O'Dwyer in that order with Robert Moses name first. So it seems,
我的意思是，线索就摆在那里，我们可以把它们连起来，也可以不连。而摩西在和市长、和所有人玩着同一个游戏。如果你按我说的做，联邦资金的水龙头就会打开。如果你不按我说的做，水龙头就会关掉。这就引出了摩西的一个计划，让欧德怀兴奋不已，这也许是罗伯特·摩西为他的任何项目制定的最疯狂的计划。把炮台公园（Battery Park）改造成一条高速公路的入口匝道，横跨曼哈顿下城和布鲁克林之间的水域。
I mean, the dots are there, we can connect them or not. And Moses plays this game with the mayor, they place with everybody. If you're doing what I want, the tribal money FOSA gets turned on. If you don't do what I want, it gets turned off. And this leads to this plan of Moses that O'Dwyer becomes so excited about that is perhaps the craziest plan that Robert Moses has for any of his projects. Now, taking Battery Park and turning it into essentially an on-ramp for a highway that goes over across the water between lower Manhattan, Brooklyn.
这已经是个疯狂的计划了。这相当疯狂。但是，罗曼，你能想出一个更疯狂的地方来修建高速公路吗？嗯，那就是穿过曼哈顿中城和曼哈顿下城。没错。现在曼哈顿中城和曼哈顿下城……
That's a crazy plan. That's pretty crazy. But Roman, can you think of an even crazier place to build an expressway? Well, there's a through Midtown Manhattan and through lower Manhattan. That's right. Now Midtown Manhattan and lower Manhattan,
曼哈顿下城，那些是非常、非常密集的区域，曼哈顿下城的建筑也很小。曼哈顿中城，那是帝王大厦（Empire State Building）所在地。那么你会不会——你绝不可能在帝王大厦中间修一条高速公路吧？你会吗？
lower Manhattan, those are pretty, pretty dense areas, lower Manhattan, the buildings are small as well. Midtown Manhattan, that's where like say the Empire State Building is located. So would you have, you couldn't possibly run an expressway through the Empire State Building. Would you?
嗯，你知道吗？如果你把它画得足够漂亮，你某种程度上还真可以。而且，我想我们在前面某一集的这本书的图片部分提到过，有一张曼哈顿中城高速公路的艺术效果图，它直接穿过大楼内部，看起来太酷了。但你需要花几分钟时间回过神来才会想：这太可怕了。这对于大楼里的人、地面上的人、车里的人来说……
Well, you know what? If you draw it nice enough, you kind of can. And there's, I think we mentioned earlier episode in the picture section of this book, there is an artist rendering of this midtown Manhattan Expressway that goes through buildings and it looks so cool. But it takes you a couple of minutes to be like, this would be terrible. It would be terrible for the people in the buildings, the people on the ground, the people
都是一场灾难。但摩西却提出了这三条径直横切曼哈顿岛的高速公路。位于125街的上曼哈顿高速公路，穿过布鲁姆街（Broome Street）的曼哈顿下城高速公路，横跨30街中段的曼哈顿中城高架高速公路。它将穿过大楼，潜在地穿过帝国大厦的七楼。想想看吧。它竟然要从帝国大厦的七楼穿过去。这在空中实在是太高了。想象一下，如果有什么东西从在30街上方行驶的汽车上掉下来会怎样。这太荒谬了。但欧德怀市长听说这条高架高速公路后……
in the cars. But Moses, he proposes these three expressways that just cut across Manhattan Island. Upper Manhattan Expressway at 125th Street, Lower Manhattan Expressway across Broome Street, Mid Manhattan Elevated Expressway across Broome Street, mid Manhattan elevated expressway that would cross in the mid 30s, it would go through buildings, potentially through the seventh floor of the Empire State Building. Think about that also. It's going through the Empire State Building at the seventh floor. That's enormously high in the air. Imagine if something fell out of a car driving above 30th Street. It's nuts. But Mayor O'Dwyer, he hears about this elevated expressway
他爱惨了。这彻底激发了他的想象力。他觉得：我们必须这么干。但摩西为了气气他——因为还在生他的气——便说：呃，我们打算先建曼哈顿下城高速公路，专门为了拿捏他。而欧德怀则以牙还牙，让估价委员会（Board of Estimate）……
and he loves it. It really captures his imagination. He's like, we gotta do this. But Moses, just to get his goat, because he's mad at him, he goes, eh, we're gonna build a lower Manhattan expressway first, just to get him. And O'Dwyer retaliates by having the Board of Estimate
从道路预算中抽出一大笔钱，转投到了学校建设上。于是摩西进行报复，宣称他不会建造市政府想要的那些停车停车场。他们两个简直恨不得掐死对方。这需要某种奇迹般的梦想项目，才能让他们重新携手合作。但这种可能性有多大？
take a bunch of money from the road budget and putting it towards schools. So Moses retaliates by saying, he's not gonna build these parking garages that the city wants. The two of them, they're at each other's throats. It's gonna take some kind of dream miracle project to get them working back together again. But how likely is it?
一个奇迹般的梦想项目——那种市长可以真正作为持久政绩拿出来夸耀的东西——在二战刚结束、世界各国都在试图走向联合的这段时期里，这种事真的会发生吗？因为这就是卡罗所讲述的故事，他称之为摩西对金钱权力的最高效利用，那就是把联合国总部拉到纽约市来。好吧，作为一个大半生都以纽约为中心的人，我觉得联合国设在纽约市简直是理所当然的事。这是世界上最伟大的城市。还有什么其他选择吗？但在1947年1月，纽约的状况其实并不算太好。你知道，我觉得这大概就是纽约的故事：它经常处于不太妙的状态。它总是破产……
How likely that a dream miracle project, something that a mayor could really point to as a lasting legacy, that that could actually come around at this period right after World War II when the nations of the world are attempting to unite. Because this is, Carol is the story, what he calls, Moses' most effective use of the power of money, which is getting the United Nations headquarters in New York City. Okay, it seems obvious to me as someone whose
尽管它是世界上最伟大的城市。欧德怀极其渴望联合国能留在纽约，好最终巩固其世界之都的地位。但其他城市也想要它。而且它们有真金白银可以砸在这上面。那些看起来或许是黑马候选人的城市，也许它们能拿下。费城已经准备好拨出土地和资金了。联合国也随时准备这么干。于是欧德怀对摩西说：你必须担任这个委员会的主席，把联合国这笔交易给我拿下来。于是他们组建了一个由摩西的忠实拥趸、富裕金融家、以及年轻的纳尔逊·洛克菲勒（Nelson Rockefeller）组成的团队——我们稍后会更详细地谈到他。而摩西的想法是：这里还有39年世博会留下的那么多空地，把他们塞到皇后区去吧。而联合国的反应是：不好意思，我们要的是曼哈顿。这是联合国。我们可不去什么外围行政区，谢谢。我们要待在曼哈顿。我们要有充足的停车位。我们要为我们的员工提供住房。
life has centered around New York for most of it, that the United Nations would be in New York city. It is the greatest city in the world. What other options are there? But in January, 1947, New York is in not amazing shape. You know, I guess I feel like that's the story of New York is it's often not an amazing shape. It's always broke.
为所有人的住房，真的是为所有人。为了所有人。为了几千人，是的。因为联合国——我不知道你有没有开车路过它。它极其庞大。那是一栋巨大的建筑。它太巨大了。
Despite being the greatest city in the world. And O'Dwyer wants the UN in New York so badly to finally cement its status as the capital of the world. But other cities want it too. And they have actual money to spend on it. Cities that seem like dark horse candidates, perhaps, but maybe they'll have it. Philadelphia is ready to pull the trigger
它看起来就像插在曼哈顿土地上的一张任天堂游戏卡带，但这并不改变它体量巨大的事实。而且他们想要所有这些东西。而纽约市的现状是：我们甚至连把全市学校统一粉刷一遍的钱都拿不出来。我们怎么可能为数千名外国外交官和工作人员建造住房？但市长太想要它了。不幸的是，在1947年12月6日，市长接到了一个电话。
on giving them land and money. The UN is ready to do it. And O'Dwyer's like, Moses, you gotta be the chair of this committee to land this United Nations deal. And they put together this group of Moses loyalists, wealthy financiers, a young Nelson Rockefeller, who we'll talk about in much greater detail later on. And Moses is like, there's all this land left over
联合国将在周三投票决定将联合国设在费城。这个消息——这就像是周五，就在那个周五，他又接到了另一个电话。房地产大亨威廉·泽克endorf（William Zeckendorf）——我们在节目里从没提过这个人，过了这一集之后，我们再也不会提到他了。不用管他是谁。他对市长说：你知道吗，几个月来，我一直在秘密买下海龟湾（Turtle Bay，位于40街东段的纽约地区）的土地，而且我对该地区的另外17英亩土地拥有购买优先权。那可是很大一块地。我本来打算建公寓大楼的，但你知道吗？我是一个富有老头子。如果我把它直接卖给市政府呢？而欧德怀……
from the 39 World's Fair, let's stick them over there in Queens. And the UN is like, excuse me, we want a Manhattan. This is the United Nations. We are not going to an outer borough, thank you. We wanna be in Manhattan. We want lots of parking. We want housing for our staff.
的反应是：哦，要是我们有钱就好了。那么谁会挺身而出呢？只有一个能把事情办成的人。没错，罗伯特·摩西。这就像电影预告片一样。他有96小时来拼凑资金、搞定法律收购，并制定征用这块土地并在上面建造联合国的规划。96小时。他只有周末的时间，这是一个四天的周末。他基本上必须把所有这些全搞定。
Housing for everybody, which is really for everybody. For everybody. For thousands of people, yeah. Because the UN is, I don't know if you've ever driven by it. It is enormous. It's an enormous building. It's huge.
他从约翰·D·洛克菲勒（John D. Rockefeller）那里筹集了一些资金——洛克菲勒家族以后会给他惹麻烦，但现在他们在帮他的忙。他拼凑了所有土地收购计划、大型公共土地项目的所有细节。他几乎全凭记忆在做这件事。你知道的，他对自己在做什么烂熟于心。而且这一切必须秘密进行，
The fact that it just looks like a Nintendo cartridge stuck into the ground of Manhattan doesn't change the fact that it's huge. And they want all this stuff. And New York is like, we can't even afford to paint our schools uniformly. Like, can we build housing for thousands of foreign diplomat workers? But the mayor wants it so badly. Unfortunately, December 6, 1947, the mayor gets a phone call.
以免有人搞砸，因为这件事太微妙了。关于这一点，书里有一个极好的段落，我要花时间把它读出来，仅仅是因为我喜欢这种描述——这其中有多少内容必须在96小时内塞进去并在期限内完成。面对出现的每一个阻碍，摩西都准备好了应对之策。律师团队花了几天时间研究城市放弃东河防波堤细节的研究。摩西把秘书叫进办公室，当场口授备忘录，连翻一本法律书都不用，直接就把方法阐述清楚了。
The UN on Wednesday is going to vote to put the UN in Philadelphia. That and this is this is like Friday, that same Friday gets another call. Real estate mogul William Zeckendorf, someone we have never mentioned in this in the show before after this episode, we'll never mention him again. Don't worry about it. He says to the mayor, you know, for months, I've been secretly buying up land in Turtle Bay, this area of New York in the East 40s, and I've got an option on 17 more acres in the area. That's a lot of land. I was going to build apartment complexes, but you know what? I'm an old rich man. What if I just sell it to the city? And O'Dwyer
这份备忘录后来被律师们发现连最后一个逗号都准确无误。市政府需要立法许可来关闭该地块内的某些道路并将土地交给联合国。摩西给奥尔巴尼打几个电话就确保了这一许可的批准。周二深夜，大约在总部委员会开会前12个小时，泽克endorf——他在提出报价后就没有再参与任何讨论，也不知道是否有被接受的可能——当时正在蒙特卡洛（Monte Carlo）的一间私人餐厅里庆祝生日，
is like, oh, if only we have no money. So who's going to step in? There's only one guy who gets things done. That's right. Robert Moses, it's like a movie trailer. He has 96 hours to put together the financing and the legal acquisition and plans for taking this land and building the United Nations on it. 96 hours. He's got the weekend, it's a four day weekend. He's basically got to do all this.
这时，杰出建筑师、洛克菲勒家族的密友华莱士·K·哈里森（Wallace K. Harrison）走了进来，他的西装口袋里塞着一张该地块逐个街区的地图，鼓鼓囊囊的。他走到桌前，试图摆出一副若无其事的样子，却失败了，脱口而出道：“你肯以八百五十万美元把它卖掉吗？”我太喜欢这个细节了，就好像……
He gets some financing from John D Rockefeller that Rockefeller's are going to cause him trouble later, but now they're helping him out. He puts together all the plans for the acquisitions, all the details of a major public land project. He's doing it almost from memory. You know, he knows what he's doing so much. And it all has to be done secretly,
他走进一个富豪的生日派对时试图表现得从容不迫，结果却脱口而出：“哦，你肯按这个价格卖吗？”然后他们真的成交了，这一切都搞定了。而当地的改革者则认为：这是市里本该花在我们自己居民身上、而不是用在联合国身上的钱。而且联合国基本上想要……
so no one can screw it up, because it is so delicate. And there's a great paragraph about this that I'm gonna take the time to read, just because I love the, it it just how much had to be crammed into this but in 96 hours it was done for every snag that arose Moses had a knife teams of lawyers prepared to research for days the details of city surrender of East River bulkheads Moses called in a secretary and dictated on the spot without reference to a single law book a memorandum setting out the
免税土地。来自该房地产的税收本可以为城市贡献巨额资金。在接下来的10年里，根据卡罗或任何他所采用的估算来源，这让城市损失了超过3200万美元。但市长和其他当权者被成为世界永久之都的想法给迷住了。我只想插一句。这不是罗伯特·卡罗说的。这是我说的。你真的相信联合国会把总部设在费城吗？拜托，你在开玩笑吧？
method a memorandum lawyers later found to be correct down to the last comma. Legislative permission was needed for the city to close certain streets within the site and give the UNO the land. A few phone calls from Moses to Albany secured a guarantee of the permission. Late Tuesday night, about 12 hours before the headquarters committee convened, Zeckendorf, who had taken no part in the discussions following his offer and did not know if there's any chance of it being accepted, was celebrating his birthday in a private dining room at the Monte Carlo
就像——无意冒犯费城，我有些朋友住在费城，那是个伟大的城市，我很喜欢去那里。那里有一座很棒的现代艺术博物馆，拥有世界上最伟大的马塞尔·杜尚（Marcel Duchamp）作品收藏，他是我的最爱之一，但我们要现实一点。
when Wallace K. Harrison, the distinguished architect and intimate of the Rockefeller family, walked in with a block by block map of the site bulging out of a jacket pocket, sat down at the table, tried to assume an air of nonchalance, failed and blurted out, would you sell it for eight and a half million? I love that detail so much of like,
费城——拜托，说真的。你在开玩笑吗？但这可能是旧金山。完全有可能是。有可能是旧金山，我能想象它在旧金山。我能想象，主要是因为《星际迷航》，我或许能在旧金山想象它。我的意思是，那是《星际迷航》里银河系的中心。
he's trying to be smooth as he walks into a wealthy man's birthday party, but he just is like, oh, will you sell it for this much? And they do it, like they get it all done. And local reformers are like, this is money the city should be spending on our own residents and not on the United Nations. And the UN wants essentially
确实如此。确实如此，把联邦总部设在那里确实把联合国比下去了，这倒是真的。我能想象联合国设在旧金山，而且总觉得——美国有些城市感觉就像世界级城市，而其他城市则不一定。也许是我不够公平，
tax-free land. And the taxes from that real estate would have paid so much money into the city. Over the next 10 years, Caro or whichever source is using estimates, it costs the city more than $32 million. But the mayor and the other people in power, they're dazzled by the idea of being the permanent capital of the world. And I just want to step in. This is not Robert Caro saying this. This is me saying this. Do you really believe the United Nations was going to base itself in Philadelphia? Like, are you kidding me?
也许这只是因为它们多年来一直没有获得这样的机会。但我总觉得，最能由《洛奇》（Rocky）象征的城市，未必就是联合国会选择落户的城市，你懂我的意思吗？这就像是——天哪，我们会收到信件的，我们会收到信件的。现在我觉得我只是在疯狂吐槽费城，我们要收到信件了。我们绝对要收到信件了。现在我感觉我就是在疯狂吐槽费城。
Like, no offense to Philly, I have friends that live in Philly, it's a great city, I love going there. It's got a great modern art museum with the world's greatest collection of Marcel Duchamp's work, which I, one of my favorite artists, let's be realistic.
就像——我们有这么棒的现代艺术博物馆。你知道它最出名的是什么吗？是一个电影里的拳击手跑步锻炼时冲上了台阶。所以，很难相信这样一个世界——很难相信这样一个世界——在罗曼喘气的时候我会继续说下去——很难相信这样一个世界里纽约居然没有联合国，
Philadelphia, like, come on, seriously. Are you kidding me? But it could be San Francisco. It totally could be. It could have been San, I could see it in San Francisco. I could see it, mainly because of Star Trek, I could maybe see it in San Francisco. I mean, it's the center of the fucking galaxy
费城，拜托，说真的。你在开玩笑吗？但也可以是旧金山。完全可以是旧金山。也可以是旧、我可以想象它在旧金山。我能想象，主要是因为《星际迷航》，我或许能在旧金山想象它。我的意思是，它是他妈的银河系的中心
in Star Trek. That's true. That's true, having the Federation headquarters there really, it does outclass the UN, that's true. And I could see the UN being in San Francisco, and there's something about, like there's certain cities in the United States that feel like world cities and others that don't necessarily. And maybe that's me being unfair,
在《星际迷航》里。确实如此。确实如此，那里有联邦总部，这确实比联合国高出一个档次，确实如此。我能想象联合国设在旧金山，而且某种程度上，美国有些城市感觉像是世界级城市，而另一些则不一定。也许是我不够公平，
maybe it's just years of them not getting their chance, but I feel like the city that is best symbolized by Rocky is not necessarily the city that the United Nations is gonna go in, you know? What is like, this is- Oh man, we're gonna get letters, we're gonna get letters. Now I feel like I'm just ragging on Philadelphia, we're going to get letters. We're going to get letters. Now I feel like I'm just ragging on Philadelphia.
也许这只是因为它们多年来一直没有机会，但我感觉最能象征洛基的城市不一定是联合国将要落户的城市，你知道吗？这就像是——哦天哪，我们要收到信了，我们要收到信了。现在我觉得我只是在批评费城，我们要收到信了。我们要收到信了。现在我觉得我只是在批评费城。
Like, we've got this amazing modern art museum. You know what it's best known for? A boxer in a movie ran up the steps while he was exercising. So, it's hard to believe a world where, it's hard to believe a world, I'm going to keep talking while Roman catches his breath, it's hard to believe a world where New York doesn't have the United Nations,
比如，我们拥有这个令人惊叹的现代艺术博物馆。你知道它最出名的是什么吗？一个电影里的拳击手在锻炼时跑上了台阶。所以，很难相信这样一个世界，很难相信这样一个世界——我会在罗曼喘口气的同时继续说下去——很难相信纽约没有联合国的世界，
because we've lived in it for so long. It's hard to believe a world where New York doesn't have the United Nations because we've lived in it for so long. It's been there for almost 80 years now, but it very easily could not have happened. And it's this whirlwind 96 hour sprint. This was a sprint. This was not a marathon. This 96 hour sprint to get it done.
因为我们在这个世界里生活了太久。很难相信纽约没有联合国的世界，因为我们在这个世界里生活了太久。它已经在那里存在了近八十年，但它本来完全有可能不会发生。这是一个旋风般的96小时冲刺。这是一场冲刺。这不是一场马拉松。这是一场为了完成它的96小时冲刺。
And by this point, Moses can kind of do no wrong with O'Dwyer. And he has some mentions. In July, 1946, they are bitter enemies. January, 1947, with O'Dwyer. And he has it mentioned. In July 1946, they are bitter enemies. January 1947, Moses O'Dwyer's hero. He will listen to whatever Moses tells him. He will do pretty much whatever he wants. Twice a week, they have breakfast together,
到了这个时候，摩西在奥德华面前可以说是难犯错误。他有一些提及。在1946年7月，他们还是死敌。1947年1月，关于奥德华。他提到了这一点。在1946年7月，他们是死敌。1947年1月，摩西成了奥德华的英雄。他会听从摩西告诉他的任何事情。他几乎会做摩西想让他做的任何事。一周两次，他们一起吃早餐，
these long breakfast meetings, and the mayor, he'll just sign, usually, whatever papers Moses brings him. Moses brings him a document signed, he will sign it, because Moses pulled off this amazing coup. Yeah, it's really remarkable. It's just like whenever you do a project with someone, how you get so close to them, like you can tell that that just really worked. And he just capitulates to everything Moses wants at that point. It's really something else.
这些漫长的早餐会议，市长通常只是签署摩西带给他的任何文件。摩西带给他一份签好字的文件，他就会签，因为摩西完成了这场惊人的政变。是的，这真的很了不起。这就像你和某人一起做一个项目时，你们是如何变得如此亲密，你可以看出这确实奏效了。在那时，他对摩西想要的一切都妥协了。这真的很不一般。
It helps that OJWIRE is overwhelmed by running this city. Like Carol gets, there's something very touching about this and the next mayor, Im Pelletary that we've been kind of seeing this parade of Titans throughout the book. There's Robert Moses but of course there's Al Smith and there's LaGuardia and there's Roosevelt. These people and it starts to make you think oh back then they just had giants among them who were able to take hold of a community and and govern it. But at the time there were plenty of people who were just kind of scared by it, you know, that this is an overwhelming thing.
这也因为奥德华被管理这座城市压得喘不过气来。就像卡洛注意到的那样，关于这一点以及下一位市长英佩莱特里，有一些非常感人的地方，我们在整本书中一直看到这种“泰坦”的游行。有罗伯特·摩西，当然还有阿尔·史密斯、拉瓜迪亚和罗斯福。这些人让人开始觉得，哦，当年他们之中真有巨擘，能够掌控一个社区并进行治理。但在当时，有很多人其实对此感到害怕，你知道的，觉得这是一件令人不知所措的事情。
And O'Dwyer finds real personal comfort, it seems, in Moses' confidence and his ability. And so he's relying more and more on him because this is a big thing. And he talks to Caro about looking out over the sea at night and being like, can you imagine, like, can you believe that I'm in charge of all this? That it's a frightening thing. And Moses does not have that fear. Maybe that's his other secret weapon, is he has the lack of fear that comes with arrogance, that he can do anything. So in December 1948, O'Dwyer finally points Moses to that Mayor's Committee on Slub Clearance. Moses has vast control over public housing, the control he couldn't get under LaGuardia,
奥德华似乎在摩西的自信和能力中找到了真正的个人慰藉。因此，他越来越依赖摩西，因为这是一件大事。他和卡洛谈到晚上眺望大海时说，你能想象吗，你能相信我负责这一切吗？这是一件让人感到害怕的事情。而摩西没有这种恐惧。也许这就是他的另一个秘密武器，他拥有傲慢所带来的无所畏惧，认为自己无所不能。因此，在1948年12月，奥德华终于将摩西指派到那个市长贫民窟清除委员会。摩西对公共住房拥有了巨大的控制权，这是他在拉瓜迪亚手下无法获得的控制权，
and he has even more control than he could have had before because Title I of the Federal Housing Act of 1949 finally extends the power of eminent domain to an area so that the government can condemn private land and turn it over to a private individual for public housing. And this is the kind of condemnation that Moses kind of used to use in his state parks in Long Island in the 20s, but that was for public parks. Now he can wield that power in New York City and he can use it to broker with the people who wanna do those private projects to create more housing. Moses of course endorses O'Dwyer for re-election.
而且他甚至获得了比以往更大的控制权，因为1949年《联邦住房法》第一篇最终将征用权扩大到了某个区域，这样政府就可以征收私人土地并将其交由私人进行公共住房建设。这种征收正是摩西20年代在长岛州立公园时经常采用的手法，但那时是为了建设公园。现在他可以在纽约市行使这一权力，并以此与那些想要开发私人项目以建造更多住房的人进行交涉。摩西当然支持欧怀尔竞选连任。
He campaigns alongside him. He ignores calls that he should run himself. He's like, I'm flattered, but no. And Caro admits that O'Dwyer probably did not need Moses' endorsement, but it doesn't hurt that he has all these ribbon cuttings, all these things he can point to. The United Nations is going to be headquartered in New York. That swells you with pride, you know, as a New Yorker. And Moses kind of helps him by deliberately holding off on doing too many massive relocations of
他为欧怀尔站台拉票。他忽视了自己应该参选的呼声。他大概是说，我很荣幸，但算了吧。卡罗承认，欧怀尔可能并不需要摩西的背书，但拥有这些剪彩活动以及所有这些可以拿得出手的政绩，对他的选情绝对大有裨益。联合国总部将设在纽约。你知道，作为一个纽约人，这会让你充满自豪感。摩西还在某种程度上帮了欧怀尔一把，他刻意推迟了在大选之后再对
tenants until after the election. You know, so that's something that can't be at O'Dwyer's feet. There's a section here where Caro introduces a kind of mini-nemesis of Moses who comes in at the end of O'Dwyer's run, a guy named Jerry Finkelstein. He's this young guy. He says, I can play O'Dwyer better than anyone else in the city. I know how to get anything I want from him. Usually because I know that whoever talks to O'Dwyer last gets what he wants. So he makes a point of just waiting till everyone else has talked to the mayor, going in and talking to him. And there's a funny scene where Finkelstein has been told he's going to be the new chair of the city planning commission.
租户进行大规模的重新安置。这样一来，这笔账就不会算在欧怀尔头上。书中这里有一个章节，卡罗引入了摩西的一个“微型克星”，他在欧怀尔任期的末期登场，这人名叫杰里·芬肯斯坦。他是个年轻人。他说，在全市范围内，我比任何人都更懂怎么摆布欧怀尔。我知道怎么从他那里得到我想要的任何东西。通常是因为我知道，谁最后一个跟欧怀尔说话，谁就能如愿以偿。所以他总是故意等到所有人都跟市长谈完后，才进去找他谈。有一个滑稽的场景是，芬肯斯坦得知自己将被任命为市规划委员会的新主席。
Moses doesn't like that. So when he shows up to get sworn in, someone says, hey, your name's not on the rolls. There's not doing anything. And he goes to O'Dwyer and he's like, I thought you're going to make me city planning commission chair. He's like, oh, Bob was saying, you know, maybe it should do something else or do another thing. What else do you want? I'll give you anything else and Finkelstein goes This is all I want. This is the only job I want and I do I goes then you shall have it and just signs them In right there so I submit and it feels like satire, but I trust Caro that it's real I assume it's probably Finkelstein's telling or someone someone else who was in the room
摩西不喜欢这样。因此，当他去宣誓就职时，有人告诉他，嘿，花名册上没有你的名字。你什么也做不了。于是他去找欧怀尔质问，说我以为你要让我当市规划委员会主席呢。欧怀尔却说，哦，鲍勃说，你知道的，也许应该让你去负责别的或者干点别的。你还想要什么？我什么都可以给你。而芬肯斯坦则回答：这就是我想要的全部。这是我唯一想要的工作，我也就要这个。欧怀尔便说：那你就拿去吧，然后当场就签了字。所以我就这样听从了，这感觉就像是讽刺，但我相信卡罗写的是真的。我猜这大概是芬肯斯坦的叙述，或者是当时在场的其他人的说法。
Finkelstein becomes the champion of a concept that has reared its head before and will rear its head again here now. The idea of a master plan, a master plan for developing the city. New York has never had one and the result is dealing with massive problems. Waste, redundancy, lack of development where development needs doing, overdevelopment where the resources can't really handle it. A master plan in theory would smooth all really handle it, a master plan in theory would smooth all that out and not a master plan in the Moses sense of a master planner
芬肯斯坦成了一种理念的捍卫者，这种理念以前就曾抬头，而现在又将在这里抬头。这就是总体规划的概念，一个用于城市开发的总体规划。纽约从来没有过这样的规划，其结果就是不得不应对铺天盖地的巨大问题。垃圾遍地、功能冗余、该开发的地方缺乏开发、资源根本无法承受的地方过度开发。理论上讲，一个总体规划可以理顺所有这一切，呃，理论上讲，一个总体规划可以理顺所有这一切，而且这个总体规划不是摩西意义上的总体规划——
draws lines on a map and says this is where things are going. Finkelstein wants to do something that involves community leaders talking to business leaders, people getting together at a table and finding compromises in things. And it's something that, Caro, he's had a couple of these throughout the book, these kind of idealists that he paint as if only, if only they'd had their way. And this is the next to them. And I really wonder if it would have worked
那种在地图上画几道杠然后说事情就该这么办的规划。芬肯斯坦想要做的是让社区领袖与商界领袖对话，让人们坐在一起，通过协商找到折中的办法。卡罗在整本书里好几次写到这样的人物——这种被他描绘成“要是他们当初能按自己的想法来就好了”的理想主义者。而这就是继他们之后的又一个。我真的很好奇，如果按芬肯斯坦想要的方式去做了，
the way that Finkelstein wants it to. And I see a disbelieving look on Roman's face. Roman, what do you think? I think it would, I mean, he's clearly, Finkelstein is much more of a modern day thinker when it comes to designing cities. He's not like roll out a map and draw lines across it, like you said.
它到底能不能行得通。我看到罗曼脸上露出了怀疑的表情。罗曼，你怎么看？我认为可以，我的意思是，很显然，在城市设计方面，芬肯斯坦要具有现代得多的思维。就像你说的，他不是那种摊开地图在上面画线的人。
The nature of this master plan is one of talk to a neighborhood, what does it need? What is it good at? How do you, you know, like have these neighborhoods like fulfill their specific character and their needs and how you patch those together and make it into a functional city. It is really a ground up idea.
这种总体规划的本质是与社区对话：它需要什么？它的优势是什么？你如何让这些社区展现出它们独特的个性和需求，然后如何将这些拼凑在一起，使之成为一个功能健全的城市。这确实是一个自下而上的理念。
You know, like when you hear the word master plan, you might think this is just competing idea with Moses's idea of a master plan. It is not, it is really something different. Like Finkelstein thinks differently. And it is just, in a way, it's like, spoiler alert, like this doesn't work out well for Finkelstein. No, it doesn't happen.
你知道，当你听到“总体规划”这个词时，你可能会认为这只是与摩西的总体规划理念竞争的另一个构想。其实不然，这完全是两码事。芬肯斯坦的思维方式与众不同。从某种程度上说，就像——剧透一下吧——这对芬肯斯坦来说并没有什么好结果。是的，它没有实现。
If you're wondering, if you're hoping to get a copy of the master plan and see how well New York has followed it since then, it doesn't happen, yeah. But my sense of like the decades that followed, you know, like maybe there isn't a grand master plan, but the thinking behind Finkelstein's master plan is more the modern thinking of how to run and shape cities. His thinking seems much more in line
如果你在纳闷，如果你希望买一本总体规划的副本，看看从那时起纽约遵循得有多好，这并没有发生，是的。但对于随后的几十年，你知道，或许并没有一个宏大的总体规划，但芬肯斯坦总体规划背后的思维，更符合现代关于如何管理和塑造城市的理念。他的思维似乎更加符合
with the kind of Jane Jacobs' death and life of great American cities, sort of. A city, a neighborhood is a living unit. You've gotta see what the life of it is like. It needs to have a kind of mixed use, and everyone has to get something out of their life. It makes it worth living in it. Yeah.
简·雅各布斯的《美国大城市的死与生》那种风格。一个城市，一个社区，是一个有生命力的整体。你必须去观察它的生活是怎样的。它需要有一种复合功能，每个人都必须从中获得他们生活的一部分价值。这使得在这个地方生活变得有意义。是的。
He's much more of a modern thinker that thinks about these things. Yeah. So it's a battle not just of this guy's stepping on my turf, but a battle of ideologies. For sure. Yeah. And the big fight is in 1950, O'Dwyer announces Triborough has done a study. Guess what? Their study of the Mid-Manhattan Elev elevated expressway says that the mid Manhattan elevated expressway
他是一个更具现代思维、会深入思考这些问题的人。所以，这不仅是一场“这家伙在踩我地盘”的地盘之争，更是一场意识形态之争。毫无疑问。是的。而这场大战发生在1950年，欧怀尔宣布三区大桥局做了一项研究。你猜怎么着？他们对曼哈顿中区高架快速路的研究所得出的结论是，曼哈顿中区高架快速路
is the best way to carry traffic across 30th street. It's a 160 foot wide road. It would be seven stories in the air. You would have to remove all the buildings on the south side of 30th street, which is insane to me. Like that's phenomenal. That's, it's wow. It is a horrifically terrible idea.
是将车流输送穿过30街的最佳途径。那是一条160英尺宽的道路。它将在七层楼的高空中。你必须拆除30街南侧的所有建筑，这在我看来简直是疯了。这太惊人了。这简直是，哇。这是一个极其糟糕的主意。
It's right over the heart of Manhattan's business district. And Carrow has shown us elevated expressways, they kill neighborhoods. You know, they, even if, even if you need them necessarily in a place, people do not want to live and work in a place where the sun doesn't reach the street. Triborough though, will pay most of the money for it.
它正好位于曼哈顿商业区的核心地带。卡罗已经向我们展示过，高架快速路会扼杀社区。你知道，它们，即使，即使你在某个地方确实需要它们，人们也不愿意在一个阳光照不到街道的地方生活和工作。不过，三区大桥局将支付大部分建设资金。
And trade and civic associations are like, did Triborough study any other plans? Like maybe a tunnel might be okay. And they want the Planning Commission to do its own study. And the mayor gives the Planning Commission permission to study it. But he's like, hey, they could show me plans for a great tunnel,
而贸易和市民协会则质问：三区大桥局研究过任何其他方案吗？比如修建一条隧道也许也行。他们希望规划委员会进行自己的研究。市长也批准规划委员会进行研究。但他却说，嘿，他们可以向我展示修建一条伟大隧道的方案，
but no one's offering me money to build a tunnel. So it doesn't matter. But he says, but you can have permission. The permission is useless. They have no money to actually do the study. They have no money to implement a building project. But just the fact that O'Dwyer gave them this useless token permission for an unfunded study
但没有人给钱让我去建隧道。所以这根本不重要。不过他说，你们倒是可以获得批准。这种批准毫无用处。他们根本没有资金去实际开展这项研究。他们没有资金来实施任何建设工程。然而，仅仅因为欧怀尔给了他们这样一个毫无用处的、针对一项没有资金支持的研究的象征性批准，
angers Moses so much that Moses has tri-brow killed the project entirely. You know what? We're not even gonna do it. So this, it's maybe the greatest movie ever had was killing his own terrifying project at, you know, if it had peak, but it's, it's an, and O'Dwyer he has to angrily announce,
就惹得摩西大发雷霆，以至于摩西直接让三区大桥局彻底取消了这个项目。你懂的？我们甚至不打算干了。所以这，这或许是摩西干过的最伟大的事：在项目达到巅峰时，亲手掐断了自己那个吓人的项目，然而，然而，欧怀尔不得不愤怒地宣布，
well, now my expressway is not going to get built across 30th street. He was going to go through the Empire State Building and he gives Finkelstein a tongue lashing. But the mayor still supports the idea of the master plan. And it seems like there's some momentum behind it. There's some movement. And again, O'Dwyer is starting with, once again,
好吧，现在我的快速路不会穿过30街修建了。它原本计划穿过帝国大厦。他还狠狠训斥了芬肯斯坦一番。不过市长仍然支持总体规划的理念。而且这背后似乎还有一些势头。还有一些进展。再说一次，欧怀尔再次开始，
sour on the fact that Moses is not actually solving the problems he's supposed to solve. It seems like the UN is behind them. O'Dwyer is preparing for a second term. Perhaps there is a turn here. Perhaps he might turn away from Moses and embrace the idea of Finkelstein's master plan. This could be it. This could be the hinge point at which O'Dwyer becomes the hero the city needs. All he has to hope is that his mob connections and the blatant corruption of his administration don't become public right now. Roman, is that exactly what happens? That is exactly what happens. I think a lot of people forget that the 50s was a big time for investigation of organized crime. Yeah.
对摩西实际上并没有解决他本该解决的问题感到厌烦。联合国似乎站在他们这一边。欧怀尔正在为第二个任期做准备。或许这里会有所转机。或许他会背离摩西，拥护芬肯斯坦的总体规划理念。这可能就是转折点。这可能成为欧怀尔成为这座城市所需要的英雄的关键枢纽。他只需祈祷自己与黑帮的联系以及政府赤裸裸的腐败现在不要曝光。罗曼，事情真的是这样发展的吗？事实正是如此。我觉得很多人都忘了，50年代是调查有组织犯罪的大时代。是的。
And the Senate committee of organized crime. Yeah. And the Senate committee on organized crime that Estes Kiefer led, they were doing hearings all over the place. They did televised hearings that were the first time that a lot of people really saw organized crime laid bare as a real, how massive the system was, how much it had stretched into American life. And so it is a, it's a bad time to be a mayor who has deep connections to organized crime.
还有有组织犯罪参议院委员会。是的。由埃斯特斯·基福弗领导的有组织犯罪参议院委员会，他们在各地举行听证会。他们举行了电视转播的听证会，这是许多人第一次真正看到有组织犯罪赤裸裸地暴露出来，看到这个系统究竟有多庞大，它对美国生活的渗透有多深。所以，对于一个与有组织犯罪有着深厚联系的市长来说，这是一个糟糕的时期。
And he hastily resigns as mayor right before, I think a massive investigation to police corruption. A friend of his goes to see Harry Truman. Harry Truman hastily appoints him as an ambassador. And as Caro says, and on August 31st, 1950, almost 18 years to the day after Tammany's most popular mayor fled the country, Tamini's second most popular mayor crossed the border into
就在我看来针对警察腐败的大规模调查即将展开之前，他匆忙辞去了市长职务。他的一个朋友去找哈里·杜鲁门。哈里·杜鲁门匆忙任命他为大使。正如卡罗所说，在1950年8月31日，几乎恰好在坦慕尼厅最受欢迎的市长逃离该国18年后的同一天，坦慕尼厅第二受欢迎的市长越过了边境进入了
Mexico. And that is why Robert Caro is, is interviewing William O. Dwyer in Mexico City. Love it so much. It is such, it's such an amazing turn and we didn't set it up the way Caro sets it up. Caro really goes into detail earlier on in the
墨西哥。这就是为什么罗伯特·卡罗要在墨西哥城采访威廉·欧怀尔。太喜欢了。这真是一个、真是一个惊人的转折，而我们并没有按照卡罗铺陈的方式来讲述它。卡罗在这一章的前面部分其实深入探讨了
chapter. We're talking about O. Dwyer's early life about his connections to organized crime. So it doesn't feel like it comes the way Carol sets it up. Carol really goes into detail earlier on in the chapter. We just talked about O'Jwyer's early life, about his connections to organized crime. So it doesn't feel like it comes out of nowhere the same way. But Carol's like, there's a reason that when O'Jwyer was asked to run for mayor, he said, no, I don't want to. It's because he's so afraid of this stuff coming out.
欧怀尔的早年生活以及他与有组织犯罪的联系。所以，当事情发生时，并不会像卡罗那样铺垫得那么突兀。卡罗在这一章的前面部分确实进行了详细的阐述。我们刚才谈到了欧怀尔的早年生活，以及他与有组织犯罪的联系。所以，它不会让人觉得同样那么突兀。但卡罗的意思是，当欧怀尔被邀请竞选市长时他说不，我不想干，这是有原因的。因为他太害怕这些事情败露了。
And so he literally flees. He flees and flees to Mexico, like the gangsters in Hollywood movies of the 30s and 40s, you know? And becomes ambassador to Mexico. And so the Ojairo era ends as suddenly as it began, you might say. That's right. But that brings us to probably Elliot's favorite character
所以他 literalmente（字面意思上）逃跑了。他逃跑了，逃到了墨西哥，就像30和40年代好莱坞电影里的歹徒一样，你知道吗？然后当上了驻墨西哥大使。所以你可以说，欧怀尔时代就像开始得那样突然，戛然而止了。没错。但这就把我们带到了埃利奥特在这本书里
in the book. One of them, I have to say, I have a real, I love this character, I love the way that Caro talks about it. Now, Roman, have you ever read the book, Eminent Victorians by Lytton Strachey? I don't know how to pronounce his name, I have a real, I love love of this character. I love the way that that Carol talks about it. Now, Roman, have you ever read the book, Eminent Victorians by Lytton Strachey? I don't know how to pronounce his name,
最喜欢的角色。其中之一，我必须说，我对这个角色有一种真正的、我太爱这个角色了，我喜欢卡罗谈论他的方式。好了，罗曼，你读过利顿·斯特拉奇写的书《维多利亚时代名人传》吗？我不知道该怎么发音他的名字，但我对这个角色有着无比的喜爱。我喜欢卡罗谈论他的方式。好了，罗曼，你读过利顿·斯特拉奇写的书《维多利亚时代名人传》吗？我不知道该怎么发音他的名字，
but it is one of the funniest history books of all time. It's essentially a burn book. He's writing, it was written in the 19 teens, 1920s. He writes about four different eminent Victorians and it is just a burn book. He's just writing about how, what hypocrites they were, how much he, you know, just scan. It's like Hollywood Babylon about Victorian England. And the writing in this section is the closest, I feel like he comes in this book to that book where it is like, all right, we're
但它是有史以来最搞笑的历史书之一. 它本质上一本“刻薄之书”。他在写，它是写于1910年代、1920年代。他写了四个不同的维多利亚时代名人，这简直就是一本黑料合集。他只是在写他们是多么虚伪，他对他们是多么地，你知道，简直是冷嘲热讽。这就像是维多利亚时代英国版的《好莱坞巴比伦》。而这一部分的文风，我觉得是他在本书中最接近那本书的一次，就好像，好吧，我们
talking about real history here. It is ridiculous. We're going to have some fun with this. Like this is, and yet at the same, at the same time, he still seems to have like a sweetness and affection for the man he's writing about. That man, Vincent Impelletary, perhaps one of the lesser known mayors of New York, which makes sense. I think Caro's feelings about him are best showed by the fact that the chapter subheading is not Impelletary, it is Impey, which was his nickname in the newspapers, is Impey, which right off the bat makes him, you know, it miniaturizes this figure, you know. He sounds like Mr. Mixipitlick from the Superman comics, you know. That's right. That's right. So let's talk about Impi when we come back.
在这里讨论真正的历史。这太荒谬了。我们要拿这个找点乐子。就好像这本是，然而与此同时，他对笔下的人物似乎仍然带有一种温柔和喜爱。那个人，文森特·安佩莱特里，或许是纽约最不为人知的市长之一，这也说得通。我认为卡罗对他的感觉最好地体现在这一章的小标题不是“安佩莱特里”，而是“安佩”（Impey），这是他在报纸上的绰号，是“安佩”，这开门见山地就让他，你知道的，把这个人物给迷你化了，你知道吗。他听起来就像超人漫画里的奇幻先生（Mixipitlick），你知道的。没错。没错。所以当我们回来时，我们来谈谈安佩。
Okay, Impi, lay it out for me. Tell me about Impi. I know why you had to put a break there, but I had so much trouble sitting through the break waiting to talk about MP, because he is, okay. By law, let's set up why he's in this position. Why is a guy, everyone calls MP, suddenly mayor of New York. By law, when the mayor retires or resigns, they have to be succeeded by the president
好吧，安佩，跟我详细说说。跟我讲讲安佩。我知道你为什么必须在那里插播广告，但我坐在那里苦苦等待、急切地想要聊安佩时实在是备受煎熬，因为他——好吧。根据法律，让我们先铺垫一下他为什么会处于这个位置。为什么一个被所有人称为“安佩”的家伙会突然成为纽约市长？根据法律，当市长退休或辞职时，必须由
of the city council. Who is president of the city council in 1950? And almost totally unknown, totally undistinguished, Tammany Aparachik. His highest previous job in the government was as secretary to a judge named Judge Schmuck, which like, this one is from like Caro, I'm gonna have to check the notes.
市议会议长来接替他们。1950年谁是市议会议长？而他几乎是一个完全默默无闻、毫无特色、典型的坦慕尼厅官僚。他在政府担任过的最高职位是一个叫施穆克法官的法官的秘书，诸如此类的事，这感觉就像卡罗编的，我得去核对一下笔记。
Like that seems too perfect. And this man is Vincent Impelletary. And according to a story that Caro says Moses attested to him is true, that Moses said he was apparently at this meeting, the machine bosses needed an Italian from Manhattan to balance the ticket. They already had an Irishman from Brooklyn and a Jew from the Bronx on their kind of a city council list.
这听起来太完美了。而这个人就是文森特·安佩莱特里。根据卡罗说摩西曾向他证实过的一个故事，摩西说他当时显然出席了这次会议，当时机器政治大佬们需要一个来自曼哈顿的意大利人来平衡候选人名单。他们已经在他们的市议会候选人名单上有一个来自布鲁克林的爱尔兰人和一个来自布朗克斯的犹太人。
They needed an Italian from Manhattan. They literally looked at a list of city employees and saw what was a name that was so obviously Italian that anyone looking at the ballot would know this is an Italian guy. And they found the name Vincent Impelletary, which is a very Italian name. And so this guy, as city council president, he voted however the mayor tells him to.
他们需要一个来自曼哈顿的意大利人。他们居然真的查阅了一份市政府雇员的名单，看看哪个名字明显是个意大利人，以至于任何看选票的人都会知道这是一个意大利人。然后他们找到了“文森特·安佩莱特里”这个名字，这是一个非常意大利的名字。于是这家伙作为市议会议长，市长让他怎么投票他就怎么投票。
He just attends public functions. Caro says, quote, "'Aimable but slow-witted. "'He was a joke among political insiders,, but now he was mayor and the joke was on the city. And it is, it is the kind of thing. It's like the movie Dave in a way, you know, like it's this guy who is, has no, no right to be the mayor of New York is suddenly there. So he has to win a special election to be the full, get the full term as mayor.
他只是出席各种公共活动。卡罗写道，引述：“‘为人温和但脑子笨拙。’他在政治内幕人士中间是个笑话，但现在他是市长，而这个笑话落在了这座城市头上。”而且，这确实是那种情况。从某种意义上说，这就像电影《冒牌总统》一样，你知道的，就好像这个毫无资格成为纽约市长的人突然坐上了这个位置。所以他必须赢得一场特别选举，才能获得完整的市长任期。
The Democrats are like, we are not nominating you for a full term. That is, this is not happening. And he runs as the independent anti-T full term as mayor. The Democrats are like, we are not nominating you for a full term, this is not happening. And he runs as the independent anti-Tamany boss candidate. He's like, you don't know much about me, but I am anti-Tamany. And he says to Moses, if you endorse me, I will not reappoint Ficklestein and you will have even more control.
民主党人却说：我们不会提名你竞选完整任期。这是不可能的，门都没有。于是他以独立的反坦慕尼候选人身份参选完整任期。民主党人说：我们不会提名你竞选完整任期，这是不可能的。于是他以独立的反对坦慕尼大佬的候选人身份参选。他说：你们对我不大了解，但我坚决反对坦慕尼。他对摩西说：如果你支持我，我就不会重新任命芬肯斯坦，这样你就能获得更大的控制权。
And Moses is like, check please, yes. And as a result- Speaking my language. Yeah, yeah, power in exchange for me. Yes, thank you. Did you read the book? You know what I do? And as a result, Impey is the first ever independent candidate to become mayor. Not a fusion candidate, not a Republican Democrat. He is an independent candidate running just on his own name,
摩西听了就像是：请给我结账，太好了，没问题。因此——正合我意。是的，是的，用权力来交换我。是的，谢谢。你读过这本书吗？你知道我是怎么做的吗？因此，安佩成为有史以来第一位赢得市长宝座的独立候选人。不是融合候选人，不是共和党或民主党人。他是一名纯粹以自己名义参选的独立候选人，
which again, most people know as Impey because that's what the newspaper calls him. And there's a section here that I just love. Caro is, he is scathing about it. It says, thanks to his PR men and his physical appearance, his addiction to the blue suit and the boutonniere combined with his iron gray hair, deeply earnest mean, and stolidity that during the campaign was mistaken for dignity,
正如大多数人所知，他的名字叫“安佩”，因为报纸上就是这么叫他的。书中有一段我非常喜欢。卡罗对他的评价极其尖刻。书中写道：“凭借他的公关人员和外表，他对蓝色西装和胸花的热情，配上铁灰色的头发、极其严肃的表情，以及在竞选期间被误认为威严的沉稳，
made him the very model of a modern mayor. At the approach of a camera, his brow would furrow, his lips would purse, his jaw would jut, and his eyes would focus on whatever piece of paper happened to be handy, just as intently as if he understood the words written on it. Impey had run a great race, but once in possession of the prize he had won, he proved to have not the slightest idea of what to do with it." And it talks about him being at board of estimate meetings and a problem coming up and he's like, gee, I don't know guys, anybody got an idea about this? Anybody got a, I got nothing.
使他成为了现代市长的完美模版。每当镜头靠近，他的眉头就会微蹙，嘴唇会抿起，下巴会前突，双眼会死死盯着手头碰巧拿着的任何一张纸，专注得仿佛他真的看懂了上面写着的字。安佩打了一场漂亮的选仗，但一旦真正坐上了他赢得的宝座，他却表现得对如何利用这个宝座毫无头绪。”书中还提到他出席估计委员会会议时，遇到了一个问题，然后他说：天哪，我不知道啊各位，有谁对这个有什么想法吗？有谁有，我什么也没有。
He is, Carol Pansom is just totally naive that he's a very sweet kind of blockhead who barely pretends he knows what he's doing. He's unaware of the power that the mayor actually holds. He's bewildered by the workings of government. He is just even more than a Dwyer. He's looking for someone to just kind of take him by the shoulder, point him in the right direction, lead him by the hand to decisions. And of course, Robert Moses is happy to be that person.
卡罗对他的评价完全是天真无邪，说他是个非常温和的笨蛋，勉强假装自己知道自己在干什么。他根本意识不到市长实际拥有的权力。他对政府的运作感到迷惑不解。他甚至比欧怀尔更严重。他一直在寻找某个人来拍拍他的肩膀，给他指明正确的方向，手把手地引导他做出决策。当然，罗伯特·摩西非常乐意扮演这个角色。
He has the big brother that every guy who is totally outclassed by the office of mayor really wants. So it was bad enough when he was going to a Dwyer's for breakfast twice a week. Now he's going up to the MPs, he's going to the mayor's office nearly every morning. He has a pile up to the MPs, he's going to the mayor's office, nearly every morning, he has a pile of papers for MP to sign, MP will sign them, and he has marching orders
他成了每个被市长办公室的职责完全压垮的家伙梦寐以求的“老大哥”。所以，以前他每周去欧怀尔那里吃两次早餐就已经够糟糕的了。现在他直接去安佩那里，他几乎每天早上都去市长办公室，桌上堆着一叠文件让安佩签字，安佩就会签下它们，而他手里则拿着
for MP for that day. If there are jobs to fill, Moses tells him who to fill those jobs with. He tells him who desperately to not fill those jobs with also. And the main test is how loyal is this person to Robert Moses? Because if they're loyal to him, they're gonna get this job.
当天给安佩的指令。如果有什么职位需要填补，摩西会告诉他让谁去填补这些职位。他还会告诉他，绝不能让谁来填补这些职位。而主要的检验标准是：这个人对罗伯特·摩西有多忠诚？因为如果他们对他忠诚，他们就能得到这份工作。
And MP, he always follows Moses' advice. He follows his tax policies. And for good measure, this is maybe the most emasculating moment, is when Moses provides the mayor with a vacation house close to his own vacation house so that he will still have close control of him even when he's on vacation, even then.
而安佩总是遵循摩西的建议。他遵循摩西的税收政策。为了做得更彻底，这或许是最具阉割意味的时刻——摩西为市长提供了一处度假屋，就紧挨着他自己的度假屋，这样哪怕安佩在度假时，他依然能对安佩保持紧密的控制，即便在那时也是如此。
And Ficklestein, he still has a little bit of time left in his term before he inevitably does not get reappointed. He manages to finish work on the master plan for the city, but his department does not have the money to print copies of the report of the master plan. And I know this is pre-Xerox, you have to go to a printer, it's printing a lot of copies, it's gonna take a couple thousand dollars. Moses, he's like, uh, mayor, don't give him the money to print those copies.
而芬肯斯坦在他的任期内还剩一点时间，直到他不可避免地无法获得重新任命。他设法完成了市总体规划的工作，但他的部门却没有资金来印制总体规划报告的复印件。我知道这是在复印机出现之前，你必须去找印刷厂，印制大量副本，这需要几千美元。摩西却说：呃，市长，别给他印这些副本的钱。
They bury the report. Uh, Finkelstein has a kind of a nervous breakdown from all the work. He finds out in the hospital that he has lost his position. He's not being reappointed and Moses has impian stall, a guy that Moses can control. And these board of estimate members who had previously supported the plan. Coincidentally around the time Moses does favors for them in their boroughs, they switched their votes. And the, and so the plan is effectively dead. And Robert Caro says, set aside the fact that $325,000 were
他们把这份报告给埋没了。芬肯斯坦因为过度劳累而濒临精神崩溃。他在医院里得知自己已经失去了职位。他没有被重新任命，而摩西则让安佩安插了一个受摩西控制的人。至于那些以前支持该计划的估计委员会成员，
spent on this plan and thus waste it because it'll never happen. The bigger cost is this idea of local control of areas of the city, a plan organized around the needs of local neighborhoods, a plan that was about finding consensus between people who have a real stake in what's happening in those regions. That's gone. The outer boroughs, they're going to continue to be developed in this haphazard, kind of irrational way, and that's the full cost of this master plan not getting off the ground. And Finkelstein, he takes his place as the latest in the parade of reformers who have tried to make the city responsive to someone other than Robert Moses and to Robert Moses then make sure does not achieve their goal.
巧合的是，就在摩西在他们的行政区为他们提供人情恩惠的同一时期，他们改变了投票立场。于是，这个计划就这样彻底流产了。罗伯特·卡罗写道，抛开为这个计划花费了32.5万美元并因此付诸东流不谈——因为它永远不会实现了，更大的代价是这种对城市区域进行地方控制的理念，这种围绕当地社区需求组织起来的计划，这种旨在那些对这些地区发生的事情真正有利害关系的人之间达成共识的计划，就这样消失了。外围行政区将继续以这种杂乱无章、近乎荒谬的方式开发，这就是总体规划未能出台的全部代价。而芬肯斯坦则在这一长串改革者队列中排在了最新的一位，这些改革者曾试图让城市对罗伯特·摩西以外的人负责，而罗伯特·摩西随后则确保他们无法实现目标。
And puts him in the hospital. Yeah, puts him in the hospital. It's like really it's a real notch on Moses' gun. He's just carving on his gun the number of reformers he's set aside and it is it shows you that um Finkelstein's working hard on this. Like it's a hard job to put together a master plan for a city, to put it in, I don't know, maybe not the most exact ways, when you care about the people that are being affected by it, you know, it's hard, it's very easy to put together a master plan when you don't really care what happens to the people
并且把他送进了医院。是的，把他送进了医院。这简直是摩西枪杆上的又一个刻痕。他只是在枪上刻下自己排挤掉的改革者的数量，这向你表明，芬肯斯坦在这上面付出了艰辛的努力。为一座城市拼凑出一份总体规划是一项艰巨的工作，把它投入，我不知道，也许不是用最精确的方式，当你关心那些受其影响的人时，你知道的，这很难。当你根本不在乎那些受其影响的人会有什么遭遇时，拼凑出一份总体规划则是轻而易举的事。
who are affected by it. Which is, for all that Moses is this amazing thinker and this master builder, the hardest part of the equation he has decided he's not gonna deal with. He's not gonna, it's like, I'm gonna build an airplane, I don't care if it gets off the ground. Oh, this guy built an amazing airplane. Look at it, it looks so cool.
这就是——尽管摩西是个了不起的思想家和建筑大师，但他已经决定不去处理方程式中最困难的部分。他不会去，这就好比：我要造一架飞机，我才不管它能不能飞离地面呢。哦，这家伙造了一架了不起的飞机。瞧它，看起来太酷了。
Does it fly? Doesn't matter, he's a great airplane builder. Or doesn't care about the passengers inside of it. It's just like. Well, that's true. It's an amazing airplane, it crashes 85% of the time. So who gets hurt? The passengers, it's fine.
它能飞吗？没关系，他是个伟大的飞机建造者。或者说根本不在乎里面的乘客。这就好嘛。好吧，确实如此。这是一架惊人的飞机，它有85%的概率会坠毁。那么谁会受伤呢？乘客呗，没关系。
The bonds on the plane, they pay off such high dividends. We can always build more, it's great. Yeah, yeah. It's fine. The bonds on the plane, they pay off such high dividends. We can always build more. It's great. Yeah. It's really something to watch this. And then it just, you know, Moses has the perfect person in MP. Just someone who would just do exactly what he says. It is Palpatine and Jar Jar Binks all over again in the Imperial Senate. Only this time it's in real life.
这架飞机带来的债券，能支付如此高的红利。我们总是可以造更多的飞机，这太棒了。是的，是的。没关系。这架飞机带来的债券，能支付如此高的红利。我们总是可以造更多的飞机。这太棒了。是的。看着这一切真的让人叹为观止。然后你知道的，摩西在安佩身上找到了完美的人选。一个只会完全照他说的去做的人。这简直就是帝国议会里的帕尔帕廷和贾贾·宾克斯再度上演。只不过这次是在现实生活中。
In New York City. not in a fictional galaxy. And Moses at this point, he's at the height of his power. He's just not showing up to meetings. He doesn't care. He gets whatever he wants. And Carol goes over numbers here, and she just talks about how vastly more was spent by the city on roads than everything else. He says during the O'Dwyer administration, when Moses only had a lot of power, the city spent like about three million dollars on colleges, about 1.1 million dollars on libraries, and 80 million dollars on highways. And under Impellatary,
在纽约市。而不是在一个虚构的银河系里。而摩西此时正处于他权力的巅峰。他甚至都不去开会了。他根本不在乎。他想要什么就能得到什么。卡罗在这里梳理了一些数据，她谈到这座城市花在道路上的资金比其他所有东西加起来还要多得多。她说在欧怀尔执政期间，当时摩西还只是拥有很大权力，城市在大学上花费了大约300万美元，在图书馆上花费了约110万美元，而在高速公路上则花费了8000万美元。而在安佩莱特里执政期间，
the numbers only go up more. The city spends four million dollars on libraries, 70 million dollars on hospitals, 137 million dollars on schools, 172 million dollars on highways, which is only, Caranotes, the city's contribution. It doesn't count federal money going into those highways. It doesn't count things, I assume, like the taxes that are not going to get paid on that real estate in the future. It is just astonishing that highways are the thing that is so much of the city's money is going into. And the city builds 88 miles of new highway during this time.
这些数字只增不减。城市在图书馆上花费了400万美元，在医院上花费了7000万美元，在学校上花费了1.37亿美元，而在高速公路上花费了1.72亿美元，而卡罗指出，这仅仅是市政府的出资额。这还不算流入这些高速公路的联邦资金。这甚至不算诸如未来那些房产将无法收缴的税收之类的东西。令人震惊的是，高速公路竟然是吞噬了这座城市如此巨额资金的项目。在这期间，这座城市修建了88英里新的高速公路。
It builds no new subway. Zero new subway miles. Zero. It's just disgraceful. Zero. Just disgraceful. Most of the people in the city use at least twice a day. It does not get expanded at all. The schools are overcrowded. There's 182 schools in the city that are not even fireproofed. And the public colleges, which New York is often justifiably proud. A lot of people in New York
它没有修建任何新的地铁。零英里新地铁。零。这简直是耻辱。零。简直是耻辱。城市里绝大多数人每天至少使用两次的交通工具，却完全没有得到扩建。学校人满为患。全市有182所学校甚至连防火设施都没有。而纽约往往引以为傲的公立大学，纽约有许多人
attend New York City's public colleges. There's a study that points out that there are 46,000 students a year who are eligible for education there and would take it, would go to those colleges, but they can't because there simply isn't infrastructure. There's no room for them in the schools. So it's just massive swaths of the city being underserved because that money is going to highways. It's really, it feels like, I just imagine Moses like he's literally like Scrooge McDuck sitting in a pile of money, just throwing it up in the air going highways, highways, highways, you know,
都上纽约市的公立大学。有一项研究指出，每年有46,000名学生符合在那接受教育的资格并且也愿意去，他们本可以去这些大学，但他们去不了，因为根本没有基础设施。学校里没有他们的空间。因此，城市的大片区域都未能得到充分的服务，因为资金全都流向了高速公路。这真的让人感觉，我简直能想象摩西就像《圣诞颂歌》里的史高治·麦克老鸭一样坐在钱堆里，把钱往空中一抛，大喊着“高速公路，高速公路，高速公路”，你知道的，
and someone comes by with a donor plate and is like, can I have five more dollars for schools? He's like, no, you can't have it. Yeah, I mean, Carol tallies this up that during MP's administration, $500 million in state and federal funds went into the New York highway and housing construction.
然后有人拿着捐赠牌走过来问：“我能多要五块钱给学校吗？”他却说：“不，你拿不到。”是的，我的意思是，卡罗统计了这些数据：在安佩任职期间，有5亿美元的州和联邦资金流入了纽约的高速公路和住房建设。
And that was all spent by Moses. That's where Moses wanted it, that's where he spent it. It's amazing for him to control that much money. And he is spending it, he's doling it out to the people who are on his team, who are doing his favors. Because remember that last chapter, it's not like he's like, it out to the people who are on his team, who are doing his favors, because remember that last chapter, it's not like he's like, I have 500 million dollars
而这些钱全都被摩西花掉了。摩西想把钱花在哪儿，钱就花在了哪儿。他能掌控如此巨额的资金，这真是太惊人了。而且他正在把钱花出去，他把钱分发给那些加入他的团队、帮他办事的人。因为记住上一章的内容，这并不意味着他会像是在说：我有5亿美元，
and I'm gonna spend it only in the most efficient, best way possible. You know, it is money for his projects and it's money he can use to accrue more power and to maintain his power. Meanwhile, this is the thing that I always forget about city budgets, is that when you issue bonds for construction,
我要把它花在最有效率、最好的地方。你知道的，这是为他的项目服务的资金，是他用来积累更多权力并维持权力的资金。与此同时，这也是我总是容易忘记的关于城市预算的一点：当你为了建设而发行债券时，
you've got to pay interest on them. And so that by 1952, the city is paying $211 million a year in debt service on the money that it borrowed to build things. Luckily, Triborough is bringing in all that toll money, right? That should cut that down. No, because Triborough gets to keep that money. That money doesn't go to the city. The city is paying off the interest fees, but it's not getting the toll money to pay it. And since it's spending all that money just to pay off the interest on things it built, it can't afford to maintain the things that it built.
你必须支付利息。因此到1952年时，这座城市每年要支付2.11亿美元的债务利息，用来偿还为搞建设而借来的钱。幸运的是，三区大桥局收了那么多的过路费，对吧？这应该能削减一部分债务吧？并没有，因为三区大桥局把那些钱全留下了。那些钱并没有交进市政府。市政府在支付利息，却拿不到过路费来还债。由于它把所有的钱都用来支付所建项目的利息，它根本无力维护它所修建的东西。
And so those roads, once Moses builds them, he puts almost no interest into maintaining them. He's just not interested in it, it seems. And so they're deteriorating. And Carol says, there was a skewing of expenditures away from service functions and toward public works construction That they are not servicing the things the city has they're instead just building new stuff and the city's population is changing
因此，这些道路一旦被摩西修建好，他几乎不花任何心思去维护它们。他对此似乎毫无兴趣。于是它们日渐残破。卡罗说，支出的方向发生了偏离，从公共服务职能转向了公共工程建设。他们没有去维护这座城市已有的设施，而是一味地去建造新东西，与此同时，这座城市的人口结构正在发生变化。
This is the era that People talk about when it's the beginning the very beginnings of movement out to the suburbs of the people who have the money to move To the suburbs. There's more and more low-income residents in the city coming in and they need services. They need them and they're not going to get them. And of course, all good and also sinister things must come to an end at some point. This 40-month ideal in which Moses is the shadow mayor behind Impellitari, it has to end at some point. But in that time, he has placed so many stakes for his projects that they cannot be undone. He's evicted so many people, their buildings have been destroyed. And what is a future mayor gonna be like?
这就是人们常说的那个时代的开始，那些有钱搬去郊区的人开始向郊区迁移的最初苗头。越来越多的低收入居民涌入城市，他们需要公共服务。他们需要这些服务，但他们却得不到。当然了，所有美好的以及邪恶的事物总归要在某个时刻画上句号。安佩在幕后扶持安佩莱特里当“影子市长”的这40个月的理想状态，总有一天会结束。但在那段时间里，他为自己的项目打下了如此之多的桩基，以至于它们再也无法被推翻了。他驱逐了那么多人，他们的建筑被摧毁了。未来的市长会变成什么样？
We're gonna stop this project that all these buildings were destroyed for? No, you could have something to make it worthwhile. You have something to show for it. Unsurprisingly, Impey is overwhelmingly defeated in the next Democratic primary. I feel like everyone in New York was just biding their time waiting for the moment when they could vote
难道我们要叫停这个导致所有这些建筑被毁的项目吗？不，你得有点成果来证明这一切是值得的。你得有东西拿得出手。不出所料，安佩在随后的民主党初选中遭到惨败。我觉得纽约的每个人当时都在隐忍蛰伏，等待着那个能够把票投给
for anyone other than him. And Moses has been so good at hiding his role in the administration that even though the city is essentially rejecting him, they don't know it. And because his jobs are unelected, even the voters rejecting his greatest puppet doesn't mean anything to him except shucks, I guess I'm just going to have 90% power instead of 100% power. And years later, Moses is talking to Carol and he's like, yeah, Impeyletary was a good mayor. He was a good mayor.
除了他以外任何人的时刻。而且摩西一直把自己在政府中的角色隐藏得极好，以至于尽管这座城市实际上是在拒绝他，他们却根本不知道。由于他的职位不是选举产生的，哪怕选民们拒绝了他最大的傀儡，对她而言也毫无意义，除了让他耸耸肩觉得：好吧，看来我只能拥有90%的权力，而不是100%的权力了。多年以后，摩西在跟卡罗交谈时还说：是的，安佩莱特里是个好市长。他是个好市长。
I thought he did a really good job. And Carol goes to visit Impey, who's working at a law firm doing kind of like a do-nothing job. He's kind of window dressing. They have a former mayor at this law firm. And Impey is going on and on about what a great man Moses is. They're so close. They were so close.
我觉得他干得真的很棒。而卡罗去拜访了安佩，当时他在一家律师事务所工作，干的基本上是那种拿钱不干活的闲差。他基本上就是块门面招牌。这家律师事务所供养着一位前市长。而安佩还在喋喋不休地吹嘘摩西是多么伟大的人物。他们曾经是那么亲密。他们曾经走得那么近。
And Carol says, when was the last time you saw him? And he says, well, actually, you know what? I was just going to summarize it, but let me just read it because it's so, there's something bittersweet about it, you know, this using up of envy. He goes, he went on for some time reminiscing about how close he and Moses had been. Then, however, he was asked when he had last seen Moses. And the sincere, friendly face turned sad as he tried in vain to recall the last time he had seen the big, charming, brilliant man who had once been so friendly to him. I haven't seen him recently, he said at last. And as much as Impy never should have been mayor, Kara has painted him as such a childlike figure that it feels so sad in that moment,
卡罗便问：你们上一次见面是什么时候？安佩回答说，嗯，事实上，你知道吗？我本来想总结一下，但让我直接读出来吧，因为这段经历太让人感慨了，你知道的，这种对安佩的榨取。他接着说：“他滔滔不绝地回忆起他和摩西曾经是多么亲密。然而，当被问及他上一次见到摩西是什么时候时，他那真诚、友善的脸上流露出了悲伤，他徒劳地试图回忆起自己最后一次见到那个曾经对他是那么亲密无间、高大、迷人而聪明的男子是在什么时候。‘我最近没见过他，’他最后说道。”尽管安佩本就不该当市长，但卡罗把他描绘成了一个如此稚气未脱的人物，以至于在那一刻让人感到无比悲伤，
such a Charlie Brown moment for a pellitary. So sad. Moses leaves mayor sad. That should be a slogan. Moses leaves Mayor sad. He uses up everybody and makes them just miserable in the end. And they're like, why in the world did I get ensorcelled by this man, except for Envy, who was just, who's like too dim-witted to like know that he was abused. No, there's the thing. You get the sense in the chapter, and I wonder if this is the case, that like, even though he was mayor of New York, he probably still felt so excited
这简直是安佩版的查理·布朗时刻。太令人难过了。摩西让市长黯然神伤。这应该成为一句标语。摩西让市长黯然神伤。他榨干了所有人，最后让他们苦不堪言。而他们却在想：我到底为什么会被这个家伙迷得神魂颠倒？除了安佩之外，因为安佩实在太迟钝了，甚至都意识不到自己被虐待了。不，关键就在于此。你在这一章里会有这种感觉，我不知道事实是否真的如此：尽管他是纽约市长，但他可能依然会感到无比兴奋，
that someone like Moses wanted to talk to him, wanted to be close with him and work with him, that this man who's so dynamic, who's so smart, who's so amazing at these things is showing him attention. And it's almost like he doesn't seem to realize that it's because he's mayor of New York that Moses is doing this. It's not like Moses likes him, you know,
因为像摩西这样的人竟然愿意跟他说话，想要跟他亲近并与他共事。这个如此充满活力、如此聪明、在这些事情上如此了不起的男人竟然向他投来了关注的目光。而且他似乎根本没有意识到，摩西这么做纯粹是因为他是纽约市长。并不是因为摩西喜欢他，你知道的，
or wants to be his friend. And it's not like Impey doesn't have something he's giving Moses. It's just a, it's a, I wonder if he was as naive as Carol paints him, but there's not a lot of, uh, biographies of Impey to crack open to get an alternate take. Maybe there's one, but I don't know of it, so.
或者想和他做朋友。也不是说安佩没有给摩西提供任何东西。这只是一种，我不知道他是否真如卡罗描绘的那样天真，但市面上并没有太多关于安佩的传记可供翻阅来获得另一种视角。也许有一本，但我不知道，所以就这样吧。
Um, okay, so this last little bit of, uh, the three mayors chapter is Robert Wagner, which is, if you'll remember, is the scene that starts the whole book is an interaction with Robert Wagner. Yes, and we should call him Robert F. Wagner, that's his official name, because then again, there's an actor named Robert Wagner,
嗯，好吧，关于“三位市长”这一章的最后一点内容是关于罗伯特·瓦格纳的，如果你还记得的话，全书开篇的场景就是与罗伯特·瓦格纳的互动。是的，我们应该叫他小罗伯特·F·瓦格纳，那是他的正式名字，因为同样地，刚好有一位名叫罗伯特·瓦格纳的演员，
we don't want to get them mixed up, but the- And he's a junior too, right? That's true, that's the thing, He's Robert F. Wagner, Jr. because Robert F. Wagner, Sr. was also a figure in New York politics. He was a state legislator. And as we'll get into it right now, let's just say, so there's just a little bit about Robert F. Wagner, Jr. here because he's going to play a bigger role. It's kind of like this end of this chapter is kind of like teasing us a little bit for the future. But Caro jumps back to those days we remember so well. Young Robert Moses hanging out with Al Smith, singing along at all hours of the night just as the
我们不想把他们搞混，但是……而且他也是个小罗伯特，对吧？确实如此，这就是关键所在，他是小罗伯特·F·瓦格纳，因为老罗伯特·F·瓦格纳曾经也是纽约政坛的人物。他曾是一名州议员。正如我们马上要深入探讨的那样，我们先简单介绍一下小罗伯特·F·瓦格纳，因为他将扮演更重要的角色。这章的结尾有点像是在为未来做铺垫。但卡罗把我们带回了那些我们记忆犹新的日子。年轻的小罗伯特·摩西和阿尔·史密斯混在一起，在深夜阿尔·史密斯公寓里的钢琴声中，
piano was played at Al Smith's apartment. And who's there with them? Al Smith's former roommate, fellow legislator Robert F. Wagner Sr. And who does Robert F. Wagner Sr. bring with him? His little boy, Robert F. Wagner, Jr. Moses has known this mayor since this mayor was a boy. So, already there's a power dynamic imbalance right there because it's hard to know somebody as a child and not always see that child in them. But Robert F. Wagner, Jr., he decides to go into his dad's business, he goes into politics, and his first race for a district office, Moses does him a favor. Moses arranges for him to promise the building of a swimming pool.
整夜跟着哼唱。谁和他们在一起？阿尔·史密斯的前室友、同为议员的老罗伯特·F·瓦格纳。老罗伯特·F·瓦格纳把谁带来了？他的小男孩，小罗伯特·F·瓦格纳。摩西从这位市长还是个男孩的时候就认识他了。所以，这里已经存在权力动态的不平衡了，因为你很难把一个人当作孩子来看待，而脑海里却不总浮现出他当年的样子。但是小罗伯特·F·瓦格纳决定继承父业，踏入政坛，在他竞选第一个地区公职时，摩西帮了他一个忙。摩西安排他承诺建造一个游泳池。
And then I guess when he's in office, Moses builds that pool. And so he has bolstered him. And so they have a relationship. Wagner has, I guess, made the mistake early on of letting Moses do something for him. But the relationship sours, because as Wagner rises, he becomes Manhattan Borough President,
然后我想当他上任后，摩西就真的建了那个游泳池。因此，摩西支持了他。所以他们建立了一种关系。瓦格纳大概在一开始就犯了一个错误，那就是让摩西为他做了一件事。但随着瓦格纳的崛起，关系开始恶化，因为他成为了曼哈顿区长，
and he supports the master plan. And when Moses says, hey, hire this guy, he goes, I'm gonna hire this other person that I like, rather than your person. And Wagner, he has a habit, he does not badmouth anybody, he doesn't like to say a bad thing about anybody, but people around him get the feeling he does not like Robert Moses. And he runs for mayor, he runs against Moses's preferred candidate, Impy, the perfect type of mayor, essentially an empty suit, and he says, I'm going to stand up to Moses after the election. And I wonder if there's a reversal that Moses sees Wagner as someone, he's known him since he was a boy, but Wagner is also like, I've known you since my whole life.
并且他支持总体规划。当摩西说，嘿，雇这个人吧，他说，我要雇我喜欢的另一个人，而不是你的人。瓦格纳有一个习惯，他从不说别人的坏话，不喜欢说任何人的坏话，但他周围的人都觉得他不喜欢罗伯特·摩西。他竞选市长，与摩西青睐的候选人伊姆皮对垒——伊姆皮是个完美类型的市长，本质上是个傀儡——他说，选举过后我要顶撞摩西。我想知道这其中是否存在一种逆转，摩西把瓦格纳看作是他从小看着长大的孩子，但瓦格纳也会想：我一辈子都认识你。
Maybe he's not as afraid of him because he remembers back when he was just a guy singing along with Governor Al Smith late at night to a piano. You know? And so we get to this scene, back to where we started, as you said in the introduction, Wagner is coming in. People say to him, don't renew Moses' membership on the planning commission.
也许他没有那么害怕摩西，因为他还记得摩西当年只是个在深夜里陪着州长阿尔·史密斯在钢琴旁哼唱的普通人。你知道吗？于是我们来到了这个场景，回到了我们开始的地方，正如你在引言中所说，瓦格纳上任了。人们对他说，不要续签摩西在规划委员会的会员资格。
Surely the creators of this government did not intend for somebody to propose a project in one job and then approve it in another job. It seems at the very least anti-democratic and maybe a little foolish, you know, for someone to be in charge of, to be their own boss in that way. And it leads us to that scene.
这个政府的创立者肯定没有意图让某人在一个职位上提出一个项目，然后在另一个职位上批准它。这至少看起来是反民主的，甚至可能有点愚蠢，你知道的，一个人掌控大权，以这种方式成为自己的老板。这就把我们带到了那个场景。
Wagner tries to do it subtly. He just does not include that as one of the posts that he is signing Mo's in for, but Moses realizes it. If he thought Moses just wasn't gonna notice till later, he was mistaken. And Moses goes into Wagner, and Wagner's like, I guess we got to get the paperwork ready. And Moses goes out, fills out the paperwork himself, hands it to him, and he says, I will resign from all of my posts if you don't sign this. Or at least that's what Moses told people close to him. Because Carol says, by the point he wanted to ask Moses about this, Moses had already cut off all contact with him and
瓦格纳试图做得隐蔽一些。他只是没有把这个职位列入他要让摩西续签的名单中，但摩西意识到了。如果他以为摩西不会马上察觉，那他就大错特错了。摩西走进瓦格纳的办公室，瓦格纳一副“我想我们得准备好文件了”的样子。结果摩西走出去，自己填好文件，递给瓦格纳，并说道：如果你不签字，我就辞去我所有的职务。至少摩西是这么对亲信说的。因为卡罗说，等他想就此事质问摩西时，摩西已经断绝了与他的一切联系，并且
Cara talks to Wagner Wagner kind of tiptoes around it and doesn't want to fully admit that he fell for the resignation threat Yeah, yeah, yeah, we've come full circle. It's that scene again. We're there Yeah in in editorial circles is known as an e-shape structure Which is like you tease a little bit of something that happens later on I I mean, this is a very big E, you know, like usually. It's a huge, it's an enormously, that's true, yeah. But you tease something in the future, that's a significant moment, and then eventually you circle back to it
卡罗和瓦格纳交谈时，瓦格纳对此支支吾吾，不愿完全承认自己被辞职威胁给吓住了。对，对，对，我们又回到了原点。又是那个场景。我们就在那里。对，在编辑界，这被称为E形结构，也就是先剧透一点后面要发生的事情。我的意思是，这是一个非常大的E，你知道，通常情况下。这是一个巨大的，非常大的，确实如此。但你在未来剧透某事，这是一个重要的时刻，然后最终你又回到了它，
and you see it again, and then the rest of the book, you know, the following, I don't know, 500 pages is the tail end of the E coming up. It's the tail, this is a lowercase E you're talking about. Exactly, it's a lowercase E. Because like an uppercase E would be more like, you'd make a turn, you turn into dead end, and then you'd have to keep going the rest of the way. This is a lowercase E you're talking about. Exactly, it's a lowercase E. Because like an uppercase E would be more like you make a turn, you turn into a dead end,
然后你再次看到它，然后这本书的其余部分，你知道，接下来的，我不知道，500页就是E的尾巴部分。这是尾巴，你说的这是小写字母e。没错，这就是一个小写字母e。因为如果是一个大写字母E，更像是你会转弯，转到一个死胡同里，然后你必须继续走完剩下的路。你说的这个是小写字母e。没错，这就是一个小写字母e。因为如果是一个大写字母E，更像是你转了个弯，转进了一个死胡同，
and then you have to keep going the rest of the way. It's a lowercase E, yeah. I've never heard about that. I mean, that's a perfect way to describe it. That's great. We are now in, it also means we are in unstable ground at this point. We don't know what happens after this scene.
然后你必须继续走完剩下的路。这是一个小写字母e，是的。我从来没听说过这个。我的意思是，这真是个完美的描述。太棒了。我们现在处于，这也意味着我们此时正处于不稳定的地步。我们不知道这个场景之后会发生什么。
We don't know what happens after this, yeah. Because we don't know. This is what we've been prepared for. It's the man who can stand up to the mayor and just like hand him a black piece of paper, fill it out really fast and just say, sign it, and have him get his way. After this moment, we're in uncharted territory
我们不知道之后会发生什么，是的。因为我们不知道。这就是我们一直以来所做的心理准备。那个能够顶撞市长，把一张空白纸递过去，让人飞快填好并说“签字”，然后就能如愿以偿的人。这一刻之后，我们进入了未知的领域，
when it comes to Moses and his power, which is a great moment, super exciting. Kara's so good at stuff. Anyway, so Wagner's aide, Warren Moscow, he goes, you should do something dramatic on housing. And he puts together this big housing development plan and Moscow thinks he's doing the smart thing. He makes sure to get Moses' approval.
当谈到摩西和他的权力时，这真是一个伟大的时刻，超级令人兴奋。卡罗太擅长写这些了。不管怎样，瓦格纳的助手沃伦·莫斯科说，你应该在住房问题上做点轰轰烈烈的事情。于是他制定了这个大型住房开发计划，莫斯科认为自己在做一件聪明的事。他确保获得了摩西的批准。
And Moses is like, yeah, it's a good plan. Yeah, we should do this. Moscow then does the dumb thing. He presents the plan to the board of estimate rather than letting Moses do it. And Moses throws a fit and he tells Wagner, you gotta kill that plan, kill it. And then once the plan is dead,
摩西说，是的，这是个好计划。是的，我们应该这样做。然后莫斯科做了一件蠢事。他把计划提交给估价委员会，而不是让摩西来呈交。摩西大发雷霆，他告诉瓦格纳，你得把这个计划扼杀掉，彻底扼杀掉。然后一旦这个计划流产了，
Moses submits pretty much the same plan but with his name on it and it flies through the approval process. It is Moses at this point, what I like about it is it's similar. It's more symmetry where he has become the thing that politicians want to be that he uses against them. He wants to have his name on this thing and that's important to him. That's right. That's right. Another thing that happens here is like, even though he's in shakier territory with Wagner, you Wagner, he's been in power for so long
摩西几乎提交了同一份计划，但署上了他自己的名字，然后它就一路绿灯通过了审批程序。此时的摩西，我最喜欢的一点是，这很相似。这更像是一种对称，他已经变成了政客们梦寐以求的样子，而他却用这一点来对付他们。他希望在这件事上署上自己的名，这对他来说很重要。没错。没错。这里发生的另一件事是，尽管他和瓦格纳的关系不那么稳固了，但你瞧，瓦格纳掌权的时间太久了，
that anyone qualified to do anything, anyone whose opinion you would respect to say, maybe Moses isn't right about this, is somebody that Moses hired 20 years ago and trained, and nobody qualified in the city to offer a counter argument. They all have some association with Moses. He probably hired them at some point and trained him to think the way he does.
以至于任何有资格做点什么的人、任何你愿意尊重其意见并认为“摩西在这件事上可能不对”的人，都是摩西在20年培植并训练出来的。城里没有一个有资格提出反驳意见的人。他们都和摩西有着某种联系。他很可能在某个时候雇用了他们，并把他们培训成和自己一样的思维方式。
It like, so he's insulated, like the new people may come and go, but by this point, the sort of ecosystem around him is just kind of versions of Moses men. You know what I mean? They're not, he's in a circle, but they're like, there's some form of progeny that has grown up in the Moses world.
所以，他是被隔离保护的，新人可能会来来去去，但到了这个时候，他周围的整个生态系统基本上都是各种版本的“摩西的人”。你知道我的意思吗？他们不是……他身处一个圈子里，但他们就像是在摩西的世界里长大的一些后代。
So, you know, he's really buffeted by all this support. And so, you know, like Wagner can complain all he wants to in some ways, but he can turn to no one who would disagree with Moses about almost anything. Yes, and these are jobs that require a high level of education and skill and experience. So it's not like you could just get someone else to, you can't clean house.
所以，你知道，他真的被所有这些支持给包裹保护起来了。因此，你知道，瓦格纳怎么抱怨都可以，但在几乎所有事情上，他都找不到一个会不同意摩西观点的人。是的，这些都是需要很高教育水平、技能和经验的工作。所以这不像是随便拉个人就能顶替的，你无法彻底清洗。
Who would you find? And Moscow says that some of Moses' power comes from, he says, quote, stem simply from the fact that his enterprises developed people. Like you're saying, they develop people in the Moses way of thinking, which makes me think about Moses.
你能找到谁？莫斯科说，摩西的部分权力来自于，他原话是，简单源于这样一个事实，即他的企业培养了人才。就像你说的，他们按照摩西的思维方式培养人才，这让我想到了摩西。
I know I've compared Bob Moses in this episode already to Cthulhu and Bob from Twin Peaks. So I hope this comparison is not- And an octopus that throws fish. And an octopus. That one didn't quite work. Yeah, fish throwing octopus. That one, we could strike that from the record, Your Honor. This is not as sinister a comparison, but it makes me think about Robert Moses almost as like a Public Works Lorne Michaels. Yeah. Like a lot of Lorne Michaels' strength doesn't come from SNL being the most amazing show on TV,
我知道我在这一集里已经把鲍勃·摩西比作过克苏鲁和《双峰》里的鲍勃了。所以我希望这个比喻不是——还有会扔鱼的章鱼。还有章鱼。那个比喻不太贴切。对，扔鱼的章鱼。法官大人，我们可以把那个记录划掉。这个比喻没那么阴险，但它让我把罗伯特·摩西几乎看作是公共工程界的洛恩·迈尔斯。对。就像洛恩·迈尔斯的许多实力并非来自于《周六夜现场》是电视上最棒的节目，
but comes from the fact that it is such an incubator of talent and those people go out and they spread that kind of comedy and he's been doing it for 40 years. And so now it's hard to find people in comedy who don't at least have some connection to the SNL world in some way. Totally, there's a sitcom with Broadway video on the front of it as a marker.
而是来自于它是人才的超级孵化器，这些人走出去，传播那种喜剧风格，而且他已经这样做了40年。所以现在在喜剧界很难找到一个与《周六夜现场》世界没有半点联系的人。完全是这样，百老汇录像带（Broadway Video）的名字就像个标志印在情景喜剧上。
Yes, yeah. Just because. And you're like, wow, yeah. And it's because Lorne Michaels created all these people and cultivated this whole development process. Yeah, and it shows how much you can get through, yeah, through the cultivation of people, through staffing power,
是的，没错。就凭这一点。你会觉得，哇，确实。这是因为洛恩·迈尔斯创造了所有人，并培养了整个发展过程。是的，这表明通过培养人才、通过人事权力、
through bringing people up through the ranks. Power is not just about corruption and graft. It's also about developing and encouraging people to think the way that you think and also give them the opportunities that they feel that loyalty to you and they agree with you on things. And Moses really, he's really good at that.
通过将人才从底层提拔上来，你能取得多大的成就。权力不仅仅关于腐败和受贿。它还关于培养和鼓励人们以你的方式思考，并给予他们机会，让他们对你产生忠诚感，并在事情上与你意见一致。摩西真的，他在这方面非常擅长。
And it's not until 1958 when Wagner just fully reorganizes the housing authority that Moses loses his control over it. That's after 13 years of domination. And even if he doesn't fully control it still, he still maintains power over its funding, its relationship to the state, the slum clearance work, transportation through it, parks in it.
直到1958年，当瓦格纳彻底重组房屋管理局时，摩西才失去了对它的控制。那是在统治了13年之后。即便他不再能完全控制它，他依然保持着对它的资金、与州的关系、贫民窟清理工作、其中的交通以及其中的公园的权力。
Like there's just, it, Moses is like, it's like, I don't know if you've ever had gophers in your yard. It's just, it's hard to get rid of them. They just, they don't go away. There's always more, you know. You think you fill in one hole, another hole opens up. This is a real-life problem that I've had to deal with and it's very frustrating. And that's Moses. He's everywhere. You stop up one thing and there's all these other places that he pops up.
就像，摩西就像是……我不知道你的院子里有没有过地鼠。总之很难摆脱它们。它们就是挥之不去。总会有更多，你知道的。你以为填上了一个洞，另一个洞又冒出来了。这是我不得不处理的现实生活中的问题，非常令人沮丧。这就是摩西。他无处不在。你堵住一个地方，他在所有其他地方又冒出来了。
And he doesn't have the automatic power that he had under Impey, but he still usually gets what he wants. For all of Wagner's, I'm going to stand up to Moses. That standing up to him is for the most part, kind of nibbling around the edges and not addressing the core of the power. And if he doesn't get what he wants, he's always got the resignation threat. Just take that out of mothballs and he starts to use it again.
他不再拥有在伊姆皮手下时那种绝对的权力，但他通常还是能如愿以偿。尽管瓦格纳表现出“我要顶撞摩西”的姿态，但这种顶撞在很大程度上只是在边缘小修小修，并没有触及权力的核心。如果他没有如愿以偿，他手里总还有辞职威胁这招。只要把这招拿出来，他又开始用了。
And he starts to use it a lot. Will anyone, will no, I was like, will no one save us from this turbulent city construction coordinator? Will nobody do the job of saying, I accept to the resignation? We're just gonna have to wait to find out is Wagner that man? Is he the one who's finally gonna do it? We're gonna have to find out in the future because that's the end of this chapter and this chapter had a lot of, had a lot of tough stuff in it, a lot of dense facts, but we're coming up
而且他开始频繁地使用这一招。难道没有人，难道没有人能把我们从这个暴躁的城市建设协调员手中拯救出来吗？难道没有人愿意承担起说“我接受这份辞职”的工作吗？我们只能拭目以待，瓦格纳会是那个人吗？他是那个最终会动手的人吗？我们只能在未来拭目以待，因为这是这一章的结尾，而这一章包含了许多艰难的内容，许多密集的史实，但我们马上要迎来
on two chapters that are very readable. The next episode is going to have some chapters, one of which is just super fun and the other one which is just heartbreaking. We're about to get into some very heartbreaking stuff that is some of the reason that Carol really needed to write this book. And so I feel like this episode, we're kind of on the top of the, we've been going up the top of the roller coaster
两章非常易读的内容。下一集将会有几个章节，其中一个超级有趣，另一个则令人心碎。我们即将进入一些非常令人心碎的内容，这也是卡罗真正需要写这本书的部分原因。所以我觉得这一集，我们有点像是在……我们正在坐过山车爬坡，
and it's super exciting as you're going up. But there's that moment when you're about to go over the top where you're like, should I get off of this thing? Like, I don't know if I can handle this. And then you start heading down again and you're like, too late, I'm enjoying it again. And I'm not gonna say the next chapters
往上爬的时候超级刺激。但就在你即将冲过顶峰的那个瞬间，你会想：我是不是应该从这玩应儿上面下来？我不知道我能不能承受。然后你开始向下俯冲，你会觉得：太迟了，我又开始享受了。我不是说接下来的章节
are necessarily enjoyable because because like I said, some of it is heartbreaking. But there's some amazing stuff coming up in the book that I just can't wait to talk about with you. But that's where we leave it this episode. Yeah, there's a lot more human tragedy and a lot less about banking and bonds. That's true. If you want to hear more about bonds, you're going to have to look out for some other books
一定会有多享受，因为就像我说的，其中一些内容令人心碎。但书中即将出现一些非常精彩的内容，我简直迫不及待地想跟你聊聊。不过我们在这一集里就先讲到这里。是的，这里有更多的人类悲剧，而关于银行和债券的内容则少了很多。确实如此。如果你想听更多关于债券的内容，你得去找别的书看了，
because we kind of covered it, I think. Yeah. More about people. And we'll cover that next time. But coming up, our conversation with New York City writer and influencer Shiloh Frederick about her experience reading The Power Broker as a native New Yorker and how her viral videos about the book actually made some change. And now our conversation with Shiloh Frederick. From when we were first planning this series, the one person I knew I wanted to have on was Shiloh. Because around that time, I read an article in the New York Times about an influencer who was reading The Power Broker and was so disturbed by the passage about the Iron Monkey decorations
因为我觉得我们已经讲得差不多了。是的，更多的是关于人的。我们下次再聊。接下来，是我们与纽约市作家兼网红希洛·弗雷德里克的对话，聊聊她作为土生土长的纽约人阅读《权力掮客》的体验，以及她关于这本书的病毒式传播视频如何真正带来了一些改变。现在，请听我们与希洛·弗雷德里克的对话。从我们最初规划这个系列开始，我就知道我一定要邀请希洛来做客。因为大约在那个时候，我在《纽约时报》上读到了一篇文章，讲的是一位网红在读《权力掮客》时，对哈林区公园里关于
in the Harlem Park that she took a little trip, recording as she went. Today I'm in Riverside Park looking for something, but I hope to God I don't find it. Or else my next stop will have to be the grave of Robert Moses so I could summon him so we could fight. The video went viral on Instagram and TikTok and to hear the rest of this story, well, you're gonna have to stick around. Thank you so much for being on the 99%
铁猴子装饰的段落感到如此不安，以至于她开启了一场边走边录的小旅行。今天我在河滨公园寻找某种东西，但我祈求上帝千万别让我找到。否则我的下一站就得去罗伯特·摩西的坟墓，这样我就可以召唤他出来和他决斗。这段视频在Instagram和TikTok上疯传，至于这个故事的后续，好吧，你得留下来听听。非常感谢你来到99%
visible Powerbroker breakdown. It's nice to have you. Thank you, it's fantastic to be here. So around September, 2023, you decided to do an extremely foolhardy thing. What was that? I decided that I would tackle reading The Power Broker in 30 days, splitting that up evenly.
隐形播客的《权力掮客》拆解节目。很高兴你能来。谢谢，很高兴能来到这里。所以大约在2023年9月，你决定做一件极其鲁莽的事情。那是什么？我决定要在30天内啃完《权力掮客》，把页数平分。
That would be around 39 pages per day, which that doesn't sound any, any other book doesn't sound bad, right? It sounds very reasonable until you see the size of this book. Exactly. And the density of it, you know, like, yeah. Yeah, the density is what really shocked me because I went into this thinking, oh, 39 pages a day, this is gonna be a breeze.
那大约是每天39页，听起来……别的书听起来没什么，对吧？听起来非常合理，直到你看到这本书的厚度。完全正确。而且它的信息密度很高，你知道的，是的。是的，信息密度才是真正让我震惊的地方，因为我开始读的时候想：噢，一天39页，这简直小菜一碟。
It'll probably be an hour or two of my day. The very first day I tried reading it, 6 a.m., just to get it out of the way, the first hour I only had ended up reading seven pages and I was shocked. I realized this was gonna be a lot more difficult than I thought. Yeah, okay, so tell me about yourself and what you do.
一天花个一两个小时就够了。结果我尝试阅读的第一天，早上6点，为了赶紧把任务完成，第一个小时我竟然只读了7页，我惊呆了。我意识到这比我想象的要难得多。好的，那么跟我聊聊你自己以及你是做什么的吧。
So why did you feel like you needed to read The Power Broker? So as a job, I know some people don't really consider this a real job, but. It's okay. We're podcasters. None of us have real jobs. We've been pioneering the concept of a not real job for a long, long time. So you're my people.
那你为什么觉得自己非得读《权力掮客》不可呢？因为我的工作——我知道有些人并不认为这真的是一份工作，但是……没关系。我们是播客主。我们谁也没有正经工作。我们很早就开始开创“非正经工作”的概念了。所以你是我的同道中人。
You understand. Exactly. But I create videos and blog posts and now branching out into zines on New York City history, specifically the buildings and the architecture history. But anything that catches my curiosity, I'll make content around it and hopefully educate and entertain my audience with it. The stories that I was attracted to would be the stories of why things are the way they are. And when you put that in perspective of the world around you, looking at buildings and
你懂的。完全正确。但我创作视频、博客文章，现在还把业务拓展到了关于纽约市历史的杂志上，特别是建筑和建筑历史。但任何引起我好奇心的事情，我都围绕它制作内容，希望能借此教育和娱乐我的受众。我被吸引的故事往往是那些解释“事物为何如此”的故事。当你把这一点放在你周围世界的视角来看，去看建筑，
looking at designs and I don't even looking at like the MTA and what keeps things going. So as a person who is studying New York City history for a living, I felt that my education of New York wouldn't be complete without reading The Power Broker because this is a book that you see on all the must read New York lists. It's consistently on those lists and I hadn't read it. So I felt that last September would be as good as time as any to start reading it, September being back to school season. That was, as someone who's been out of college for about seven, eight years, that was a shock. It was probably more difficult
去看设计，甚至去看MTA（大都会运输署）以及是什么在维持城市运转。所以作为一个以研究纽约市历史为生的人，我觉得如果没读过《权力掮客》，我对纽约的教育就不算完整，因为这是你在所有纽约必读书单上都能看到的书。它一直都在那些书单上，而我却没读过。所以我觉得去年9月是开始阅读它的绝佳时机，9月正值开学季。作为一个大学毕业已经七八年的人来说，这真是一个打击。它可能比我上过的任何历史课都要难。
than any history course I've taken. So, as a native New Yorker, before you had read The Power Broker, were you aware of the impact Robert Moses had on your life? Not at all. And now that I'm aware of it, his name is a name that I think about daily. It's like a ghost haunting me.
所以，作为土生土长的纽约人，在读《权力掮客》之前，你意识到罗伯特·摩西对你的生活有什么影响吗？完全没有。而现在我知道了，他的名字成了我每天都会想起的名字。就像一个幽灵在纠缠我。
So in what way? Well, let's see. So I currently live in a neighborhood called Inwood at the very top of Manhattan. You probably familiar with it now. Inwood Park is the park that Robert Moses destroyed to build the Henry Hudson Parkway. And taking walks in that park daily, I see that bridge. And every time I see it, I just want to shake my fist because it's a very beautiful view that he's ruined. I just have a big steel, massive steel going across it now. But that's only one of the things that I see on a daily basis that Robert Moses has affected.
那是在哪种方面？嗯，让我想想。我目前住在曼哈顿最北端一个叫因伍德（Inwood）的社区。你现在可能对它很熟悉了。因伍德公园就是罗伯特·摩西为了修建亨利·哈德逊公园大道而摧毁的那个公园。每天在那个公园散步时，我都能看到那座桥。每次看到它，我都恨不得挥起拳头，因为那是他毁掉的一处非常美丽的风景。现在我看到的只有横跨其上的巨大钢结构。但这只是罗伯特·摩西影响到我日常生活的事情之一。
Surprisingly enough, he did not really affect the neighborhood that I grew up in. I grew up in Flatlands, but everything around it he's had an effect on. But I wonder if that's the case because can you talk to us about the transportation situation in that part of Brooklyn? Namely, is there easy subway access to get in and out of that area of Brooklyn? Now that you mention it, not all. There is not easy subway access in Flatlands. I grew up having to walk an entire mile from my home to the nearest subway station, which is the Flavish Avenue station
出人意料的是，他并没有真正影响我长大的那个社区。我在弗拉特兰兹（Flatlands）长大，但他对周围的一切都产生了影响。但我想知道事实是否真的如此，因为你能跟我们聊聊布鲁克林那一带的交通状况吗？也就是说，从布鲁克林的那个区域进出，有便捷的地铁吗？经你这么一提起，完全没有。弗拉特兰兹没有便捷的地铁。我从小就得步行足足一英里从家走到最近的地铁站，也就是2号线和5号线终点站的
for the end of the two and the five line. Wow. Flatlands is actually really car-centric. I grew up taking cars everywhere because the buses are, I wouldn't say unreliable, but the buses aren't preferred method of transportation. So you're bringing up a good point. It's wild to me the idea of growing up in Brooklyn and spending most of your time traveling in cars.
夫拉特布什大道（Flatbush Avenue）车站。哇。弗拉特兰兹其实非常以汽车为中心。我从小到大去哪儿都得坐车，因为公交车——我不会说它们不可靠，但公交车不是首选的交通方式。所以你提到了一点。在我看来，在布鲁克林长大，大部分时间都在汽车里度过，这太疯狂了。
It feels like it's so – again, Brooklyn is enormous. New York is an enormous city. But it feels like your life then is being affected by his lack of interest in allowing the city to expand that subway system, that so much money was hoovered up for roads and so little was available for mass transit, that even by that neglect is impacting the lives of people around. It's a powerful person where his positive actions affect people and his negative action, by negative actions I mean inaction. Like his, and by positive action I just mean
感觉——再说一次，布鲁克林很大。纽约是一座巨大的城市。但感觉你的生活受到了他那种对扩建地铁系统缺乏兴趣的负面影响，大量的资金都被吸干用于修建公路，而留给公共交通的却少之又少，甚至连这种漠视都在影响着周围人们的生活。这是一个很有权势的人，他的积极行动会影响人们，而他的消极行动——我指的是不作为。就像他的，我说的积极行动只是指
he's doing something, not that it's a great thing that he's doing, but his actions affect people and his inaction affects people, which is astounding. It is, it is. And I can think of people in my life who his actions have had a more direct detrimental effect on. As my fiance grew up in the Bronx, in the South Bronx, and his house, his family's home, is right on the corner where the major Deacon Expressway and the cross Bronx meet.
他在做点什么，并不是说他做的是件多伟大的事，但他的行动影响着人们，他的不作为也影响着人们，这太惊人了。确实，确实如此。我能想到我生命中有些人的生活曾直接受到他更具破坏性的影响。我的未婚夫是在布朗克斯长大的，在南布朗克斯，他家、他家族的房子就在狄根远东高速公路和横贯布朗克斯高速公路交汇的拐角处。
Oh, wow. He has been plagued with really severe headaches his entire life. And his sister, one of his little sisters, has severe asthma. Not surprising if you look at their house on Google Maps. Wow, that's amazing. So you made like an announcement video that you were going to read The Power Broker in 30 days. if you look at their house on Google Maps. Wow, that's amazing. So you made like an announcement video that you were gonna read the Power Broker in 30 days. And then somewhere in the middle of the month,
哦，哇。他一辈子都饱受剧烈头疼的折磨。他的妹妹，其中一个小妹妹，患有严重的哮喘。如果你们在谷歌地图上查看他们的房子，就会觉得一点也不奇怪。哇，太惊人了。所以你做了一个类似预告的视频，说你要在30天内读完《权力掮客》。如果你们在谷歌地图上查看他们的房子，就会觉得一点也不奇怪。哇，太惊人了。所以你做了一个类似预告的视频，说你要在30天内读完《权力掮客》。然后在这个月的某个时候，
you ran across the decorations at Ten Mile River playground. This is in the chapter about the West Side Improvement. One of the sort of innovations that Robert Moses comes up with to make it all affordable is by the time it gets into Harlem, he's not doing all the nice things that would make a park good. He's not covering up the tracks, he's, you know, whatever.
你偶然发现了十英里河游乐场的装饰。这是关于西区改善工程那一章。罗伯特·摩西为了让整个工程能够负担得起，想出的创新方法之一就是，当工程延伸到哈林区时，他就不去做那些能让公园变好的漂亮事了。他没有把铁轨盖起来，他就是……随便怎样。
But one thing he does do is on one of the comfort stations, sort of basically outside public restroom. He, I think it's like, basically the frame is silver and then there's these monkeys that are decorating it that are black and they're like shackled to the sort of other part of the... They're not playful or enjoyable monkeys. They're not monkeys that are having a great,
但他确实做的一件事是，在一个休息站——基本上就是室外的公共厕所外面。他，我想大概是这样的，框架是银色的，然后有一些黑色的猴子装饰在上面，它们被铁链锁在……它们不是那种顽皮好玩的猴子。它们不是那种过得很开心的猴子，
let alone the fact that they're monkeys. They're monkeys that look like they're having a terrible time, that they don't wanna be there and are being kept there against their will. So there's a number of different layers of terrible, just kind of offensive messaging going on in these sculptures, which it's the efficiency of Robert Moses that he can offend
更不用说它们是猴子了。这些猴子看起来过得很惨，它们不想呆在那里，却被强行留在那里违背意愿。所以这些雕塑中存在着多层可怕的、带有冒犯性的信息，这就是罗伯特·摩西的高效之处，他能在同一个设计中从如此多的不同层面冒犯到别人。这有点尴尬。当我读到书的那个部分时，我不知道，也许是罗伯特·卡罗的文字以及层层铺垫产生的效果……但意识到罗伯特·摩西可能做了这么一件刻意的事，某种程度上那件事击碎了我内心的一部分。是的。是的。所以，所以，所以你决定要去……你知道，这本书是50年前写的。谁也不知道那些猴子还在不在。所以你亲自去寻找它们了。
on so many different levels in one design. This is a little embarrassing. And when I was reading that section of the book, I don't know, maybe it's the effect of Robert Carroll's writing and just the buildup to it making But realizing that Robert Moses had done something possibly so deliberate, something about that broke something in me. Yeah. Yeah. And so, so, so you decide that you're going to, you know, like, you know, this book was written 50 years ago. There's no telling why that those monkeys are still there or not. So you go out there to go find them.
我本来以为找不到的。我想，噢，这会是一趟短暂的旅行。甚至都算不上短途旅行。这会是一趟去哈林区的旅行。可能是在浪费时间，但内心深处有什么东西只是想确认它不在那里，然而事与愿违，50年后它竟然还在那里。谁有通灵板吗？
And I didn't think I would find them. I thought, Oh, this is going to be a quick trip. Not even a quick trip. This will, this will be a trip to Harlem. Probably be a waste of time, but something in me just wanted to confirm that it wasn't there and much to, much to the opposite. It was still there 50 years later. Anyone got a Ouija board?
因为我要和这个幽灵硬刚一下了。我拍那个视频并不是为了当什么拆除猴子的维权人士，但我认为那里有一个需要被讲出来的故事，有一小段历史，我希望人们至少能意识到它的存在。那么你在什么时候得知猴子被拆除了呢？
Cause I'm about to knuckle up with this ghost. I didn't necessarily make that video to be an activist for removing the monkeys, but I thought that there was a story there that needed to be told, a little piece of history that I wanted people to be aware of at least. So at what point did you learn that the monkeys have been taken down?
我从没想过看到某个东西失去装饰我会这么高兴，但我无比兴奋地证实，罗伯特·摩西在河滨公园的猴子——你知道的，就是在哈林区十英里河游乐场挂在手腕上的那些黑色猴子——现在已经没有了。因为在某个时候，那些猴子被拆除了，而且我觉得这件事发生时并没有正式公告。所以你发现了什么？
I never thought I'd be happy to see something lose its decoration, but I am ecstatic to confirm that Robert Moses' Riverside Park monkeys, you know, the black ones that were hanging by their wrists at Ten Mile River playground in Harlem, they're now gone. Cause at some point the monkeys had been taken down and I don't think it was really announced that it happened. So what did you find out?
呃，我是从几个发信息给我的粉丝那里知道的，有人甚至给我发了一封电子邮件。他们找到了我的邮箱地址，然后说：“嘿，我在公园管理局工作，你可能会高兴地知道，你在视频里谈到的那些猴子现在已经没了。”我不得不立刻赶到那里去核实他们说的话，果不其然，它们真的没了。我没想到他们效率这么高，也绝对没料到他们会因为一个随意的TikTok视频而采取行动。但我后来了解到，公园管理局其实多年来一直试图摆脱这个东西。它多年来一直都在
Uh, I found out, I found out from a few followers that were sending me messages about this, someone actually sent me an email. They found my email address and they're like, Hey, I work for the parks department and you'd be happy to know that the monkeys that you talked about in your video are now gone. And I was, I had to rush here immediately just to confirm what they said and lo and behold, they were gone. I didn't expect them to work so quickly and I certainly didn't expect them to do it out for the back of a random TikTok video. But I later learned that the Parks Department has been trying to get rid of this for years. It's been on the
被淘汰的名单上。所以发布那个视频要么是时机极其巧妙，要么就是他们彻底摆脱它所需的最后一把推力。是的。当这件事发生时，你是什么感觉？就像，我不知道，感觉如何？我至今还是不敢相信这座城市的效率能这么快。这简直太有摩西的风格了。我本来想说，你觉得得需要一个罗伯特·摩西式的人物才能动作这么快，因为那真的太快了。所以这几乎可以说是“摩西式的”。我本来想说，你觉得得需要一个罗伯特·摩西式的人物才能动作这么快，因为那真的太快了。
chopping block for years. So putting out that video is either really good timing or the last push they need to get rid of it for good. Yeah. And what did you think like when that happened? Like, you know, I don't know, how did it feel? I still can't believe that the city would work that fast. It's almost Mosesian. I was gonna say you think it would take a Robert Moses type figure to work that quickly because that is that fast. So it's almost Mosesian. And it's, I was going to say, you think it would take a Robert Moses type figure to work that quickly because that is very fast.
那，那快得太疯狂了。内心深处，我不相信是那个视频起到了作用。我对纽约市的运作方式以及它的运作速度持如此怀疑的态度，我不相信在一个月前发布的视频能促使他们把这些装饰拆下来。它甚至不可能病毒式传播到那种程度。不过关于这一点我倒不这么认为，
That's, that's insanely fast. Deep down, I don't believe that it was a video that did it. There's, I'm so skeptical about the way New York City works and at the speed that it works, that it can't be a video that was put out a month before that would encourage them to take this, take these decorations down. There's no way it would even go that viral. I don't know about that though,
因为正如我们在书的后面会看到的，通常当摩西受阻时，是因为有人能够在恰当的时刻引起媒体或足够多的媒体的注意来从中阻挠。感觉这可能是一件已经列在“找时间处理”名单上长达50年的事情。
because as we'll see as we get further in the book, oftentimes when Moses is stymied, it's because somebody is able to get the attention of the media or enough of the media at just the right moment to get in the way. And it feels like perhaps this was something that for 50 years had been on the, let's take care of this list.
然后你的视频成了这样一个契机，他们心想：噢，有人注意到这个了。现在我们真的得处理一下了。就像，这就是我们一直以来都想做的那件事，现在真该去做了。我觉得你不应该贬低自己的作用，因为你应该为此感到自豪，你知道的，即使你并不是导致这些雕塑被拆除的唯一因素。你知道，我认为你绝对参与其中了，我会这么说。
And then your video was the moment where they go, oh, somebody noticed this. Now we really have to take care of it. Like, this is, we should really do this thing that we've been meaning to do for all this time. I don't think you should undercut what you did because it's like, take pride in it, you know, even if you weren't the only thing that led to these being removed. You know, I think you were definitely a part of it, I would say.
我很难为此感到自豪，因为我身上的历史学家属性会想：你怎么能为抹去一段历史而感到自豪呢？嗯。但我至今仍在为此纠结。不过罗伯特·卡罗为这本书做了大量的研究。而我并没有，我没有看到其他人谈论过这些猴子具有种族歧视色彩，也没有看到任何其他相关文档。我拍那个视频是基于一个消息来源的话。对我作为一个历史学家来说，这是一个很大的疑点。是的。
I struggle with taking pride in it because the historian in me is like, how could you be proud of erasing a piece of history? Mm-hmm. But I still struggle with this. But Robert Carroll did extensive research for this. And I haven't, I haven't seen anyone else talk about the monkeys being racist or any other documentation of that. I made that video off of the words of one source. To me as a historian, that's a big note. Yeah.
是的。你说得对。我刚才说你应该感到自豪，确实有点草率了。你说得对。我当时没考虑到这一点。但我据以得出结论的消息来源是罗伯特·卡罗。他可能是史上最伟大的研究者。所以如果我要盲目相信任何人，那一定是他。这就是我参与移走这段历史所能得到的唯一慰藉了。我的意思是，这很有趣。
Yeah. You're right. I was too quick when I said you should be proud. You're right. I wasn't thinking about that. But the source that I'm basing this off of is Robert Frick and Kara. Probably the greatest researcher of all time. So if I'm going to take anyone at face value, it should be him. So that's my only solace in being part of removing this piece of history. I mean, this is interesting.
所以，就像，我的意思是，确实有人在争论，也许从那以后，有人认为，也许，我不知道，那些只是栅栏上戴着脚镣的猴子的完全无辜的雕塑，而且哈林区跟50年前相比是一个完全不同的地方，甚至比他制作这个雕塑的时候还要久远，那是在30年代吗？30年代或者，是的，大概是30年代后期吧？
So, like, I mean, they're definitely people who have argued, I think maybe since then, that maybe, you know, like, I don't know, they're perfectly innocent sculptures of shackled monkeys up on the grates, that also Harlem is a really different area, 50 years ago than it was, or even longer than that, when he did this, it was in the 30s? 30s or, yeah, late 30s, I guess it would have been, right?
在某种程度上，这种背景可以为摩西洗脱恶意。我的意思是，你对此怎么看？我不知道，我不知道我对此怎么想。我的意思是，我有我的看法，但当有人说“你又怎么能猜透这个男人的意图呢？这也不是他职业生涯中唯一一件看似带有种族歧视色彩的事”时，你是怎么想的？确实如此。他可没拿过多少全美有色人种协进会（NAACP）的奖项。在别的聚会上，他可能会说：你知道吗？在这件事上我们还是给他点受益疑罪的宽容吧。
And in some way that that context exonerates Moses from this being sort of ill intent. I mean, what do you say to that? I don't know, I don't know what I think about it. I mean, I have my opinion about it, but what do you think when somebody says, well, how could you guess the intent of this man? It's not like Doug's the only seemingly racist thing
是的，完全正确。很难对他抱有这种宽容，因为他的黑历史实在太多了，至少在对待黑人这件事上是这样。
he's done in his career. That's true. He was not winning many NAACP awards. At other parties, he'd be like, you know what? Let's give him the benefit of the doubt on this one. Yeah, so exactly. It's hard to give them the benefit of the doubt because track record isn't so great, at least when it comes to black people.
嗯，我只是觉得这是一个非常有趣的时刻，你以这种方式与历史产生互动。你喜欢向人们呈现它，它促进了改变和有趣的讨论。这不只是那种“耶，让我们把一切都拆掉”的讨论。这是一场关于深思熟虑、
Well, I just think this is an intriguing moment of you sort of engaging with history. You like presenting it to people, it like facilitating a change and a discussion that's interesting. And it's not like just like, yay, like let's remove everything discussion. It's a discussion about thoughtfulness
与环境互动以及环境是否仍然适合所有人的讨论。我只是，我深受启发并且对此感到好奇，我太喜欢这是由你这个像个疯子一样在30天内读完《权力掮客》的人所引发的了。就像我们这些读过三遍的专业人士，却不会以这种方式……
and like engaging with the environment and does the environment still work for everybody? And I just was, I was so sort of inspired and intrigued by that, that I just, I love that it came from you reading the Power Broker like a crazy person in 30 days. Like we're professionals who've read it three times and in this way like that.
我不建议在30天内读完它。你觉得呢，当时是什么感觉？我觉得对于那些可能正在努力啃这本书的听众来说，听听有这种经历的人的分享可能会有所帮助。在一个月的最后读完整本书时，是什么感觉？你感到骄傲吗？你感到头晕目眩吗？就像你已经不知道今年是哪一年了一样？当你读完后，你是怎么打发时间的？“头晕目眩”是个很好的词。说实话，我头晕目眩了好几个月。
And I do not recommend reading it in 30 days. Did you find, what was the feeling like? I feel like it might be helpful for someone who's had this experience to talk to our listeners who might be pushing through the book. How did it feel at the end of the month having read it so quickly? Were you proud? Were you dazed? Like you didn't know what year it was anymore? How did you fill your hours when you were done? Dazed is a very good word. I felt dazed for months afterwards, to be honest. I felt like my head was swimming. I felt like I was seeing the world with brand new eyes afterwards. And I was very insufferable to the people around me. I would not shut up about the power broker. I would shut up about Robert Moses. I'm so grateful for my fiance putting up with me
我感觉自己脑子里一直在转。我感觉自己之后是用一双崭新的眼睛在看世界。我对周围的人来说简直难以忍受。我嘴里不停地念叨着《权力掮客》。我停不下来地谈论罗伯特·摩西。我非常感谢我的未婚夫容忍了我好几个月。但我就是无法停止看到摩西对纽约市一切事物的深刻影响。嗯。是的。而且，我经常走他修的那些主干道，这也无济于事。我总是开在FDR大道上，总是开在西区高速公路上，
for all these months. But I couldn't stop seeing Moses' effects on everything in New York City. Mm-hmm. Yeah. And it doesn't help that I take a lot of his major roadways all the time. I'm always on the FDR, I'm always on the West Side Highway,
不是作为司机，而是作为坐在车里被载着到处跑的人。所以这真的很“罗伯特·摩西”。是的，这正是他设想的使用方式，由别人开车接送。所以，但是如果你，作为一个历史学家，一个热爱纽约的人，如果你拥有像摩西那样的权力，你会做些什么来改变这座城市？我会立即把2号线和5号线延伸。你说的是再延长一英里。再延长好几英里，打个响指立刻一路延伸到杰里森海滩（Gerritsen Beach）。
not as a driver, but as one being driven around. So it's very Robert Moses of me. Yeah, that's the way he intended it to be used, being driven by someone else. So, but if you, as a historian, as a person who loves New York, like if you had your Moses-like powers, what would you do to change the city? Immediate extension of the two five lines. You say like one mile further. Several miles further, all the way down to maybe Gerritsen Beach with a snap of the finger immediately.
所以这其实对改变我的生活没有太大帮助。但即便如此。它能帮到所有人。也就是世界上未来的希洛们。是的，会受到巨大影响。太棒了。是的，再也没有人冒着风雪步行一英里去地铁站了。
So that wouldn't do much to change my life. But still. It would help all those people. The future Shilas of the world. Yeah, it would be greatly impacted. That's great. Yeah, no one else walking in the snow and the wind one mile to the subway station.
这太有道理了。我最喜欢你的一个视频是，你坐在地铁上，脑子里在想：如果罗伯特·摩西对公共交通的热爱能像他对公路和汽车的热爱那样深，那该多好。这座城市出行将会变得多么不同、多么轻松。我觉得在所有的历史中
That makes a lot of sense. One of my favorite videos of yours is where you are sitting on the subway and you're just thinking about what if Robert Moses had loved mass transit as much as he had loved roads and cars. What a different, easier city it would be to get around in. And I feel like that of all the historical
这非常合理。我最喜欢的你的视频之一，就是你坐在地铁上，脑子里在想，如果罗伯特·摩西对公共交通的热爱能像他对道路和汽车的热爱那样多，那该有多好。那将是一个多么不同、出行多么便利的城市。我觉得，在所有历史中
what ifs that put the finger on the biggest one for me in terms of Moses, not just like what if he had built this thing or what if he hadn't built this thing, but what if he had grown up loving trains the same way he grew up loving the idea of cars? Just how different, if he was like Walt Disney, who loved trains all his life, what would, how different would the city be? I was so wrapped up in Caro's depiction of Moses that it never even occurred to me like,
那些“如果当初”让我对罗伯特·摩西斯有了最深刻的思考，不仅仅是“如果他建造了这个”或者“如果他没有建造那个”，而是“如果他从小就热爱火车，就像他从小就热爱汽车那样呢？”这会有多大不同？如果他像华特·迪士尼那样，一生都热爱火车，那么这座城市会有什么不同？我之前完全沉浸在卡罗对摩西斯的刻画中，以至于我甚至从没想过……
oh yeah, he might've liked trains if he had given them a chance. So I really appreciated your putting it so simply. Yeah, I mean, who doesn't like trains? Trains are so cool. I mean, I just, every time I'm in another city with my kids and the whole family, like we went to the whole family,
哦，是的，如果他给过火车一个机会，他可能会喜欢上它们。所以我真的很感激你把它说得这么简单。是的，我的意思是，谁不喜欢火车呢？火车太酷了。我是说，每次我和孩子们还有全家人去别的城市，就像我们去全家……
like me and my wife and our six children, we went to Tokyo recently. And I'm just like the whole time, I'm just like, see how you can get around, see how amazing it is, you know, like, it just feels so good, you know, and it's like cool and like air conditions and beautiful, there are clean bathrooms everywhere and just like, how could you not be inspired by this?
就像我和我妻子还有我们的六个孩子，我们最近去了东京。我一路上都在想，你看大家是怎么出行的，看它是多么神奇，你知道吗，那种感觉太棒了，你知道的，既凉爽又有空调，还很漂亮，到处都是干净的洗手间，简直就是，你怎么能不为此受到启发呢？
I like, it just blows my mind that like a good functioning train system is just like, it just, it feels, it's so much cooler than any other alternative in my opinion. I just, I don't, I don't even, I just don't get it. We got to go back in time and make that case to young Robert Moses and maybe, maybe, maybe things will be different. Just give him like a little model train, a little train book as a kid. You just like start them off.
我喜欢，这简直让我大开眼界，一个运转良好的列车系统就是这样，它感觉，比我所知道的任何其他替代方案都要酷得多。我只是，我甚至，我就是不明白。我们得回到过去，把这个道理讲给年轻的罗伯特·摩西斯听，也许，也许，情况就会不同了。送他一个小模型火车，一本小火车书作为童年礼物。你只需这样引导他。
You wouldn't have to go back and like the kill baby Hitler's sort of variety of, of intervention. No, no, no, no, just inspire him with a choo choo set. Just leave train little model trains at his door, like surprise, tooth fairy presents. Oh, New York would be so different. Oh my goodness. This, this is, this is the sort of sci-fi fantasy book we should write about life.
你不需要像去杀死婴儿希特勒那样，采取那种形式的干预。不，不，不，不，只需要用一套呜呜叫的小火车去启发他。只要把火车小模型留在他的门前，就像牙仙送的惊喜礼物一样。哦，纽约将会变得多么不同啊。哦，天哪。这，这，这就是我们应该写的关于生活的科幻奇幻小说。
You could just inspire children to do different things. Well, Shiloh, thank you so much for all you're doing, like in terms of just educating the public and your videos and stuff. And thanks so much for being on the 99% visible breakdown of the power broker. It was a real delight to have you. Thank you.
你只需启发孩子们去做不同的事情。好吧，希洛，非常感谢你所做的一切，无论是为了教育公众还是制作视频。也非常感谢你参加《99%隐形》对《权力掮客》的深度剖析。很高兴你能来。谢谢你。
This was an honor. I've been a long time listener since I was in college, I think. and on the 99% visible breakdown of the power broker. It was a real delight to have you. Thank you. This was an honor. I've been a long time listener since I was in college, I think. So this is amazing. Thank you so much for doing it. Thank you so much. Next month, we're going to cover chapters 35 through 38. That's pages 807 through 894.
这真是个荣幸。我想我从大学起就是一个老听众了。因此，能参与《99%隐形》对《权力掮客》的深度剖析，我感到非常荣幸。非常高兴你能来。谢谢你。这真是一个荣耀。我想我从大学起就是个老听众了。所以这太棒了。非常感谢你参与节目。非常感谢。下个月，我们将讨论第35章到第38章。也就是第807页到第894页。
But if you just can't wait that long, if you just can't wait a month to hear me summarize something, then why not check out The Flophouse, my bad movie podcast over on the Maximum Fund Network where me and my friends Dan and Stuart will be talking about some bad movie in probably as much detail as we talk about the power broker on this show.
但如果你等不了那么久，如果你等不及一个月来听我总结内容，那为什么不去看看《The Flophouse》呢？这是我在Maximum Fun网络上的烂片播客节目，我和我的朋友丹（Dan）和斯图尔特（Stuart）会在那里讨论一些烂片，其详细程度可能不亚于我们在本节目中讨论《权力掮客》的程度。
We had a great time during our AMA on Discord last week. Thanks everyone for showing up. Keep an eye out on the Discord for more details about our special talk with Robert Caro at the New York Historical Society to celebrate 50 years of the Power Broker. We cannot wait. Robert Caro, in New York City, we're gonna be there.
上周我们在Discord上举办的AMA（问答活动）非常开心。谢谢大家的出席。请密切关注Discord，了解我们关于在纽约历史学会与罗伯特·卡罗进行特别对话的更多详情，以此庆祝《权力掮客》出版50周年。我们迫不及待了。罗伯特·卡罗，在纽约市，我们一定会去的。
I will tell you the absolute truth. I am missing an Iron Maiden concert for this. I planned months ago that I was gonna go to this Iron Maiden concert for this. I planned months ago that I was going to go to this Iron Maiden show. It's not going to happen because I'm going to be there with Robert Caro and I'm only a tiny bit sad to be missing that concert because I'm going to be with Robert Caro. And make sure you get your Power Broker merch. It would be very cool to fill the Historical Society's event space with a bunch of Power Broker breakdown band t-shirts. I mean, to be, I'm gonna
我跟你说实话。为此我错失了一场铁娘子乐队的演唱会。几个月前我就计划好要去看这场铁娘子乐队的演唱会了。几个月前我就计划好要去看铁娘子乐队的演出。这去不成了，因为我要去和罗伯特·卡罗在一起，而且我只有一点点难过自己错过了那场音乐会，因为我要和罗伯特·卡罗在一起。请务必买一份《权力掮客》的周边商品。如果历史学会的活动空间里挤满了穿着《权力掮客》解析版T恤的人，那一定会非常酷。我是说，为了，我将
be wearing a suit. And see, Robert Caro, he's gonna be dressed to the nines too. I don't know, maybe we should all dress up. I'm not sure. Anyway, all I know is when I'm in New York, I will be very, very disappointed if I don't see someone in a Power Broker t-shirt. The 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Power Broker is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by Comiti, music by Swan Real, mix by Dara Hirsch. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Cathy Tu, our senior editor is Delaney Hall, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, the rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Martín González, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Dawn,
会穿着西装。你看，罗伯特·卡罗也会盛装出席的。我不知道，也许我们都该盛装打扮一下。我不确定。总之，我只知道当我在纽约时，如果看不到有人穿着《权力掮客》的T恤，我会非常非常失望。《99%隐形》对《权力掮客》的深度剖析由伊莎贝尔·安杰尔（Isabel Angel）制作，科米蒂（Comiti）剪辑，音乐由天鹅真实（Swan Real）创作，达拉·希尔希（Dara Hirsch）混音。《99%隐形》的执行制片人是凯茜·图（Cathy Tu），我们的高级编辑是德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall），库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监，其余团队成员包括克里斯·贝鲁布（Chris Berube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney）、马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martín González）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·雷（Vivian Ley）、拉什玛·唐（Lashma Dawn），
Jekyll Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find the show on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server where we have fun discussions about the power broker, about architecture, about movies and music, about not getting credit for the New York Times like we deserve.
杰基尔·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jekyll Maldonado Medina）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、尼娜·波图克（Nina Potuck），还有我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）设计。本系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分，目前总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区上城，在潘多拉大楼向北六个街区的地方。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站上找到这个节目，也可以在我们的专属Discord服务器上找到我们，我们在那里就《权力掮客》、建筑、电影和音乐，以及为什么我们没有像应得的那样在《纽约时报》上获得署名等话题进行有趣的讨论。
It's where I'm hanging out most these days. You can find a link to that Discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Reading the sections about Robert Moses' interaction with Fiorella LaGuardia, something inspired me to do a search on their birthdays and their astrology signs. I'm not even an astrology person. I don't even really believe in that. But I discovered that they're both Sagittarius.
这正是我最近经常闲逛的地方。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到该 Discord 服务器的链接以及 99PI 以往的所有单集。在阅读关于罗伯特·摩西斯与菲奥雷洛·拉瓜迪亚互动的章节时，某些内容启发我去搜索了他们的生日和星座。我甚至都不是一个迷信星座的人。我甚至不怎么相信这个。但我发现他们俩都是射手座。
For some reason, that makes so much sense to me. A lot of it has to do with being stubborn, and I'm doing the negative traits, but stubborn and reckless and selfish and very self aggrandizing, as well as being big dreamers. And reading those was like ding ding ding ding ding. They both have those traits. So no wonder they butted heads so frequently. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不知为什么，这让我觉得非常合理。这很大程度上与固执有关，我说的都是负面特质，但他们既固执、鲁莽、自私又非常自大，同时也是伟大的梦想家。读到这些时，就好像叮叮叮叮叮一样。他们俩都有这些特质。难怪他们会如此频繁地针锋相对。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。